Scholastic audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 14, The Dangerous Gift, by 2ET
Sutherland, read by Shannon McManus.
The Lost Continent Prophecy.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire. to
the land across the sea, where dragons
are poisoned and dragons are dying, and
no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book, a
secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive.
Face a great evil with talons united
where none of the tribes will survive.
Prologue.
Sortell blanked awake in a haze of
smoke.
Smoke clung to the air and filled his
nose.
Even the savannah grass seem to still
have wisps of smoke clinging to its
blades.
There were dragons all around him.
Hundreds, maybe 1000s of dragons, that he
didn't know any of them.
They were all lying in the tall grass, and
on the other side of the smoky sky, he
could see the blurred outline of the
sun.
The last thing he remembered was falling
asleep at night, in the jungle, next to
blue and cricket and sundew.
Before that, he could remember lying
there, listening to the carnivorous
plants rustle and slither nearby, thinking
about the battle to come.
He remembered watching Blue rub his
wrists nervously at the spots where his
flame silk glowed in the dark.
Flame silk.
Fire.
Blue is going to set the bonfire of heart
of salvation aflame, and the smoke would
be the antidote to the breath of evil.
His fire was going to set all the hive
wings free from wasps' mind control.
If it worked, maybe there wouldn't be a
battle at all.
The smoke in the air suggested that there
had definitely been a fire, a much bigger
fire than one pile of roots could have
produced, in fact.
But what had happened?
How did I get here?
He pushed himself up to standing and
winced.
Everything hurt.
His muscles ached as though he'd been
flying for days.
Even his claws felt bruised and sore.
From the sounds of the moaning and
grumbling around him, many of these
strange dragons felt the same way.
He suddenly realized that most of them
were hive wings.
His enemies.
Why am I lying in the savannah, surrounded
by hive wings?
Did they capture me?
If so, they were doing a pathetic job of
keeping him prisoner.
No one was even looking at him.
It wasn't tied up.
He could fly away right now.
Which way, though?
Which way was blue?
Or Luna.
If I could fly to Luna, I would.
So what if there was an entire ocean
between them?
He would find his way there?
To her?
Just as soon as he figured out where in
Pentala he was.
He squinted around. looking for a
landmark.
Even if there was nothing but Savannah
around him, that would be a clue.
But there was something. 2 hives, visible
in the distance, with glimmering webs
stretching between them.
Which meant the poison jungle should be
in the other...
A cloud of black smoke covered the
horizon behind him, reaching from ground
to sky.
Is that the jungle?
And suddenly he had a memory.
A memory of standing beside blue, as
flame silk spiraled out of blue's wrists
onto the pile of roots.
Sortell remembered his own claws
clutching a spear with sharp thorns
twisting from one end.
He remembered staring at the rows of hive
wings, all of them eerily still and white
eyed.
They hadn't moved as he and Blue
approached the pyre.
They hadn't swarmed forward to try to
stop them.
They hadn't even looked at him.
He remembered now how that had worried
him.
But he'd put his faith in the antidote.
He'd watched the green tinged smoke rise
and fill the air, drifting over the front
ranks of the high wing army, slinking
around his own head, and blues.
And then he'd felt his claws twitch and
sink into the ground.
His wings opened, but he hadn't moved
them.
His head turned toward blue, and his
mouth moved, and something that wasn't
him spoke through him.
Two little silk wings.
All for me, just what I always wanted.
And one of them a flame silk.
So nice when a plan sprouts exactly the
way it's supposed to.
Blue had stared back at him, his talons
also firmly planted.
The leaf wings flying down from the trees
would not have been able to tell that
there was anything wrong.
Only Swordtail could see the panic in
Blue's eyes.
Only the 2 of them knew that they were
paralyzed inside their bodies, controlled
by someone, or something else.
It felt like the tox in the hive wings
used on misbehavors way prisoners, but
worse.
The rest of his memories came flooding
back.
The smoke spreading over the leaf wings
Sequoia and Belladonna and Nettle, caught
by the breath of evil, just as Sortell
was, Blue's talons turning toward the
jungle, his fire burning it all down.
Soartell crouched into the savannah grass
trying to breathe.
It was morning now.
They must have spent the whole previous
day scorching the poison jungle.
He remembered being in the squadron that
was sent to gather all the breath of evil
from its hidden lair before the fire
reached that area.
He also remembered searching for the rest
of the leaf wings.
The thing inside him had driven him
relentlessly through the crackling
smoking trees, looking for sundew and
cricket, and the young leaf winged
princess.
That was probably why he was so sore and
singed and scratched up.
It was a miracle he hadn't been eaten by
a frantic dying plant along the way.
But he didn't remember finding any leaf
wings.
Sortell jumped to his feet, ignoring the
pain in his talons.
He's fun, searching the savannah around
him.
Hundreds of hive wings, a few leaf wings
but nobody he recognized.
No sundo.
How had she escaped the smoke by the
battlefield?
Oh, wait.
She hadn't been there when Blue went to
burn the roots.
He didn't know where she'd gone.
But maybe that meant her mind hadn't been
taken over.
And if they'd searched all day for her
with no luck, maybe she'd really escaped
along with cricket and the rest of the
leaf wings who hadn't been near the
smoke.
Where could they be?
He lifted one talon gingerly, then the
other.
He was controlling himself right now.
His head felt curiously light.
As if it had been caught in the grip of
someone's talons all night, and they just
released him.
Cautiously.
He started walking through the grass
toward a flicker of bright blue wings
near one of the shrubs.
Blue?
If he could find blue.
They could fly away together.
Maybe the mind control had been
temporary.
Or maybe it didn't work over long
distances.
Maybe they could fly out over the ocean
as far as they could possibly get, and
escape its clutches that way.
It was blue.
Sortell could see soot smudged along
Blue's face and limbs and wings, but it
was unmistakably him, asleep, with his
brow furrowed in worry.
Sortell was a few steps away from his
friend, when his legs suddenly froze.
He felt a chill sweep through him, all
his scales shivering away from believing
that they'd been taken over again.
Nice try.
His own voice whispered.
His wings folded in, and he dropped to
the ground, stuck in place, trapped.
So close to blue, but so far from
himself.
She has me in her claws, he thought.
But she can't read my mind.
She can't stop me from thinking.
Or hoping.
Blue and I may be stuck here.
But I believe sundoo and cricket
escaped.
Maybe they went to find Luna.
And if they did, I know they'll come back
for us.
They'll find a way to set us free.
We just have to survive until they do.
Part one.
Blizzards and buried magic.
Chapter one.
The youngest queen in the history of the
Ice Kingdom was going to be the very best
queen of the Ice Wings ever.
Ever ever.
The best.
She was going to keep all her dragons
safe.
They were all going to be healthy and
prosperous and safe, and no one was going
to die of any more evil magic plagues
like the one that killed the previous
queen.
No one.
Not on her watch.
Queen Snowfall had a plan, or at least
she had a firm death grip on an idea that
was kind of like a plan.
That plan was, stay away from other
dragons.
No more getting involved in other tribes
stupid wars.
No more summits with queens who talked
down to her, or eyed her as if she might
be the one to start the next war.
No more interactions with Nightwings
ever.
None of this intertribal, peace talk
empathy building drum circle nonsense.
Ice Wings were a great tribe.
They didn't need any other tribes.
Those subjects of hers who wanted to go
explore, to meet other dragons, and study
in their perilous flammable schools.
They needed to be stuffed into igloos
until they came to their senses.
Her counsel had talked her into letting a
few ice wings go to Jade Mountain Academy
for now.
Instead of using her excellent igloo
plan.
There had been so much alarming
enthusiasm for the idea of connecting
with the other tribes.
Why?
was her question.
How could anyone even want to be around
strange dragons after what had happened
to their tribe?
She was hoping the students they'd sent
would come back with stories about how
terrible the academy was, and that by
then, all the other curious ice wings
would have forgotten about ever wanting
to leave.
No, in Snowfall's vision of her reign, all
ice wings would stay in the kingdom, where
she could keep an eye on them.
Other dragons would stay out of the
kingdom, and there would be no more
dealing with tribes that weren't them.
It was a good plan, a straightforward
plan, a nice, safe, brilliant plan, Except
for the problems.
Problems like queens who kept sending her
messages about alliances and trade and
building more schools like Jade Mountain
Academy.
Shut up, Queen Ruby, go away, Queen Glory
deal with your own stupid dragons, Queen
Thorn.
Problems like the ice wings on her own
council, who wanted to meet with the
night wings and try to build a bridge
over centuries of violence and hatred.
After the blast of magic empathy that had
ended their last battle.
Problems like not knowing exactly where
everyone was, and having to wonder
whether the missing dragons in question
had left the ice kingdom or were still
lurking around somewhere, maybe plotting
some cold blooded murder.
Most urgent, though, was the problem that
100s of strange dragons were apparently
flying toward her shores at that very
moment.
You're sure they aren't night wings?
She demanded again.
Her scout managed not to sigh, but she
could tell that he wanted to, which was
very disrespectful, and maybe she should
have him punished.
Wasn't that what a fierce, powerful very
best queen ever would do?
Punish dragons for disobeying her, or
thinking about disobeying her, or making
faces as if they were trying not to make
faces?
I could see flashes of different colors
from their scales.
He repeated.
I promise you, my queen, mostly green, but
many, many other colors as well.
No black dragons.
They're not night wings.
Snowfall paced from one corner of the
balcony to the other.
They were high on one of the tallest
spires of the palace, with the wind
whisking pellets of ice all around them.
The sun was low in the sky off to the
west, painting the clouds gold and orange
as it sank into the sea.
She knew they were out there, but no
matter how fiercely snowfall glared at
it.
She couldn't see any dragons flying out
of the sunset.
She wondered if Nightwings had found a
way to disguise their scales.
Maybe Dark Stalker wasn't really gone
even though all those not ice wings at
the Jade Mountain Academy promised he
was.
Maybe he was still out there, and he'd
come up with a way to turn night wings
into multicolored rainbow dragons, and
then he'd sent them far out into the
ocean to fly in an enormous arc so they
could come at the ice kingdom from the
west and avoid the great ice cliff, and
soon they would be her to kill her and
her entire tribe.
This was not far-fetched freaking out.
This was completely reasonable, justified
freaking out.
Her scout was looking at her as if he
thought she might be losing her mind
though.
She had to put her queen face back on, and
act as if an invasion of alarming rainbow
dragons was the sort of thing excellent
queens, such as herself, could easily
handle.
No problem.
Well, if they're not night wings?
What are they?
She asked.
He hesitated, and she answered her own
question.
Rain wings?
I mean, rain wings.
Of course.
That's the only tribe with many colors, so
perhaps with sea wings?
Those can be green.
It's probably a group of rain wings and
sea wings.
Why would rain wings and sea wings form
an alliance to invade my kingdom from the
west?
Her brain screamed.
Coral and Glory have betrayed me.
They decided I'm too young to be queen
and they're coming for my throne.
Which is very unfair because glory is the
same age as I am and she's queen of 2
tribes.
All right, Queen Glory probably wasn't
coming to depose Snowfall because of her
age.
See?
Her brain could figure that out.
And so it was, ipso facto, working
perfectly reasonably, and that meant all
these other worries were entirely
legitimate.
Also, the rain wing tribe hadn't invaded
another kingdom in literally 100s of
years.
They hadn't even participated in the War
of Sandwing Succession.
All they wanted to do was snooze around
the rainforest eating papayas.
They would be an utterly useless invasion
force.
If Glory did want to invade another
kingdom, she'd have to do it with her
night wings, who liked attacking and
killing and stabbing and violence and
lying and destroying things.
So maybe glory found a way to turn night
wings into rainbow dragons, and sent them
this way, and so they are night wings
after all.
Snowfall rubbed her head, which was
throbbing as though someone had shoved
icicles through her temples.
I don't think.
The rain wings and sea wings would attack
us, the scout said cautiously.
Is your job thinking?
Snowfall shouted, making him jump.
Are you an expert thinker?
Did we accidentally assign you to
scouting?
Because we missed your giant, amazing
brain, and all the amazing things?
It could have shared with us?
Does it seem likely that your thinking
would interest me?
No, Your Majesty, he stammered.
No, she agreed.
You are a scout.
Go scout again and come back with real
actual information.
He flew away immediately, and then she
spent 7 minutes worrying about whether
she'd been too harsh with him, and
whether an excellent queen would have
said any of that, and whether a certain
sister of hers would have been more
serene, and therefore more excellent, and
then another 12 minutes growling at
herself about how excellent queens didn't
2nd guess themselves, and how she needed
to be more decisive, and then she
realized that she was accidentally
thinking about murdery black dragons
trying to murder her again.
And she had to lie down and cover her
face for a moment.
When she finally sat up, her aunt Tundra
was standing in the doorway of the
balcony, watching her with impassive
raised eyebrows.
Hello.
Snowfall said haughtily.
I was definitely not panicking.
I was resting my eyes in a very normal
queenly fashion.
I do not need to explain myself.
I am the queen, and therefore, whatever I
do is queenly, no matter what her
eyebrows think.
Good evening.
Said her aunt.
It is time for the wall.
Of course it is, Snowfall said.
How marvelous.
My favorite part of the day.
Tundra had a face that repelled sarcasm.
No matter what snowfall said, no matter
her tone of voice, it all slid right off
that frozen expression.
Tundra inclined her head slightly, and
held out the jeweled box that contained
the ice wing crown.
As a little dragonet princess, Snowfall
had looked forward to wearing the crown
her entire life.
Diamonds, sparkles, power.
Everything she'd always wanted.
Until the moment it officially became
hers, when it became clear what Queen
Snowfall had had to lose to get it.
And now it was her least favorite thing
in the world.
Well.
Maybe Tundra's face was her least
favorite thing in the world?
But they usually came together, so she
could hate them both simultaneously.
Snowfall opened the box with an irritated
sigh and lifted out the glittering
diamond encrusted monstrosity.
Spiraling spikes like icicles jutted up
into the air, around a cluster of
crystalline jewels and twisted silver
arches.
It weighed as much as a small polar bear
and made her neck hurt the moment she put
it on.
But she couldn't let tundra see that.
She tipped her chin up and flared her
wings to usher her aunt ahead of her.
Everyone says the war is over.
Everyone says Dark Stalker is gone.
Everyone says the night wings won't
attack us again.
But everyone could be wrong.
The night wings can't be trusted.
They want me dead.
They want all of us dead.
If I could find a way to wipe them all
out first, I should.
Tundra's necklace of sky wing teeth
clicked noisily as they strode through
the palace.
Snowfall pressed her talons to her eyes
for a moment, trying to drive the
headache away.
Being the queen, it turned out, was like
living inside a snowstorm that never
ended.
She tried so hard to start each day all
new, with a list and a plan and energy.
She'd get so much done.
Each new problem was a mere snowflake.
She could tackle them one by one.
Little, sparkly, quick melting problems.
Except the snowflakes piled up faster
than she could fly.
Sparkles on sparkles on fluff on ice, on
cold, on heavy, wet layers of slush and
freezing clumps.
And by night, she was buried far below
them.
And then, every night, just when it was
all too much.
Her Aunt Tundra would appear with her
cold marble face, and that meant it was
time for the wall.
According to the ancient tradition of the
tribe.
Every night, the queen of the ice wings
had to consider the wall that listed
every important dragon in the tribe, and
then she had to adjust the rankings of
all the dragons in the aristocracy.
Every night.
His idea was this?
Snowfall had always considered the wall
known as the gift of order, to be one of
the best magic things in the kingdom.
She used to wake up before the sun and
soar down to the courtyard to see where
her name was each morning.
She loved watching the word, snowfall
climb higher and higher as she worked and
trained and studied, until she was at the
very top of the dragonette's side of the
rankings.
And there it stayed.
Moon after moon.
Apart from that unfortunate blip when her
cousins messed everything up for a few
days.
But then winter was gone, and Hailstorm
moved over to the adult wall, and
snowfall was in her proper place at the
top again, and it was excellent to look
at.
Best Dragonette in the whole kingdom, the
wall reassured her, morning after
morning.
You are doing great.
Even your mother thinks so.
She put you right here at the top because
she sees how undeniably great you are.
Sometimes it felt like a secret message
from Queen Glacier.
Like, don't worry, I remember you, even
though we haven't been in the same room
in a while.
I am quite pleased to have a daughter
like you.
I appreciate that you are not
embarrassing me.
It wasn't like that now.
The wall did not tell Snowball.
She was undeniably great anymore.
It said, well?
And make some decisions, and stop
tithering.
And a good queen would have no trouble
with this.
And what happened to being the best queen
ever?
Why are you such a disaster?
There were no more messages, unspoken or
otherwise, from her mother.
Now the word snowfall was set apart, in
its own little queen corner, off by
itself.
Now the task of reordering the rankings
every night was her job, and Snowfall had
begun to suspect that the gift of order
was less a gift, and more an act of
twisted revenge.
Some queen must have angered her anima
somehow, and he or she had responded by
crafting this torture device, perfectly
designed to drive ice wing queens insane
for the rest of time.
Once upon a time, Snowfall had thought
she would love this part of being Queen.
The fate of all her dragons in her own
talons, the power to lift up those most
loyal and knock down her enemies.
But it didn't feel like power.
It felt like work, pinning her down like
the weight of the crown.
Icy rain drizzled down, as snowfall
stared up at the wall of rankings.
The light globe floating over her
shoulder lit up the names in front of
her.
Behind her, the 3 moons illuminated the
snowy courtyard.
Silver, empty, cold and wet, speckled
with weird shadows from the light tree.
Empty.
Only 20 ice wings had died of the plague
only, +13 more in the battle with the
night wings, but since snowfall became
queen, the palace had felt as empty as if
the entire tribe had vanished into thin
air the day Queen Glacier died.
The entire tribe, that is, in addition to
the one sister who had actually
vanished.
Maybe the rest of the ice wings
deliberately made themselves scarce
whenever they saw her coming.
Maybe that was always what it was like
for a queen.
Well, Tundra asked smoothly.
Who are you going to move?
Yeah, agreed the wall.
Your mother never took this long.
Snowfall's head hurt.
Her teeth hurt.
Why did her teeth hurt?
Every night?
She had to do this.
Even when she had much more urgent crises
to deal with than the hierarchy of palace
dragons.
Such as the dragons that were coming
across the ocean right at this moment
preparing to tramp their dangerous talons
all over her snowy kingdom.
She wished she had a list of their names
and an entire history of their tribes, and
an explanation for their behavior, and an
outline of what they were planning to do
when they got here, plus a battle
strategy for getting rid of them.
Tundra cleared her throat.
Right.
The wall.
Snowfall adjusted a heavy crown on her
aching head.
She couldn't remember even seeing half
these dragons today.
How is she supposed to know whether they
deserve to move up or down?
When everyone avoided her or spoke to her
in polite monosyllables.
Where was she supposed to hear about the
squabbles, mistakes, outrages, or
triumphs in their freezing little
aristocratic world?
How did mother always know everything?
Snowfall glanced sideways at her aunt?
Tundra had lost her husband, Norwhal, and
the ice wing night wing battle.
One of her children lived in exile, and
another was in prison awaiting trial
while the 3rd was recovering from a very
bizarre magic spell.
Snowfall didn't know quite what to think
of Hillstorm these days.
He seemed rigidly perfect on the outside
and all melted together on the inside.
Tundra looked exactly the same, though.
Snowfall never saw a hint of sadness or
rage or resentment in her face.
Even though they both knew perfectly well
the tundra had always hoped her daughter
Icicle, would take the throne from
glacier before snowfall could.
Never going to happen now.
Snowfall thought.
After all those years of competing.
Suddenly, I'm the queen, and icicles
locked in the dungeon for being a traitor
and none of it was up to me in the end.
She lifted her chin.
Act like a queen, all the time, no matter
how much your teeth hurt.
Hellstorm could go up a notch.
He had annoyed her at all today. and it
would please Tundra, so perhaps she'd let
Snowfall cut this short without too many
more changes.
Snowfall stabbed her claws into
Hellstorm's name and dragged him up a
spot.
She left Tundra's name where it was.
Safely in the 1st circle ever since
narwhal sacrificed himself to save the
new queen.
She also left Crystal up among the top 10
names, even though she could feel Tundra
glaring at it intently every night.
Wherever Crystal was, she was still a
princess.
She hadn't done anything terrible that
Snowfall knew of.
She wasn't definitely out there trying to
raise an army to steal snowfall's throne
and she wasn't certainly hiding in the
palace, trying to poison snowfall's
food.
She was only maybe doing those things.
Snowfall could knock her down the list
for maybe crimes, even if the maybeness
of them was terrifying enough.
If she left Crystal's name and place.
She hoped it would look as though she
wasn't afraid of her sister at all.
She reordered a few other names, trying
to keep her eyebrows arched in a bored
haughty way.
So easy, this boring task.
Her eyebrows yawned.
Easiest task in the world.
Definitely not, frying all my brain
cells.
Really?
Tundra said once.
As snowfalls lit her uncle permafrost
down a notch for pointing out, again, how
easy it would be for sea wings to invade
from the northern oceanside of the ice
kingdom, a reminder that snowfall really
did not need right now, thanks very
much.
Tundra snapped her jaw shut.
A snowfall glared at her.
Finally, Snowfall stepped back, shaking
her talons.
Her claws felt as if they might shiver
into a 1000000 pieces in a moment.
The wall always made them feel that way
and they were always fine after a while
but it was unpleasant.
That's your final decision, Tundra said
with just a hint of skepticism in her
voice, easily denied if Snowfall had
snapped at her.
Yes.
Snowfall couldn't take another moment of
this.
She had to figure out what to do about
the approaching dragons.
The only other ice wing who knew was the
scout who'd reported it to her.
That animus Sandwing, Jerboa, knew too.
Snowfall had gone to her for a spell to
protect them, but it hadn't been any help
because animus magic was broken, or
Draboa was lying to her, and either way
she was useless.
So Snowfall needed to deal with the
invasion by herself, somehow, although so
far her strategy of pacing around her at
their own room all night, hadn't been
particularly effective.
Even so.
Alone.
That was what she wanted to be.
Or, specifically, somewhere far away from
tundra.
She wrestled the giant crown off her head
and shoved it into her aunt's talons.
Her headache eased a little.
Go away, she snapped.
Now.
Tundra bowed and swept off, leaving only
a faint vibration of disapproval in the
air behind her.
She never said anything obvious to remind
Snowfall that only a few months ago.
Tundra and Narwhal had been practically
2nd in command to Quinn Glacier.
She never even hinted at memories of
their former relationship.
Back then, Snowfall had been so careful
about every word she said, afraid of
offending her aunt and falling down the
ranks as a result.
Snowfall knew Tundra must hate the fact
that she had to bow to her niece now.
And probably Snowfall wasn't helping the
situation by barking at her and ordering
her around.
She couldn't help it though.
She was too overwhelmed by everything
else to add being more polite to Aunt
Tundra to her list.
If there was one upside to being queen
surely it was that she could finally snap
at dragons who deserved it.
Couldn't she?
Maybe she couldn't.
Maybe that was worst queen behavior, not
best queen.
Maybe she was messing this all up every
time she opened her mouth.
She glanced up at the wall again.
The wall didn't say anything.
Of course it didn't.
It was a wall.
But it was clearly thinking about how
civil Queen Glacier always was, and it
was definitely judging her.
This is sane.
It is normal to feel judged by magic
walls.
I am a perfectly sane queen with a well
functioning brain and everything is
fine.
Something snapped in the courtyard behind
her.
Snowfall whirled around and stared
through the icy raindrops.
It all looked the same, pale, icy, wet
weird shadows.
But it wasn't empty.
Someone was there.
Someone was watching her.
Chapter 2.
It's Dark Stalker.
He is here to finish the job of killing
us all.
Or another night wing.
Or crystal.
Definitely a murdery dragon about to kill
me.
Show yourself, Snowfall shouted.
I know you're there.
She inhaled a gust of frost breath, ready
to unleash freezing death on her assassin
and charged toward the tree of light.
A figure moved among the branches, wings
spreading, and snowfall bared her teeth.
Ah, the figure shouted.
Stop. snowfall, it's me.
The dragon tumbled out of the tree and
landed awkwardly among its roots, trying
to stand and bow and duck behind the
trunk at the same time.
Snowfalls get into a stop.
The dragon's scales were white, freckled
with dark blue, not black.
Not a night wing.
The dark blue meant it wasn't crystal
either.
She swallowed her frost breath back down
and lowered her head to squint at the
spy.
Lynx?
Hi, said the dragonette.
Hello, thank you for not freezing me.
Hi, Snowfall.
Queen, snowfall.
Snowfall snapped automatically.
Ling's had been her biggest competition
all through school and training.
At least, Dr. Hillstorm was captured by
Skywings.
She was only the daughter of a minor
noble, but she was hardworking and clever
and good at making teachers like her.
And Snowfall had wanted to strangle her
more than a 1000 times.
Right, Link said, glancing over her
shoulder as though she was already
regretting this conversation.
Queen snowfall.
Sorry.
She didn't sound sorry.
She sounded like she always had
challenging snowfall to races around the
palace, or arguing over points of ice
wing law in class.
Snowfall narrowed her eyes.
Lynx was still a year away from moving to
the adult wall, and without snowfall, or
any of the cousins left on there, Lynx
had been sitting easily at the top of the
dragonette list.
But snowfall could move her down.
Snowfall could flick her all the way into
the 7th circle if she wanted to.
Snowfall was the queen now.
Deciding that lynx was a disrespectful
nobody who deserved to be squashed back
into her place, was absolutely Snowfall's
job.
What are you doing here?
Snowfall demanded.
Are you spying on me?
A normal dragon?
With a healthy fear of punishment?
Would have denied it immediately.
But Lynx made a rueful phase, spread her
wings and said, I am, actually.
What?
You are?
Snowfall's gal, Datter.
Why?
Is she working with the Nightwings?
Or the invading dragons?
Or crystal?
Or all of the above?
Or writing to my cousin Winter about what
a terrible job I'm doing?
They were always too friendly, those
two.
Maybe she's convinced him to round up a
bunch of ceilings to attack us.
I don't know why, but it's possible.
Because I'm worried about you.
Ling said frankly.
Snowfall.
Are you all right?
Snowfalls?
Entire brain?
Stopped working.
It just rolled over and lay there.
Suddenly full of nothing to say after
months of nonstop yelling about
everything.
Her mouth was all, hello, any thoughts?
And the response was apparently, nope
just flap around like a bewildered walrus
for a while.
Snowfall?
Link said after a moment.
Are you, did I break you?
She reached out and tapped lightly on
Snowfall's forehead.
Nobody tapped on the queen's forehead.
Snowfall jumped back and stared at her.
Nobody asked if the queen was all right
either.
She had never been asked that question
and certainly not since she became ruler
of the whole Ice Kingdom.
Of course, I'm all right.
She snapped.
I am the queen.
Those 2 things don't necessarily go
together.
Links observed.
I think maybe the opposite, actually.
Why don't you think I'm all right?
Snowball demanded.
What are you trying to say?
Do you think you'd be better at this than
me?
Oh my goodness.
Length edged away a step and looked even
more concerned.
Not even remotely.
I never want to be queen.
The correct answer?
Snowfall said in an icy voice, is no
snowfall.
You're doing amazing.
You are doing amazing.
Lanks cried.
See?
Now I don't believe you.
Snowfall wrenched a globe off the tree
and batted it up at one of the windows
that overlooked the courtyard.
Some aristocrat was going to wake up in
the morning and be very confused about
why he had a 2nd light globe bobbing
gently around his room.
Links watched it sail over their heads.
Then returned her gaze to Snowfall.
I'm just worried about the fact that the
only dragons you ever get to talk to
anymore are old and bossy and kind of
mean.
Snowfall let out a snort.
That certainly described the Council of
Powerful Ice Wings who'd nominated
themselves to guide the new young queen.
Some would say, I'm bossy, and kind of
mean too, she said to Lynx haughtily.
Oh, you are, Ling said, which was not the
correct answer either, but that means you
need to order some kind, agreeable
dragons to hang out with you.
Once that won't make your brain hurt all
the time.
Like you, I suppose?
Snowfall asked.
How does she know that my brain hurts all
the time?
No.
No, Link said.
I'm not agreeable at all.
You'd be like, fetch me a narwhal, and
I'd be all, why?
narwhals are heavy and I'm reading.
And you'd say, but I want one right now.
And I'd say, then go get one, bossy tail
and you'd bellow, I am your queen, and
I'd be like, yes, but this book is at a
really exciting part, though.
And then you'd probably have me
executed.
I'd be so irritating.
You already know this about me.
How do you know that my brain hurts all
the time?
Snowfall blurted.
I mean, that is, what makes you think
that my brain hurts all the time?
Well, Ling said carefully, flicking her
tail.
You haven't stopped frowning since the
beginning of the plague.
That would give anyone a headache, I'd
think.
And my brain is always tired?
When all we have to do is study and train
and stay at the top of the Dragonette
rankings.
You have to do all the queen stuff.
And, you know, also the, The sad bit.
No, no.
Snowfall's damped right over Lynx's last
words.
No time for that.
I can handle all the queen stuff.
I'm not a lowly noble like you.
I can do everything just fine.
This is what I've been preparing for my
whole life.
Sure, but there was supposed to be more
of a whole life 1st.
Lang's pointed out.
Like, a couple more decades at least, I
imagine.
You don't know that, Snowfall said.
Maybe I was planning to challenge mother
for the throne like next week anyway.
Because I'm so already ready to be
queen.
The light from the tree was too bright
and she could feel her eyes watering.
She turned to pace back to the wall
rubbing her face with one talon.
A couple more decades with mother as
their queen.
Maybe longer.
That was what they should have had.
That was what dark stalker stole.
She hadn't really had a plan for
challenging her mother anytime soon.
She thought there would be plenty of time
ahead of them before she had to worry
about that.
Or that certain sisters would get there
1st.
I guess I don't know, Link said, catching
up to her.
And walking beside her instead of a few
steps behind.
How had this dragon done so well in her
exams?
Did she not know any royal etiquette at
all?
I guess, Links went on.
Maybe it had to be sooner because you
needed to challenge her before icicle did
right?
Or someone else?
Maybe it's better this way.
With her giving you the throne instead of
you having to take it?
I could have taken it.
Snowfall is shorter.
Anytime I wanted to.
She remembered Queen Glacier lying on her
deathbed, gripping one of Snowfall's
talons and staring intently up at her.
She remembered her sister's watching from
the queen's other side, Crystal's eyes
glittering in the blue twilight.
Manx sobbing.
I will not have our tribe suffer the fate
of the kingdom of sand.
Glacier breathed between spasms of
coughing.
There will be no war of ice wing
succession.
Do you 3 understand me?
Mink nodded frantically, although, at age
two, she knew almost nothing about the
war. and probably couldn't even name the
sisters, Blister, Blaze, and Burn, that
she and Crystal, and Snowfall, might
become.
We promise mother, Crystal said, in her
frail, slippery, sweet voice.
They were all sick at that point, although
they didn't know yet that the plague came
from Dark Stalker's magic.
But Crystal had draped herself in
diaphanous scarf fails, that managed to
make even the plague look glamorous.
Nobody wants another war.
Even though Crystal had actually fought
in the War of Sandwing succession.
She hadn't come back noticeably tougher
or more aggressive.
She actually seemed a bit less there.
She kept staring out of windows and
losing track of conversations, probably
thinking about all the deaths she'd
witnessed, Snowfall guessed.
She could easily believe that Crystal
didn't want the tribe, or especially
herself, to face any more battles.
We'll just fight each other, Snowfall
said.
We won't drag anyone else into it.
A normal duel, over in a day.
Could I be crystal in a fight?
Maybe right now, while she's sicker with
a plague than I am.
Crystal was 3 years older.
Slightly taller, a little lazy, and a bit
of an overthinker.
Snowfall could probably use those last 2
to her advantage.
Do I really have to kill her though?
Snowfall didn't know if she could handle
one more dead ice wing.
She didn't know if her claws could add to
the death toll.
Mink sniffled, and snowfall felt a small
lurch in her chest.
Mink wouldn't want to be queen, would
she?
Surely she wouldn't try to be in the
duel.
No, Glacier snarled.
She crushed Snowfall's wrist in her
talons with painful ferocity.
You will not fight each other.
I am going to choose the next I swing
queen.
Crystal rubbed the edges of her wings
together, a nervous habit that made a
jittering sound, which drove Snowfall
mad.
But Crystal started.
But that, that's never.
You must swear on the spirits beneath the
ice, Glacier said fiercely.
Whoever I choose to be queen, the other 2
will support her.
You'll help her save the tribe and keep
the peace.
No duels, no fighting, no war.
Do you understand?
Snowfall glanced across at her sister's.
Of course, mother would choose crystal
the oldest, the calmest, the one other
dragons liked.
Crystal had never clawed her way to the
top of the rankings like Snowfall, but
she didn't seem to care even half as
much.
To swearing this oath means snowfall
would have to give up on the throne
forever.
For how long?
she asked.
I mean.
Tradition says no one should challenge a
new queen for the 1st month of her
reign.
Is that what you mean?
Or for longer?
Longer, glacier raft.
The tribal need stability after this
plague.
If any of us survive it, was the unspoken
murmur under her words.
So...
Snowfall studied crystals bowed head for
a moment.
A year?
Glacier sighed, a sad whisper of wind
across a frozen lake.
I don't want you 3 to fight, she said
closing her eyes.
Ever.
I won't, Mink cried.
She climbed up onto the bed with her
mother and crept under Glacier's wing.
I won't ever hurt them, mommy.
I promise.
I love them, and I love you, and we'll
all be really good.
Crystal lifted her gaze and met
Snowball's eyes.
Hers were clear blue as the sky, and
snowfall couldn't read them at all.
Was she angry that their mother was
asking them to break centuries of ice
wing tradition with a promise like this?
Or was that look of triumph, knowing that
if she agreed, Snowfall would never be
able to take her throne.
Else swear too, Crystal said.
No fighting.
Whatever you want mother.
Snowfall.
Glacier said.
Snowfall felt as though sharp talons were
waking the words out of her throat.
I swear, she choked out.
I'll support the new queen.
I won't challenge her.
For now, her brain couldn't help adding.
Four.
A while, at least.
She tried to shut it off, but it kept
whispering.
Maybe one day.
Good.
Glacier opened her eyes again, and tucked
Mink in closer with her wing.
She reached for the glittering diamond
crown on the side table.
The next queen of the ice wings is
snowfall.
That is final.
A shocked numbness seized snowfalls
scales, spreading out to her wing tips
and tail.
She felt the heavy weight of the crown
settling down around her temples.
Crystal's face was unreadable, a blur
over mother's shoulder.
Me.
She chose me.
I'm the next queen of the ice wings, not
crystal.
She thinks I'd be the best queen.
Is she right?
What if she's wrong?
Now, I'm the one who has to protect us
from the night wings.
And I'm the one who has to find a cure
for this plague before any more dragons
die.
Queen Snowfall.
Crystal bowed to snowfall with a swoop of
her wings, murmured something like
congratulations, and excused herself to
check on something in the kitchens.
She was beside the bed again, veiled and
coughing.
When Queen Glacier died later that
night.
Shortly after the queen told snowfall, far
too late, about the animas who might be
able to save them.
But the next morning, Crystal was gone
and Snowfall hadn't seen her since.
So, one could see why she might find that
worrying.
She cut a suspicious glance at links.
Do you actually think it's better?
That I'm queen.
You don't wish it was?
Someone else instead?
You mean crystal?
Lynx asked, saying the quiet part loud
again, like an absolute beluga.
I don't know her very well.
She had just left for the war front when
I came to the palace.
Whenever I did see her.
I got the impression she was hiding
something.
Isn't everybody?
Snowfall said with a snort.
Links scrunched up her snout and thought
for a second.
I'm not.
You were spying on me, Snowball pointed
out.
Sure, but not very well, lengths argued.
Snowfall was tired of being rained on.
She turned away from the wall and went
through the nearest archway, shaking her
wet wings over the icy floor.
It was marginally warmer inside the walls
of the palace, but it would still take a
while to feel dry.
Lynx followed her into the ballroom, where
a pair of servants was changing the faded
light globes in the chandeliers.
They took one look at the queen, or maybe
at the queen's thunderous expression, and
fled through one of the upper balconies
their task only half finished.
Snowfall frowned after them.
Well, I don't know crystal.
Lang went on, but I knew Queen Glacier
and she was brilliant.
She chose you.
That's good enough for me.
That's it?
Snowfall rounded on her with a hiss.
So you don't think I'm actually good
enough to be queen?
If it were up to you, it wouldn't be me.
You're only supporting me because my
mother thought it was a good idea. 3 moon
snowfall.
Lynx took a step back.
I'm sure you'll be a good queen, except
maybe if you have a meltdown because all
the dragons around you are awful, and you
yell at anyone who tries to be nice to
you.
Oh, is that what this is?
Snowfall said.
You're being nice to me?
Thank you so much.
That's just what I needed.
See, you're being sarcastic, Lang said
but it is what you need, walrus breath.
You can't call the queen a walrus
breath.
Snowfall shouted.
It's not allowed, and it's not nice.
Where are my executioners when I need
them?
You don't have those, Ling said, with a
distinct lack of concern in her voice.
Hey, I know what would help.
Wanna go for a swim?
No, I obviously don't want to go for a
swim.
Snowfall yelled, even though swimming had
once been one of her favorite things.
She wondered if Links had actually
remembered that.
I don't have time for that kind of
nonsense.
I am ruling a kingdom right now.
Not that you've apparently noticed.
But don't you need a break?
Leng asked.
I think it would make you feel better.
Snowfall Dugger claws into the ice below
her.
I don't have time to feel better, she
said through gritted teeth.
My sister has gone into hiding, probably
so she can kill me.
Animus magic is broken, so I can't use it
to fix anything, and there are 100s of
evil mystery dragons flying directly at
our border. right the heck now.
They will probably be here by tomorrow.
To do something nefarious.
I don't know what, but probably involving
murder.
When am I supposed to fit a leisurely
swim into all of that links?
Link stared at her.
Blinking fast for a long moment?
Well, she said finally.
No one said it had to be a leisurely
swim.
Executioners!
Snowball bellowed.
Great eye spirits, snowfall, take a
breath.
Links grabbed one of snowfalls
gesticulating talons and gripped it
between hers.
Tell me about the 100s of evil mystery
dragons.
That is tough secret information.
Snowfall said haughtily.
Not for insignificant dragonettes to
know.
But you clearly need to talk about it
Links pointed out.
Just tell me, and I promise I'll keep it
a secret if you want me to.
Words started spilling out of snowfall
against her will.
Hundreds, she said.
Hundreds of strange dragons, on their way
here, right now.
I got that part, Link said.
That's all the information I already
have.
But do you mean real dragons?
Not paranoid made up hypothetical
dragons?
Snowfall began to swell with indignation
and Links jumped in before she could
start yelling again.
All right, sorry, just checking.
I believe you.
Hundreds of mystery dragons.
Um, from where?
I don't know.
Snowfall cried.
That's the problem.
One of the problems.
Maybe Crystal went to get an army to
destroy me.
Maybe the night wings want to finish what
they started with the plague.
Maybe Carl and Glory have formed an
alliance, and decided to take me down.
But...
Why would they do that?
Links asked.
Because everyone is evil.
Snowball shouted.
She yanked her talent out of Lynx's
grasp.
Snowfall.
Everyone just got out of a war.
None of the queens in Pyria want to get
back into another one.
Listen, listen.
How do you know about the 100s of
dragons?
One of my scouts, Snowfall said.
He was out scouting the Western Ocean and
saw them coming from a distance.
They landed on an island out there, but
he said they were regrouping to fly again
soon.
Length scrunch up her face in a thinking
hard expression, that snowfall knew very
well from years of sitting next to her in
class.
From a distance?
Across the Western Ocean?
Her eyes went suddenly wide.
Three moons, snowfall?
What if they're from the lost continent?
How have you ever beaten me on a test?
Snowfall demanded.
Does your brain even work at all?
The lost continent isn't real.
It's a myth.
Unless it is real, and we're about to get
100s of visitors to prove it.
Links was nearly dancing on her claws
now.
Snowfall wanted to drop a mountain on
her.
That is not better, Snowfall shouted.
Dragons from a whole other continent?
Invading my kingdom?
They must be coming to steal our land and
treasure.
What if they have extra murdery
superpowers we've never even thought of?
Or weird diseases?
Links?
What if they have weird diseases that
will kill us?
We can't worry about all of that until it
actually happens, Ling said with an, I'm
so practical expression, that made
Snowfall feel like screaming.
Yes, we can, Snowfall cried.
I'm worrying about all of it right now.
Okay, Lang said.
Sure.
But maybe they come in peace.
Snowfall's scales wanted to leap off her
and go running up the walls, shrieking or
exploding or whapping into everything.
She couldn't even hold all the things
inside of her that might go horribly and
dramatically wrong.
Snowfall, Link said.
She folded her wings forward around
Snowfall's head like a dome of white
curtains, and looked into Snowfall's
eyes.
It was impertinent, but it cast an
irresistible stillness around them.
Queen, snowfall.
Snowfall reminded her.
It was kind of peaceful not to be able to
see the palace.
This was what she wanted for the whole
tribe.
A wall of solid scales around them
blocking everything else out.
Queen snowfall. links echoed.
You said they'll be here tomorrow?
So let's fly to the western coast and
meet them.
Let's find out who they are and what they
want before we panic.
I mean, bit late for that, clearly, but
we can save the more epic panicking for
when we actually know something.
We, Snowfall said.
Meaning me and my whole army.
Meaning, you and me, Link said, and one
guard, if you must.
Terrible plan.
Snowfall said.
The worst.
I hate it.
Great.
Links granddadder.
See you at the front gate at dawn.
She trotted away, like a dragon with no
worries in the whole world, and snowfall
was left, staring into the walls of the
palace, pale shimmering blue drizzled
down through the translucent ice
reflecting the weather outside with
phosphorescent magic.
The gift of elegance, crafted by a long
ago animus with no sense at all.
Why couldn't it be a gift of
invincibility?
Or a gift of unlimited, every queen gets
magic now, or a gift of crush your
enemies with one thought.
It was so unfair, and deeply suspicious
that animus magic stopped working, exactly
when Snowfall found out about Cherboa.
She should have had at least one animus
gift.
She had so many great ideas.
Didn't animus dragons know about the
danger from other tribes 2000 years ago?
Was the one who made the great ice cliff
the only smart one?
Suddenly a thought hit her, a thought so
brilliant.
It made her gasp.
There were other animus dragons before we
lost Prince Arctic, other gifts.
She knew where she needed to go.
The forbidden treasury.
Chapter 3.
Most of the ice wing treasure, including
Snowfall's awful crown, was kept in the
regular treasury, a guarded vault close
to the center of the palace.
But there was another treasure, one known
only to a few, and spoken of in
whispers.
It was buried in an ice cave deep below
the palace, and the only way to get there
was through a secret passage from the
Queen's own rooms.
No one but queens and princesses, had
been down there in 100s of years, or
perhaps ever.
Only the queens and princesses, were even
sure it was real.
Had it been conjured by an animus
sometime long ago, a gift of secrets?
Or did a queen in their ancient past once
order workers to carve out the cave and
the passage with their own claws?
Snowfall didn't know.
She didn't think her mother had known
either, although now she wished she had
asked more questions.
At the door of her royal chambers, a tiny
dragonette was sitting between the
guards.
Her eyes were large and dark blue, and
her scales were white, with feathery
patterns of gray along her wings, like
whiskers, or tufts of fur.
The guards had clearly been chatting with
her, but they snapped to attention as
snowfall approached, and the little
dragon scrambled to her feet as well.
Hi, Snowfall, Mink blurted.
Um, um, um, I made you something.
She reached into a small pouch slung
across her back and brought out a tiny
block of ice carved with great care into
as far as snowfall could tell, a blob.
Make gently placed it into snowfalls
talons with an expression of bashful
pride.
Oh, uh, thank you.
Snowfall turned it around a few times
wondering which end was up.
It's...
Great.
It's a mink, her little sister said.
Like me.
But um, an actual mink?
Not a dragon mink.
See the whiskers?
And the ears?
Sure.
Snowfall said doubtfully.
It's just to say, I love you, Mink said
shyly.
This would have been sweet, if it weren't
for the fact that Mink loved literally
everyone.
Snowfall was pretty sure every dragon in
the whole palace had at least one of Manx
I love you gifts.
The queen's room was still cluttered with
them.
Miniature unidentifiable ice sculptures
on every surface.
Snowfall hadn't seen her tiny flipperty
gibbet sister very much since becoming
queen.
There were dragons in charge of her
education and training, and Snowfall
assumed they had carried on since Queen
Glacier's death, the same as they had
before.
Manx life shouldn't have worked very much
at all.
Well, thank you, Snowfall said, aware of
the guard's eyes on her.
Now, I'm very busy, so.
Oh, can't I please come in?
Mink pleated.
I miss mommy's room.
Snowfall frowned at her.
You miss her room?
I slept in there sometimes when I
couldn't fall asleep, Meg explained.
That figured.
Snowfall would never have dared to crawl
into her mother's room in the middle of
the night.
It was highly against the rules, and
would almost certainly have gotten her
knocked down a few spots on the wall.
Training herself to go back to sleep
alone was part of being a 1st circle kind
of dragon.
But that wasn't the kind of thing Mink
worried about.
If she weren't everyone's beloved
princess, she'd probably be stuck in the
6th circle her whole life.
You can sleep in there now, Snowfall
said.
It's my room.
She had enough trouble sleeping without
adding a fidgety little snuggle lizard
into the situation.
I know, Mink said, her wings drooping.
I just want to see it again.
Snowfall side.
If she sent Mink away now, these guards
would probably tell everyone in the
palace that she'd hurt her sister's
feelings.
Not an excellent queen move for sure.
Besides, she should probably know about
the forbidden treasury.
Queen Glacier had taken Snowfall down
there only once, when she was 4 years old
and she done the same with Crystal 3
years before that.
But not mink.
She was still too young.
I should show it to her With crystal
gone?
If anything happens to me.
This secret could be lost forever.
Snowfall shivered.
It was extremely strange to think of
little mink as her sole heir, even
stranger to think that snowfall should
teach her how to be queen, just in case.
Snowfall wasn't cut out to be a patient
teacher, and Mink definitely wasn't cut
out to be a ruthless queen.
All right, come in, Snowfall said
grumbly.
Mink squeaked happily, and bounded into
the room ahead of her.
Nobody else is allowed in for the rest of
the night.
Snowfall ordered the guards.
Did that sound cool and calm or strange
and paranoid?
Wasn't this a perfectly normal thing for
a queen to command?
The guards expressions were impassive
unmoving.
What were they thinking about her?
Did they find her queenly or ridiculous?
In the main chamber, the bed dominated
the center of the room.
A block of ice carved into whorls and
drifts, where a dragon body could fit
perfectly.
As snowfall shut the doors, Mink leaped
onto the bed and wriggled around, looking
ridiculously comfortable.
The truth was, snowfall still hadn't
slept in her mother's bed.
She couldn't stop thinking of it as her
mother's bed.
She wasn't sure how she ever would.
Most queens killed their predecessor on a
battlefield, or in an arena, or before
the whole court in a blood stained throne
room.
They didn't watch them slip away into
darkness, in the very spot where they
then had to fall asleep for the rest of
their lives.
It was just as comfortable up on top of
the jewel cabinet anyway.
Or on the polar bear rug by the window, or
in the icy bathtub in the next room.
Fine, nowhere at all was comfortable, but
that was fine.
Queens didn't complain about their
sleeping quarters.
Real queens probably didn't need as much
sleep as regular dragons anyway.
Off, she ordered her sister.
I have to show you something.
Mink hopped off the bed immediately.
Her eyes wide.
Snowfall braced her talons against the
spot at the foot of the bed, the one her
mother had shown her, and pushed.
The bed slid aside soundlessly, revealing
a hole underneath that plunged into
endless darkness.
Wow, Mink breathed.
Wow, oh wow.
Why is there a hole in the floor?
I never, ever knew there was a big hole
under the bed.
It's a secret for queens, Snowfall said.
Mink's face fell.
Oh, she said.
Not from me then.
Well, Snowfall said reluctantly.
It could be for you, one day.
If anything happens to me and you have to
become queen.
What?
M cried.
No, I don't want to be.
What's going to happen to you?
Nothing.
Snowfall said.
I'm going to be clean for ages and ages.
But you should see it anyway, just in
case.
Hang on to your light globe and follow
me.
She clasped her own light globe in her
front talons, spread her wings, and dove
into the chasm.
The walls glittered around them as they
spun down and down and down, until soon
all she could see above and below them
was darkness.
Finally, her light reflected off a smooth
glassy surface at the bottom of the hole
several heartbeats away.
She banged her wings and slowed to a
gentle drift until she felt her claws
touch down.
A little thump behind her, announced to
the arrival of her sister a snowfall
released her light globe to drift over
her shoulder once more.
Oh my gosh, 0 my gosh.
Mink whispered, trying to crawl under one
of Snowfall's wings to press against her
side.
What is this place?
Teaching her little sister about royal
secrets was one thing.
Snuggling was quite another, and
definitely not on her list of queen
responsibilities.
Snowfall wiggled away, and took a step
into the dark corridor before them.
This is the forbidden treasury, she
said.
You must never tell anyone where it is or
how to get here.
There are secrets down here, and magic
that only a queen can use.
She realized she'd slipped into her
mother's voice, echoing the words Queen
Glacier had said to her on this very
spot.
I won't tell, Mink breathed.
I promise, promise.
The walls around them were blackest ice.
Gleaming with silvery filaments and
bubbles when the light hit them.
Snowfall led the way to the passage
spiral.
It coiled in on itself like a snail shell
with alcoves cut into the eyes at eye
level every few steps.
Well, eye level for an older dragon.
They were slightly above snowfall's head
but she could stretch her neck up and see
into them.
Everything was too high for mink to reach
without flying.
The 1st 2 alcoves were empty.
They had been when Snowfall visited with
Glacier too.
She didn't know what had been in them, or
if they'd been left empty in anticipation
of gifts that had never arrived.
Thank you, night wings.
Her light glittered off something
shimmery in the 3rd alcove, and she
paused.
It was a tiara, delicate and elegant.
Much lighter and smaller than her hideous
crown, and prettier too.
Hmm.
She nudged the light globe closer to the
wall, where words were carved into the
ice.
The gift of strength.
Use cautiously.
Ooh, strength sounded promising.
This would definitely be useful.
Would it make the whole kingdom stronger
somehow?
Or specifically just whoever wore the
tiara?
Snowfall thought for a moment, then
lifted out the tiara, and placed it
carefully on her head.
Nothing dramatic happened.
She felt the same.
It fits so comfortably she could hardly
tell she was wearing it.
She glanced down at Mink.
What do you think?
The little dragon's eyes were shining.
It's so pretty.
She breathed.
Can I try it on?
No, no, definitely not.
Snowfall said quickly.
Everything down here is only for queens.
You can look, but you can't touch, all
right?
Mink's face fell, and her wings drooped
on either side of her.
Snowfall turned away quickly before she
could see any tears in her sister's
eyes.
Come on, let's see what else there is, she
said briskly.
She trotted forward, and she heard Mink's
tiny claws scrambling on the ice to keep
up.
The next alcove held a scepter, carved
from some dark blue rock, with little
diamonds set into it.
Snowfall disliked it immediately.
It reminded her of night wings.
The gift of compromise.
Read the inscription.
No, thank you.
Snowfall thought furiously.
She didn't read the rest of the carved
words, which covered half the wall under
the alcove.
Compromise was not what the ice wings
needed.
They needed a strong queen, who could do
impressive, giant, scary magic things
like maybe shoot lightning bolts from her
claws, or suddenly grow to 3 times her
size, or flick her tail and make it rain
poisonous scorpions.
Compromise indeed.
Make fluttered her wings to get high
enough to see the scepter, but snowfall
was already whisking away.
Not useful, she called. striding to the
next alcove.
This one held a ring.
A weird looking ring.
It had a milky, pink, gold, white, green
opal set into the center of it, and the
rest of the ring looked like silver
dragon tails, winding around the opal, and
the space where a dragon's claw would
go.
Snowfall studied it for a moment.
The opal was kind of mesmerizing.
The more she looked at it, the more
flecks of different colors she could see
in it.
This one said, The gift of vision.
No other notes.
Well, that was pretty straightforward.
Better vision?
Snowfall would take that.
It wasn't as useful as strength or
scorpion hail, but maybe it would help
her see the mystery dragons from much
farther away.
Maybe she'd be able to identify them long
before they hit the shores of the ice
kingdom.
She lifted it out, and slipped it on one
of her front left claws.
It was a bit too big, as if it had been
designed for a bigger older dragon.
A real queen.
Snowfall side.
Shut up, brain.
Stop thinking like that.
This is my gift now.
That makes me a real queen.
She stormed onto the next alcove, which
was empty.
Whatever had been written underneath, had
been violently scratched out sometime
long ago.
Snowfall wondered if there was any
explanation in one of the old ice wing
history books.
Not that she had time for history right
now.
Three moons.
After that was an alcove that seemed to
have been added later.
It wasn't at the same distance from the
others, and it looked hacked out of the
ice instead of beautifully carved.
The item inside looked like an unwearable
mystery piece of silver.
The scribble scratch writing underneath
said, part of the gift of understanding
which was weird.
Part of?
Where was the rest?
And not helpful either.
Bah, humbug understanding.
Snowball was getting nervous.
The walls were spiraling in tighter and
tighter. soon they'd be at the end.
Wasn't there anything down here that
could destroy an invading army with one
swoop if she wanted to?
Absolutely useless animus idiots.
The next treasure, though, looked a lot
more promising.
Pale silver wristbands set with diamonds
and underneath.
Snowfall read the inscription and
smiled.
Well, it's not exactly what I wanted.
But it'll definitely give those invading
dragons quite an unwelcome surprise.
Chapter 4.
Snowfall arrived at the front gate at
dawn with 5 guards, because she was the
queen, and she did what she liked, and
Lynx didn't get to decide all the
things.
So there.
Links was waiting at the gate, looking
unfairly well rested.
She kind of rolled her eyes at the 5
guards, but she didn't say anything, so
Snowfall didn't have to threaten her face
1st thing in the morning.
They flew south and west along the coast
out toward the farthest peninsula that
reached into the ocean.
The ocean that was supposed to be so big
no one could cross it.
So even if there was a continent full of
dangerous dragons on the other side
they'd have to stay over there.
If Lynx was right, how had they gotten
here?
And why now?
Why would they arrive right when I've
just become queen?
Did they hear about me and decide to
invade because they think I'm young and
useless and I'll be easy to defeat?
She gnawed at these questions as they
flew and the sun rose higher, setting the
snow below them into a dazzling blaze of
sparkles.
It was so beautiful and pure out here.
All these untouched snow drifts
stretching out below them.
No murder plots, or magic plagues, or
untrustworthy dragons anywhere to be
seen.
You look tired, Link said after a little
while.
That's treason, and no, I don't.
Snowfall snapped.
Did you sleep at all?
Lang asked.
Did Snowfall ever actually sleep?
Or did her brain just slide a little
underwater?
Where the worries were blurrier, and
night wings stalked around in the dark
trying to kill her.
Did it count as sleeping when she woke up
more tired than she'd been before?
Could she even call it waking up?
When it felt more as though all her
worries suddenly became so pressing that
her eyes flew open.
The arrival of dawn only seemed to shove
her from a drifting haze of nebulous
problems, straight into a blistering ice
storm of them.
Last night, she hadn't even tried.
No, she answered length.
I was very busy.
Length tilted her head.
Doing what?
You might find this hard to imagine
Snowfall said.
The queens have a lot to do, actually.
But... when everyone else is asleep?
Length asked again.
What did you do specifically?
Snowfall tipped her wings to catch an air
current?
Last night, specifically?
I visited the treasury.
She knew Lynx would think she meant the
regular royal treasury.
And then I spent absolutely forever
trying to make a certain pathetic seal
eyed princess go away, but she ended up
falling asleep on my bed in the middle of
my lecture, which was very rude.
Ooh, the treasury, Lang said.
I thought you looked extra sparkly
today.
Is this to impress the strange dragons?
She flicked her tail at Snowball's
accessories.
Sure, Snowfall said, rolling her eyes.
Wow, oh wow.
I really hope they think I'm extra
sparkly too.
All right, sarcasm face.
Links flicked her tail at snowfall
again.
Then what's all this about?
Snowfall held out our front talons?
Where the diamond crusted wristbands
glittered alongside sleek fitted knife
sheets.
The tiara of strength was perched on her
horns.
The ring of vision was still on the front
left claw where she put it, but so far
she hadn't noticed any improvement in her
eyesight.
Maybe she had to activate it somehow.
If Lynx couldn't guess why she was
wearing all of this, maybe she wasn't cut
out for the new council Snowball was
thinking about after all.
Just as she had that thought, Lynx's eyes
widened.
Wait, she said, lowering her voice, even
though the guards were flying a perimeter
around them, just out of earshot.
Snowfall.
You don't mean the forbidden treasury, do
you?
Are those jewels animus touched?
Snowfall smiled slyly, letting the sun
catch on the opal in her ring.
I'm glad to see your brain does work
sometimes.
But you can't go to the forbidden
treasury.
It's forbidden.
It's right there in the name.
And you definitely can't take things out
of it.
Of course I can, Snowball snapped.
I'm the queen, even though you can't seem
to remember that.
I'm literally the only dragon allowed in
a forbidden treasury.
It's my treasury.
Yeah, but isn't all that stuff forbidden
for a reason.
It's forbidden to dragons who would be
too weak to use it properly, Snowball
said.
Not queens.
And besides, this is an emergency.
And why would we keep stuff like that
around if not for exactly this?
Links tilted her wings, looking puzzled.
An emergency?
You are a very poor listener, Snowfall
shouted.
Animus magic is broken.
No one can cast any more spells.
We can't make anything to protect
ourselves from the invaders.
But...
Hasn't that been the case for like 2000
years?
Links asked.
Ice Wings haven't had an animist dragon
since Prince Arctic.
Snowfall didn't want to tell her about
Jerboa, the difficult sandwing animus
that Queen Glacier had found and formed
some kind of alliance with.
Glacier had told Snowfall to go find
Jerboa, in the hopes that the animus
could stop the plague, but they were too
late.
And, of course, now it turned out, the
sand wing was perfectly useless.
Now, right when Snowfall needed her.
Maybe the invading dragons somehow know
that too, or maybe they froze everyone's
animus magic.
Irrelevant and classified.
She hissed at lengths.
The important part is that I realize we
can use something we already have.
The forbidden treasury is where we keep
our ancient magic from 1000s of years ago
before we lost our animus bloodline.
Back then, every animus dragon made a
gift for the tribe.
I realized, because I am a genius, that
there's a chance one of those could save
us, and I could find it in the forbidden
treasury.
I never saw Queen Glacier wearing any of
that, Link said cautiously.
Maybe my mother was not as brilliant as
everyone thinks. snowfall said.
Maybe if she'd thought of this, she could
have found something in the treasury to
protect us all, and maybe she'd still be
alive.
She tipped her head up until her eyes
stopped watering.
The thought of magic lying under the
palace, forgotten, unused, going to
waste.
It made her claws itch to stab
something.
All right.
So what do all those jewels do?
Lang asked.
I'm not telling you, Snowball snapped.
But you do know.
Links asked nervously.
I mean, you understand each of the things
you're wearing.
You can control them.
Snowfall, Castro, a withering look.
Of course, she said.
Most of them were stored with notes from
the queens who used them.
She squinted at a shape moving below them
but it was only an Arctic hair, and it
looked the same as Arctic hairs always
did from up in the sky.
She'd kind of expected the gift of vision
to actually, you know, do something to
her vision.
Maybe that one was broken.
Lynx didn't need to know about that.
Most of them?
Length squeaked.
A snowfall whisked ahead of her.
She flapped her wings to catch up.
Snowfall.
What if they're dangerous?
They'd better be dangerous, Snowfall
said.
That's the whole point.
There's an invasion on its way here
remember?
We need all the protection we can get.
This is why facing them with an army
would be the best idea.
I think you're just as scary as any army
all on your own, Link said.
Without any magic.
Ha, Snowfall snorted.
I only have like 7 non-magical weapons on
me.
We need 1000s of weapons to drive these
dragons away.
Lynx glanced down at her claws, as if
she'd only just noticed that those were
the only weapons she'd brought.
Really?
Seven weapons?
Yes.
Of course, Snowfall said.
She pointed to the spear on her back.
Spear.
Then to the knives and the sheets at her
wrists.
Knife, knife, then to the sheaves under
her wings, the concealed pockets of her
chain mail armor, and the pouch around
her neck.
Knife, knife, throwing stars, poison.
She didn't mention the other 3 hidden
weapons.
Just in case Links was actually working
for Crystal, or the Night Wings, or had
her own ulterior motives, and was maybe
planning to attack snowfall as soon as
she had her away from the castle
unprotected.
Well, ha, ha.
Snowfall had foiled her with those 5
guards.
And the extra secret weaponry.
And totally being on to her.
Headache again?
Ling said sympathetically.
No, Snowball snapped. jerking her claws
away from her temples.
More like headache always, she thought.
And you're not helping, potentially
untrustworthy dragon.
She spotted a cluster of ice structures
below them, along the cliff that
overlooked the ocean here.
What's that?
One of the outer villages.
Link said.
Where the turns fly, I think.
I should royally decree that all ice
swing villages must have one word names
Snowfall said grumpily.
Her claws still hurt from years of
writing out the list of villages, over
and over again, and labeling them on maps
and writing essays about them.
The time she could have saved, if Hamlet
that worships the whales who sing at
night, had just been called whales.
Not to be confused with where the whales
leave at dawn, of course.
That would be a great royal decree, Lang
said fervently, at least for maps and
lists and essays by exhausted
dragonettes.
Your puny little estate is out here
somewhere, Snowfall remembered.
It is.
Links cast a wistful glance to her left.
It overlooks among the evergreens.
My father lives there, but I haven't been
back in a while.
What is he?
Fifth circle, sixth?
Fifth for the last couple of years, Link
said.
Because Lynx's success at court has
raised him up.
Snowfall guest.
But hang on.
Isn't there some kind of rule that no one
is allowed to talk to the queen about the
wall?
It's fine if I bring it up.
Snowfall said, bristling.
But you can't ask me to change anything
not that I would anyway.
No one else makes my decisions for me.
Oh, good.
Link said.
I was wondering why Tundra and permafrost
had stayed up so high lately, when
they're always so awful.
But now that I know it's entirely your
decision.
I feel much better.
Snowfall glared at her.
That sounded like sarcasm.
Did it?
Links gasped.
Your majesty, one of the guards
interrupted, swooping back toward them.
We think we see something.
Snowfall pumped her wings to shoot ahead
of links.
Catching out to another guard who had
been flying out in front.
She squinted at the horizon, for the
ocean took over from the snowy cliffs.
At 1st she thought she was looking at
clouds.
Ordinary clouds, non-threatening puffs of
fluff in the sky, and then she realized
that the clouds were flickering and
shivering with movement.
Flashes of green and gold and rose and
aquamarine caught the sunlight.
They were clouds of wings, a whole fog of
dragons descending on her kingdom.
The jolt of terror that ran through
snowfall's veins was like being stabbed
with a sandwing tail.
It was like 6 night wings attacking her
at once.
It was like the moment a cobalt blue
hybrid dragon had bowed in front of her
held out a garish earring and said, I am
so sorry I didn't get here sooner, Queen
Snowfall.
I am too late for your mother, but I can
at least save your life, if you put this
on.
This plague, it's a spell.
It was sent by an animus night wing named
Dark Stalker to wipe out the entire tribe
of ice wings.
They're coming to kill us, she said
whisking around in the air and nearly
colliding with links.
Hearing her words, the closest guards
faltered in the sky.
They looked as scared as she felt.
They're not coming to kill us.
Link said.
I mean, we don't know that they're coming
to kill us.
They're probably not coming to kill us.
We're going to find out.
This is a terrible way to find out.
Snowfall protested, as Lynx turned her
around.
It would be much smarter to attack them
with my whole army the moment they land.
No, no, Links objected, alarmed.
That would start things off on completely
the wrong talent.
Listen, it won't take long to get your
army if we need it.
If these dragons do seem dangerous, we
can retreat to my father's estate and use
the mirror signal system to summon
backup.
See?
No need to panic.
Snowball hissed at her.
Yes, fine.
She should probably act less terrified in
front of the guards.
Queens weren't supposed to freak out
about anything.
Queens never panicked.
Mother was never scared.
Not once, not during the war, and not
even when the plague came.
But why not?
is my question.
There are so many things to be scared
of.
Was she secretly this close to falling
apart all the time, like I am?
Did she wonder how she was going to hold
the whole tribe together in this large
cold kingdom after a war with so many
deaths?
Didn't she spend all her time worrying
about how we could possibly survive
against a tribe of dragons who hate us
and who, by the way, have all the magic
powers?
Stop thinking about night wings.
Deal with the brand new mysterious scary
thing.
Nobody is panicking, she said, flicking
her tail.
You're an impertinent net.
Stop annoying me.
She pushed links aside and flew on
ahead.
There was an alarming heartbeat of
stillness from the guards, but then she
sensed them moving into place around her
flying in formation, just as though she
were exactly the right queen doing
exactly the right thing.
Instead of making this all up as I go.
She led them to a cliff. that overlooked
a grove of snow covered pines and a rocky
beach.
Below them, dragons were swooping down to
land.
They were not night wings.
The scout was right about that.
They were not sea wings or rain wings
either.
The green dragons, actually green and
brown and sometimes flecked with gold
scales, snowfall noticed.
Headwings elegantly shaped like leaves.
No phosphorescent markings, and no webs
between their claws.
The other tribe was much stranger.
Their scales were all over the color
spectrum, shimmering pinks, dark violets
pale lavenders, blues, and oranges, and
summery yellows.
They each had 4 wings instead of 2, and
even at a distance, snowfall could see
delicate antennae curling from their
foreheads.
Weird, creepy dragons, she hissed
crouching close to the ground and peering
over the cliff edge.
They must be evil.
They look totally different from us.
So do sandwings.
Could we manage to ally with a bunch of
them during the war?
Links pointed out from beside her.
Every tribe looks a little different, but
none of them are completely evil.
Wrong, Snowfall snapped.
Objectively wrong.
Nightwings are 9000% evil.
Thanksgiver that curious sideways look
again.
Didn't that empathy spell work on you at
all?
she asked.
Didn't you feel what they were feeling?
during our battle with them.
It made the rest of us ice wings hate
them way less.
Why not you?
Snowfall didn't answer.
That moment, in the middle of the battle
when an animus dragon had connected all
the minds of the fighting dragons, ice
wings and night wings together, that had
been one of the worst moments of her
life.
Because threaded through the ice wing
sphere, in dragon after dragon, she'd
found one particular whisper, what are we
going to do without Queen Glacier?
How can snowfall possibly save us from
this?
She's not ready.
She's a smug little monster.
Our new queen is a spoiled dragonette. who
has no idea what to do.
Why would Glacier pick her?
Up until then, she thought maybe the
tribe was proud of her.
Maybe they were glad she was the sister
who'd been chosen.
Maybe they knew how fiercely she would
fight for them.
Maybe when Glacier chose her.
It had convinced everyone that she was
truly a worthy queen.
Apparently not.
And over on the other side, she felt the
night wings triumph too.
Look at their queen.
She's barely old enough to fly.
She doesn't know anything.
We can destroy her easily.
It wasn't the biggest feeling the
battling dragons were all having.
That was fear.
And now that fear was all anyone talked
about.
Night Wings, hey, maybe they're just like
us.
Maybe they're scared of stuff too.
We can totally understand them.
Snowfalls seem to be the only one who
remembered, those layers of doubt under
everything else.
At least no one had ever dared to ask
her.
Hey, did you happen to hear me thinking
about what a terrible queen you'll be?
And she was still afraid of night wings.
The other ice wings were delusional not
to be.
Do you want me to go talk to them first?
Length asked.
Snowfall realized the other dragon had
been studying her face for the last few
minutes.
No, Snowfall growled.
I'll go.
We'll leave 2 guards here in case they
have to fly for help.
She flicked her tail at the 3 biggest
guards to signal them to follow her.
The closer they got, the more Snowfall
noticed how bedraggled all the invaders
looked.
Some of them had singed tails or wings.
All of them were wet and crusted with
salt from the spray.
Most of them were very thin.
Almost all the colorful dragons had heavy
looking metal wrist cuffs around their
front talons.
Why would anyone wear something like that
for a long flight?
Snowfall wondered suspiciously.
They drag you down the whole time.
They must be some kind of powerful
weapon.
Some of the green dragons lived oddly
lumpy until they realized they were each
wearing several woven pouches.
And what's in those, she wondered.
Car stop checks?
What if they have something that can
enchant us to hand over our whole
kingdom?
She touched the diamonds in her armband
sharp edged and cold.
It was comforting to know she had magic
of her own.
Most of the dragons looked up wearily as
Snowfall and the others landed, pebbles
and dice crunching under her claws.
One of the green dragons stood up
frowning, but then another grain dragon
tugged her back down, and a 3rd grain
dragon climbed to her feet, and came to
face snowfall.
Who are you?
Snowfall demanded.
What are you doing in my kingdom?
The green dragon sat down and spread her
wings.
With her front talons raised, palms up.
I am pre, um, Queen Hazel of the Leaf
Wings.
The other dragons traveling with us are
silkwings.
We come from the land of Pantala across
the sea.
Seems like a lot of dragons to bring with
you for a neighborly visit.
Snowfall said.
I'm afraid we need help.
Hazel said, sorrow flickering across her
face.
We were forced to flee our home very
suddenly.
Our jungle was burning, and our queen was
gone.
There is a terrible danger back on our
continent, and if we hadn't escaped, it
would have destroyed us all.
Snowfall could feel the waves of sympathy
radiating off links, who was standing a
little too close to her left.
No surprise that she would fall for any
sad snout story she heard.
But snowfall was smarter than that.
She had a kingdom to protect.
It sounds like you should have stayed and
fought for your land, she said.
We don't have any room for you anyway.
You're going to have to leave, right
now.
Hazel's face fell.
Just wait.
Please.
Let me tell you the whole story.
Something suddenly charged at them across
the sand, shrieking alien syllables.
Snowballs bun toward it, drawing her
knives, and was a tail flick away from
throwing them, when she realized the
attacker was a tiny dragonette.
Like, really tiny.
Let's get it to a stop with a terrified
yelp, staring up at her glittering
weaponry.
Big, black rimmed eyes blinked in a warm
golden face.
Her 4 wings were a little more shimmery
and thinner than most of the others, and
her scales alternated in black and yellow
stripes.
The dragonette burst into tears.
Oh, well done, Your Majesty.
Links whispered to Snowfall.
Excellent self-defense.
Another yellow and black dragon came
hurrying over and wrapped her wings
around the baby.
She wore crooked spectacles, and she
looked absolutely exhausted.
It's all right, she murmured.
Don't cry, Bumblebee.
Look, we made it to the distant
kingdoms.
Can you believe it's real?
Isn't this amazing?
We're here.
We're safe now.
Length, shot, snowfall, uh.
You're going to crush this moment, aren't
you?
Look.
Pibishimmy?
Bumblebee sniffled into the other
dragon's shoulder.
Boutique, awar.
The spectacled dragon looked up and met
Snowfall's gaze.
Her eyes flew wide, and suddenly she
didn't look tired at all.
Oh, wow, she cried.
Our 1st new dragon in the distant
kingdoms?
Isn't she beyond amazing?
Oh my gosh, she looks like she's made of
ice.
I had no idea.
Hello, hi.
Are you actually made of ice?
I mean, you can't be right?
No, you're clearly biological, but how
are you so shiny?
It is very cold here.
Is this some kind of Arctic adaptation?
Cricket?
The one called Hazel said in a warning
tone.
I am trying to negotiate with this dragon
queen.
She is the queen.
Cricket burst out, so excited.
Her words started tumbling over each
other even faster.
Of the whole continent?
Wow.
How many dragons is that?
Do you think this place is as big as
Pantala?
Of the Ice Kingdom.
Snowball interrupted coldly.
I am Queen Snowfall of the Ice Wings.
But no, we're not actually made of ice.
Links whispered to Cricket.
Snowfall glared at her.
Beyond Cricket and Hazel and Bumblebee
Snowfall could see even more dragons
arriving, staggering onto the beach.
There really were 100s of them.
And they landed with such relieved
expressions, as though this was exactly
where they wanted to be, as though it
were just the kind of territory they'd
been hoping to steal.
One of them collapsed, digging his claws
into the snow dusted soil.
Is he sick?
Snowfall wondered, is he contagious?
Another movement made her spin to her
right, but it was only a pair of young
strong leaf wings, helping to drag a silk
wing out of the water.
Do they have magic?
Are they going to suddenly turn violent?
You must leave, she said to Hazel.
She realized she was still holding the
knives she'd brandished to the
dragonette.
She lifted her head regally and sheathed
them.
You are not welcome here.
Go invade Thorn's kingdom instead.
We have several dragons who can't
possibly fly any further right now, Hazel
pleaded.
They're injured, or elderly, or too small
and we've been traveling for days.
Please.
They need to rest.
That's not my problem, Snowfall said.
They're not my dragons.
Snowfall, Link said meaningfully.
They're not, Snowball protested.
I have a tribe to protect.
We are no threat to you.
I promise.
Hazel said.
Snowfall realized the leaf wing queen was
shivering.
Was that fear or exhaustion or cold?
Hopefully cold.
Maybe the temperatures would drive them
out of the ice kingdom even faster than
she could.
If so, maybe letting them stay for one
night would be all right.
If they promised to stay on the beach, and
left 1st thing in the morning.
That's everybody, a brash, familiar voice
announced.
Someone large and blue bounded out of the
ocean.
I mean, except Turtle, but he'll come
wheezing up soon.
Don't worry.
Snowfall gasped.
You, she spat.
It was that awful sea wing dragonette of
destiny who ran the Jade Mountain
Academy.
So this was a sea wing invasion.
Somehow.
And wasn't she friends with glory?
The night wings were probably lurking
nearby, waiting for snowfall to be
distracted by the weird looking dragons
and then they would pounce.
An ambush, an attack, just as she'd
suspected.
Oh no.
Tsunami said, wrinkling her snout and
giving Snowfall a disgruntled book.
We hit the ice kingdom?
I thought we were way farther south.
She sighed and shook out her wings.
Scattering salt water and kelp and tiny
sea snails everywhere.
What are you doing here?
Snowfall demanded furiously.
How dare you come into my kingdom
bringing an enormous throng of suspicious
weird looking strangers.
Get out at once.
We're not suspicious, the one named
Cricket protested.
We're just tired and scared, and running
away from a really scary bad thing.
What do you think we could possibly do?
It's all right, Cricket, Hazel said
taking a step back toward her other green
dragons.
Snowfall noticed that the 1st one who'd
moved was standing up again, frowning
menacingly.
I'd be alarmed if this many dragons
suddenly showed up in my jungle too.
You wouldn't be super rude to them though
I bet.
Tsunami snapped.
Oh, I know, Cricket said.
Wait, Queen Snowfall, we're not total
strangers.
Bumblebee and I had an ancestor from your
continent 100s of years ago.
Doesn't that help to know?
You must have heard of her.
We are descendants of Clearsight.
Out of the corner of her eye, Snowfall
saw tsunami wins.
Snowfall had a strange moment of vertigo
as though the ground under her had
suddenly cracked and sent her sliding
into the dark ocean.
A pulse of fury stabbed through her
temples and out to the tips of her
wings.
The black scales.
The secretive, smarter than you
expressions.
She should have seen it.
These dragons were part Nightwing.
And worse than that, they were related to
clear sight.
Clearside, the dragon who'd helped Dark
Stalker rise to power in the 1st place.
The true love of that mass murderer.
Seething with rage.
Snowfall lifted her wrists and smashed
the diamonds together.
Once, twice, 3 times, just as the
instructions had said.
Behind her, along the top of the cliff
the entire ice wing army appeared.
Chapter 5.
Lynx jumped away from her, startled.
The other dragons, Hazel, Cricket
Bumblebee, Tsunami, and 100s of invaders
Frozen Place, staring up at the
glittering ranks of soldiers, 3 moons.
How did you do that?
Links hissed.
Snowfall tipped the wristbands toward her
smirking the gift of stealth, she said.
According to the notes in the forbidden
treasury, she could use it to hide
herself or anything else she wanted to.
So she'd gathered her army in the night
and prepared them to fly, weapons at the
ready.
She'd tested her new magic toy to make
sure she could hide them, soaring along
behind her.
And there they were.
As though she had pulled them from thin
air.
Now she felt strong.
She felt like a queen.
The strange dragons all look terrified of
her.
So brilliant.
Everything she'd hoped for between the
army and the magic, she'd proven her
power.
They wouldn't dare argue with her
anymore.
Why did mother ever dig these out, she
wondered.
We could have used some impressive ice
wing magic during the war.
She could have hidden her army, or spies
or an assassin to go after burn and
blister.
The gift of stealth could have made us
the most dangerous tribe in the war.
Well, it's time for an ice wing queen
who's not afraid to use all her
resources.
She lowered her voice to its coldest
iciest tone.
I said.
She hissed softly.
Get out.
Hazel's gaze flickered hesitantly from
her to the army to lynx.
Of course, she said.
Well, we'll go.
She took another step back.
There was one dragon who didn't look
terrified, Snowfall realized.
The frowning leaf wing behind Hazel was
bristling, like an angry polar bear about
to charge.
Her tail lashed as she glared back at
snowfall.
The sooner Snowfall got that one out of
the ice kingdom. the better.
What was that?
Cricket breathed, adjusting her glasses
to squint up at the army.
Can all dragons here turn invisible?
What else can you do?
Bumblebee, did you see that?
Sparkle, toothie.
Bumblebee murmured, burying her head in
cricket's shoulder.
All right, all right.
Tsunami grumbled.
She spread her wings.
I might have known we'd land in a worst
kingdom, and the 1st dragon weed sea
would be the queen of grumps.
Before snowfall could bite Tsunami's head
off, Links unexpectedly spoke up.
She is not grumpy, Link said.
She's a great queen, and this is the best
kingdom and nobody invited you here to
insult us.
Hazel had been giving quiet orders in the
background, sending dragons to gather
everyone, but now she paused and touched
tsunami's shoulder before the sing wing
could argue with links.
Can you lead us somewhere else?
She asked.
Yeah, south to the kingdom of sand
tsunami said.
We'll find Luna and Moon there.
And I'm sure Queen Thorn.
We'll know how to treat a group of
harmless tired, sad dragons who've lost
their home.
She's welcome to keep you.
Snowfall snapped. throwing her wings
back.
Tsunami tossed her a disgusted look, and
turned to help organize the dragons for
departure.
South, Snowfall thought suddenly.
If they follow the coast, which they
probably will, so they can rest often.
They might end up flying within range
with a great ice cliff.
Which will promptly shoot them all with
ice beers, even though they'll be flying
over it from the other side.
She hesitated.
That would get rid of the problem
completely.
Those descendants of Clear Sight would be
gone, and she wouldn't have to worry
about any of this anymore, and her
kingdom would be safe again.
She would be safe again.
But sending them off to be massacred was
exactly the kind of thing Dark Stalker
would do.
Snowfall was about to speak.
She was pretty sure she was about to say
something.
When Lynx got there first.
You have to be careful.
She said to Hazel.
There's an ice cliff at our southern
border that attacks dragons who fly over
it if they're not ice wings.
He'll have to circle out to sea to avoid
it.
Pretty far out to sea, I think.
This news made Hazel look so tired, and
Cricket so fascinated, the snowfall
almost almost melted.
But she couldn't.
She had to be strong.
Outside dragons were dangerous.
That was all there was to it.
We'll fly with you, Lang said, with
absolutely no effort to run this plan by
snowfall at all, we'll take you to the
southern border of the ice kingdom, and
make sure you get across safely.
All of you?
Hazel asked, glancing up at the army
again.
Just me and Queen Snowfall, Link said.
Snowfall interjected, and 10 of my
personal gar.
She wasn't quite sure why she was
agrained to go along at all.
Perhaps she just wanted to make sure they
were really gone.
Yes, that made sense.
Best to see them well over the border and
definitely out of her life forever.
Should she recloak her army and have them
follow?
Or would that be overkill?
A sign of fear instead of strength?
Hmm.
She considered her options while she sat
up on the cliff and watched the dragons
below prepare to leave.
They moved very slowly.
If it was true that they'd been fleeing
some enemy, Snowfall thought it must have
been a rather lethargic one, or else it
could have caught them easily.
An enormous sloth perhaps.
An elephant seal on land?
A malevolent glacier?
Lynx was down there trying to help.
Snowfall could see her moving between the
dragons, bringing them bowls of melted
snow to drink.
She'd also asked one of the soldiers to
fly to the nearest gift of subsistence
and bring back a few seals to share among
the dragons.
Snowfall had considered ordering him not
to, but she decided it would be queenlier
not to get involved.
And after all, the gift of subsistence
was magic, producing as many seals as the
dragons needed, so they couldn't exactly
run out.
Apparently, the silk wings didn't eat
meat though, which added to Snowfall's
suspicions.
Because wasn't that true of rain wings as
well?
Was anyone sure that these weird dragons
weren't working for Queen Glory?
Anyway, there was nothing growing in the
pine grove that they could eat.
See.
The Ice Kingdom would be all wrong for
them.
Snowfall told herself, freezing over any
twinges of guilt inside her.
Too cold, no plants, dragons who want
them gone.
They should move right along and become
some other queen's problem.
The strange dragons had some kind of
large makeshift thing that floated on the
ocean, made of palm trees lashed together
with vines as far as snowfall could
tell.
Tsunami had left it out at sea when she
came crashing in, but she swam back out
to get it, and a few of the healthier
dragons, plus links, helped her drag it
onto the shore.
Snowfall watched them narrowly as they
guided some of the oldest, weakest, and
smallest dragons to climb on top of it.
Evidently, the idea was to haul them over
the top of the ocean, because they were
incapable of flying that distance on
their own.
Then they shouldn't have left their own
stupid continent, she thought.
What did you call it?
Pintala?
They should have stayed there and dealt
with their own problems, instead of
bringing them to me.
She flipped her tail to summon her
favorite general.
Ivory came over immediately, bowing with
exactly the amount of respect Snowfall
was looking for.
Ivory had been in that battle with the
night wings.
But she hadn't thought, Queen Snowfall.
Ugh, what a terrible choice, like so many
of the dragons in her army.
Her thoughts had been more alike, I hope
she can do this.
If we survive this, I'm going to help our
new queen, however I can.
It wasn't exactly.
Hooray, Snow Fault.
She's the best.
But it was one of the only supportive
things Snowfall had heard in the chaos.
That's why she was Snowfall's favorite
and would stay in the 1st circle forever
as far as Snowfall was concerned.
I am putting you in charge while I'm away
from the kingdom.
Snowfall said.
Me?
General Ivory looked surprised for a
moment.
Yes, your majesty.
May I ask, what if Tundra objects?
Then she can eat her own tail, Snowfall
snapped.
Tell her if she complains, I'll be happy
to move her down to a different circle.
Oh, she thought, with a sudden surge of
something almost like joy.
If I escort the invaders out of here, I
definitely won't make it back to the
palace by nightfall tonight.
I'll have to camp overnight somewhere.
Which means I won't have to do the wall.
Perhaps it was a bad sign that this
moment was literally the happiest she'd
felt since becoming queen.
Lynx waved up to her, and the dragons
below rose from the beach in a whirlwind
of wing beats.
Snowfall summoned the 10 guards she'd
chosen, and leaped into the sky to join
them.
Not with them, obviously, more like off
to the side, where she could see them, but
not get bummed by any of them.
Her plan to stay apart was thwarted
though, when Queen Hazel soared over to
fly next to her.
What are you doing?
Snowfall asked, banking away slightly.
We'll be out of your kingdom soon, Hazel
said.
I was just hoping.
You're the only queen I've ever met.
Besides my great grandmother, and you're
not at all ancient.
I mean, you seem about my age, and I just
I'd love to know how you do everything.
Because it's really new for me and it's a
lot, a lot harder than I thought it would
be.
You know?
My great grandmother has been queen for
the longest ever time, and I thought I'd
have so much longer before I'd have to do
this.
Snowfall was certainly not going to feel
sympathy for a weird invasive dragon from
across the sea.
They were not the same at all.
How long have you been, queen?
Hazel asked.
Less than half a year, but if she told
Hazel that, the invading dragons wouldn't
take her seriously.
She needed them to stay afraid of her.
A long time.
She answered.
It actually felt very true as she said
it.
Maybe when you barely slept.
All the days and nights seemed a 1000
times longer.
Oh, Hazel said.
So you must find it really easy by now.
Snowfall hoped her face didn't give her
away.
There are Challenges, of course, she
said.
But the ice wings have a lot of
traditions in place, that are responsible
for upholding.
They help keep the kingdom safe and
orderly, so as long as I follow them
everything stays in its place, and
everyone will be safe.
Safe would be so great.
Hazel said sadly.
We lost our home and our trees before I
even hatched.
If we had traditions like that once
they're gone now.
She paused for a moment, gazing off west
as if the horizon was lined with the
ghosts of everything her tribe had lost.
After a few heartbeats, she asked, how
did your last queen die?
Evil magic plague, Snowfall said.
Yours?
Hazel hesitated.
Well?
I don't think she's dead.
But I don't know for sure.
We were fighting this enemy who can take
over dragon minds and control them, and
it got control of Queen Sequoia.
So it might have killed her, I guess, but
I think it would keep her alive. to use
her against us.
She sighed, and then noticed the way
Snowfall was staring at her.
What?
An enemy who can take over dragon mines?
Snowfall asked.
Was his name Dark Stalker?
No, Hazel said cautiously.
That is, we always thought it was Queen
Wasp, but it turns out maybe it's a
plant?
Snowfall narrowed her eyes.
A plant.
A very evil plant, Hazel added.
What was more likely?
An evil plant?
Or that dark soccer's terrible nightwing
powers somehow reached across the ocean
to ensnare a mythical continent full of
clear sight's descendants?
Snowfall pondered this for a moment.
Nothing really seemed beyond Dark
Stalker's magic or malevolence in her
opinion.
Or maybe it was some other magic
malevolent night wing.
There could definitely be others.
So, if she is still alive.
Are you going back to save her?
Snowball asked.
Definitely.
Yes.
If I can figure out how, Hazel said.
How to stop the mind control, I mean.
But then, wouldn't you have to give your
throne back to her?
I do that in a heartbeat, Hazel said
fervently.
Would I?
Snowfall thought.
In exchange for my mother back.
Yes.
But they still weren't the same.
Hazel, for instance, probably didn't have
a nefarious missing sister lurking
around.
Is there anyone else who wants to be
queen?
Snowfall asked.
I mean, someone who might take the throne
from you?
Hazel cast a glance over her shoulder, and
snowfall followed her gaze to the leaf
wing who'd been frowning at her before.
She was flying close to her green friend
almost close enough to twine their tails
together, and it looked like they were
arguing.
No, Hazel said.
I mean, there are dragons who would
probably be better queens than me, but
they don't want it.
Ha!
They say they don't want it.
Snowfall burst out.
You want some advice on being a queen?
Watch your back.
Don't trust anyone.
Someone is always plotting to take your
throne or murder your subjects or steal
your territory.
Hazel blinked.
Shading her eyes from the bright
reflection off the snowy cliffs to their
left.
Always?
She said faintly.
Even here in the distant kingdoms?
Snowfall snorted.
Especially here, and especially the night
wing tribe.
Watch out for any dragons with black and
silver scales.
They can read your mind and see the
future, and they want to wipe out all the
other tribes so they can be the only ones
left.
That sounds like clear sight, Hazel said
thoughtfully.
I mean, not the mind rating.
I've never heard that she could do that.
Can dragons here really do that?
But she could see the future.
And her descendants nearly wiped out my
tribe.
See?
Snowfall batted a seagull away from her
with her tail.
Night wings, evil, untrustworthy, and yes
totally mind readers.
She doesn't sound evil in her book
though.
Hazel offered.
I read it a few times on the journey, and
she sounds much kinder than, say, Queen
Wasp.
I don't think she would have wiped out a
tribe or hurt anyone if she could help
it.
Snowfall rolled her eyes.
This green dragon wasn't going to rule
much longer, if she kept trying to see
the best in dragons like Clearsight.
I'd better go check on the raft, Hazel
said.
Squinting down at the dragons towing
their contraption through the waves.
I hope we can talk more later.
She whisked away, leaving snowfall to her
unending circle of anxious thoughts.
It was a much longer flight than Snowfall
had anticipated, partly because the
strange dragons had to stop to rest, like
all the time, and partly because they had
to detour so far out over the ocean to
stay out of range of the ice cliff, and
partly because the raft was unwieldy and
awkward, and the dragon's towing it kept
switching places, and once a surprise
wave flipped the whole thing over, and
everyone had a massive panic attack, and
dove into the water to rescue the
floundering swimmers.
Even though tsunami and turtle were right
there, and everything was totally fine
and all the overreacting was completely
unnecessary.
But by late afternoon, they finally
reached the far side of the tundra that
was the disputed territory between the
Ice Kingdom and the Kingdom of Sand.
Territory that was definitely snowfalls.
As far as snowfall was concerned, the
land belonged to the ice kingdom, and
Queen Thorn could stick a cactus upper
nose if she thought she had any right to
it.
The pebbly beaches gave way slowly to a
coastline of yellow white sand, and the
temperature grew warmer and warmer as
they flew.
Just as the sun brushed the western edge
of the orange flooded sky, tsunami came
flying out of the water, waved at Hazel
and pointed to something down below.
A hut with a palm frond roof, tucked into
a small cove where the water was calm and
clear.
And standing outside the hut, on the sand
4 dragons, gazing up at the sky.
Snowfall narrowed her eyes, wishing again
that the stupid gift of vision ring
actually worked.
I swing eyesight was sharper than that of
most other tribes, but she couldn't see
their faces clearly from this distance
like she wanted to.
She could see, though, that one of the
dragons down there was pale green, with
bits of blue and gold and white, and that
it had 4 wings, like some of the strange
dragons from across the sea, the silk
wings, Hazel had called them.
Also, it was standing next to what was
clearly a night wing.
A night wing.
With one of the weird rainbow dragons.
They were working together.
Snowfall was right all along.
She felt a shiver of fear run along her
scales, and tried to tamp it down.
There were 10 well armed ice wing
soldiers with her.
She had the gift of stealth and the gift
of strength.
That night wing was the one who should be
scared.
The other 2 were sandwings, boring
nothing to...
Wait.
Snowfall swooped lower and let out a
hiss.
One of the sand wings was jerboa.
Jerboa, her animus dragon.
Her animus, who was supposed to live in a
hut all alone, and never talked to anyone
but the ice wing queen.
Maybe that wasn't exactly what Queen
Glacier had said, but something like
that.
She wasn't supposed to help other sand
wings and weird dragons from across the
sea, and she definitely shouldn't be
hanging out with a night wing.
Nightwings had their own animus dragons.
They didn't need Jerboa too.
Why was she helping one of them?
Or all of them, maybe actually?
So maybe Turboa was lying about animus
magic being broken, because she didn't
want to help ice wings anymore, because
now she was working with Snowfall's
enemies.
Snowfall's wings were vibrating with
stress and anger and nerves as she
crashed onto the beach ahead of the other
dragons.
The Silkwing bounded toward her with her
whole face alight.
Is blue with you?
And sore tail?
Wait, you're not a Silkwing?
Sorry, but, oh, Sundu.
She hurried past snowfall and threw her
wings around the frowny leaf wing, who, it
turned out, had other expressions besides
menacing, such as startled.
Sundew.
The silk wing cried again, letting her
go.
I can't believe you all made it here.
We're sore tail and blue.
Sundews, pleased look, fell away, and she
dug grooves in the sand with her claws.
They're not here, Lena.
I'm so sorry.
Luna pressed her talons to her face.
But before she could burst into tears
Sundew's companion jumped in.
They're still alive, as far as we know.
She said.
The Queen Wasp has them.
It's a long story.
We're going to get them back.
Sundu said fiercely.
I promise you that.
Even at slugs for brains, sword tail.
We'll figure out how to save them.
Yes, Luna said.
I'm so ready.
If you know how to cross the ocean, I'll
do it right now.
Crossing the ocean isn't the hard part
unfortunately.
Sundew said.
Luna's eyes drifted to cricket, standing
behind the leaf wings and holding
Bumblebee.
She beckoned the yellow and black dragon
forward and hugged her too.
Come, tell me all about it, she said, and
the 5 of them went up the beach into the
hut.
Snowfall had only been half listening.
Her focus was on Jerboa, and if she could
freeze dragons with her eyeballs, the
anima sandwing would have turned to ice
all the way to her bones.
The voice of the rage in her glare was so
strong, she couldn't believe how long it
took Jerboa to finally turn and meet her
eyes.
And then Treboa didn't even look guilty.
She looked.
Annoyed?
Tired?
Something aggravating.
Snowfall stormed up to her.
The night wing and the other sand wing
had gone down to the water to help the
sea wings drag the raft ashore, with lots
of yelps and chirps and gleeful reunion
noises.
There was a small oasis of silence around
her boa and her little patch of sand.
What are you doing here?
Snowfall growled at her.
Treboa arched one eyebrow.
I live here.
What are you doing here?
Are you working with these dragons?
Snowfall demanded.
Did you give them some magic to help them
invade my kingdom?
Treboa gave her a withering look.
As I am quite sure, I have mentioned
before, she said.
No one wants to invade your kingdom.
Wrong.
Snowfall snapped.
These dragons tried to, and I have driven
them out.
By myself, I might add, without any help
from you.
See?
Turboa said flatly.
I knew you could do it.
You just had to believe in yourself.
Raw, raw.
Why are you helping a night wing instead
of me?
Snowfall asked in a low hiss.
I'm not helping anyone, Treboa said.
I fulfilled my purpose.
All I did here is provide some shelter
and make an introduction, although
providing shelter to 3 dragons is quite
different.
From sharing my cove with 2 entire
tribes.
She wrinkled her snout slightly, as she
looked around at the chaos of dragons
engulfing her beach.
Tales and talons were churning up the
sand.
Several dragons were wading in the
shallows of the cove, catching fish and
crabs and clouding the water with silt.
Others had collapsed all along the beach
wings flung out to either side, soaking
up the sun.
The relieved expressions were back on
most of their faces, and some of the silk
wings were already gathering coconuts to
eat, and debating placidly about how to
open them.
The night wing came floundering back of
the beach, and snowfall finally
recognized her.
It was that interfering little one with
the visions, the one Winter liked so much
Moonface or something like that.
The one who had been Dark Stalker's very
best friend when he 1st came out of the
mountain.
According to Winter.
She'd also been instrumental in stopping
Dark Stalker, but given the lack of
actual evidence, or a body, specifically
Snowfall would have liked a specifically
clearly dead body to examine and yell at
and stomp on.
Snowfall couldn't help but still find her
very suspicious.
This was a particularly bad nightwing
defined with her animus.
Hello, Moonface said breathlessly.
You are Queen Snowfall, aren't you?
You know perfectly well that I am?
Snowfall said coldly.
Mind reader.
The black dragon had the grace to look a
little abashed.
It's moon actually, she said.
Just moon, not moonface.
Snowfall wished one of the ice wing
animus gifts had been an invulnerability
to night wing powers.
That would have been extremely useful.
Why didn't anyone ever think of that?
Because they weren't our mortal enemies
until they stole Arctic, she remembered.
And after that, there were no more animus
gifts.
Moon winced and touched her temples.
This is a lot of noisy dragons, she said
to Jerboa.
It certainly is, Treboa said, eyeing a
pair of leaf winged dragonettes as they
tumbled and wrestled along the beach with
squeals of joy.
Is this what your vision showed you?
Sort of, Moon said.
But it's only the beginning, I think.
Only the beginning.
Treboa looked nearly as annoyed with Moon
as she was with Snowfall.
Are there a lot more coming?
Here, to this beach in particular?
No.
Wait, actually, I don't know, Moon said.
They can stay for now, Treboa said with a
sigh.
Until they're ready to move on, which had
better be soon.
But where do you expect them to end up?
I know, cried the other sandwing, jumping
over the dunes toward them in little
flying, hopping leaps.
I have an idea.
We can take them to sanctuary.
Yes.
Of course, the night wing said, her whole
phase relaxing.
That's perfect.
They'll be safe there.
That's where winter is, right?
Length aft.
Moon gave her a curious look.
Have we met?
I'm lynx, the ice wing offered.
A friend of Winter's.
But an even more loyal subject, my
excellent one true queen snowfall right
here, of course.
She added quickly.
Snowfall flicked sand in her face with
her tail, and Lynx sneezed.
Do you want to come with us?
To sanctuary?
Moon asked.
I'm sure Winter would be happy to see you
and we could use a few more strong wings
to help these dragons get there.
Links gave Snowfall a hopeful look.
We can't sit here for days and days
Snowfall pointed out.
It won't be that long, Moon said, catching
a look on Jaboa's face.
Maybe one day to rest, and we leave the
day after tomorrow?
Or tomorrow, maybe tomorrow?
Night was falling swiftly around them, but
for once.
Snowfall could watch the stars come out
without a sense of suffocating dread.
For once, her scales weren't crawling
with the knowledge that Tundra was tip
tapping toward her on cold judgmental
claws.
The wall was far, far away, and Snowfall
did not have to worry about it for one
blissful night.
Which could be 2 nights, maybe three.
Maybe even 4 if sanctuary required
inspecting or anything like that.
The wall wasn't going anywhere.
Snowfall would face it again when she
returned to the ice palace.
There was no need to rush back.
Queen Glacier had often gone on
diplomatic trips or battle missions for
days, and the kingdom didn't collapse.
Maybe that was why she'd gone away so
often, come to think of it.
Fine, Snowfall said to Length.
We'll go to sanctuary.
But only so I can make sure my weird
scavenger obsessed cousin isn't up to
anything with all his new other tribe
friends.
Snowfall shot a glare at Moon, just to
clarify exactly who she meant.
The tribes settle down to sleep early.
The silk wings, it turned out, could
produce some kind of strange silvery
stuff from their wrists, and several of
them made little hammocks out of it to
hang from the trees, then slept in them.
It was very weird, and didn't seem like a
normal dragon ability to snowfall at
all.
Snowfall ordered the other ice wings to
choose their own section of beach, some
ways off from the other tribes, but still
within sight.
She set a rotating guard schedule and
gave them instructions to keep an eye out
for the night wing especially.
It was mercifully cooler after the sun
went down, but still a little too warm
for snowfall's comfort.
She stabbed her claws into the sand
digging down and down until she found a
cold layer of sand far below the sun
warmed layers on top.
This was better.
It was no slab of ice, but it would cool
her off enough to sleep.
She curled into the hole and felt her
weapons jabber in the side.
The animus touched wristbands weighed
down her talons, and the tiara was quite
uncomfortable to sleep in.
But she wasn't about to take any of it
off, of course.
She might need those knives, or throwing
stars, or other knives, or magic strength
if someone attacked her in the middle of
the night.
She was surrounded by enemies here after
all.
Well, technically, she was surrounded by
10 ice wing soldiers, and then a bunch of
enemies.
Still.
But she could take off the gift of vision
at least, since the stupid thing didn't
work at all.
She tugged on the opal ring to slide it
off her claw.
It didn't move.
Which was odd.
Hadn't it felt loose when she 1st put it
on?
Snowfall frowned at it.
The opal caught the starlight and
twinkled cheerfully at her.
She tugged on it again.
It was definitely stuck.
Weird and annoying.
With a sigh, she gave up.
She was too tired for a wrestling match
with an accessory tonight.
Tomorrow she'd rubbed palm oil all over
it or something, and then it would slide
off easily.
Stupid, useless, frustrating stupid
thing.
She tucked her nose under her tail, and
for the 1st time in months, she fell
asleep within moments.
Chapter 6.
She is flying, although her wings feel so
heavy.
She thinks they might drag her down into
the ocean any moment.
She has been flying for days and days.
And below her, there is nothing but
treacherous water in every direction
restlessly waiting to swallow her up.
Each island is so far away, and some of
them are so tiny, it's a miracle anyone
spotted them at all.
There was one island that was big
enough.
She'd hoped it was the distant kingdoms
but it was empty, and the map said it was
only halfway to the other continent.
Every morning she lifts into the sky on a
new wave of terror, afraid that this will
be the day they run out of islands, and
everyone will drown.
They can't turn back.
Nobody can.
There's only one map.
She wouldn't know how to follow the chain
of islands all the way back home on her
own.
And what's behind them is even worse than
this.
The burning jungle, the white eyed
dragons, the mind control you can catch
as easily as breathing in the wrong smoke
someone said.
Her wings shiver with terror.
She thought she was joining an army.
She thought the time for rebellion had
finally come.
That it was time to be brave and heroic.
Io said the chrysalis was going to rise
up, join the leaf wings, and fight Queen
Wasp for freedom and a better future.
But they never had a chance.
Aren't we going to fight them?
She'd asked.
No.
By the time they reached the poison
jungle, everything had changed.
Queen Wasp could control silk wings and
leaf wings now.
They'd lost before lifting even a single
claw.
All they could do was run.
She couldn't even stop to get her little
brother or her placid, perpetually
confused grandparents.
She'd left them in Yellow Jacket Hive
thinking she'd be home within a day or 2
to free them with a triumphant leaf wing
army.
She didn't even say goodbye.
Where are they now?
Have their minds been taken by the hive
wing queen?
Are they even less free now than they'd
been before?
And will she ever see them again?
Her tears blur the shapes of the dragons
around her before they're swept away by
the cold wind.
Two more days until we reach the distant
kingdoms, says a leaf wing flying beside
her.
His voice kind.
Gentle leaf wings.
She'd had no idea such a thing had ever
existed before all this.
We're almost there.
Then we can rest and be safe.
Safety.
Rest.
Those both sound impossible.
All she wants is to lie down on solid
ground and feel for even a moment that
she doesn't have to be completely
terrified.
She rubs her face dry and flies on.
Snowfall jolted awake, her heart
pounding.
Her wings flared up and flung sand in all
directions.
Her wings, her own wings.
White and curved, and only 2 of them as
they were supposed to be.
She touched her claws to her skull.
Nothing strange growing out of her head.
She checked her wings again, but they
definitely hadn't turned peach orange
with sapphire spots during the night.
She was on a beach.
A beach with waves pounding nearby
everything pale and pearly gray in the
early morning light.
Dragons slept all around her.
I'm Queen Snowfall.
She reassured herself.
I am Queen Snowfall.
She said out loud, because the universe
had a whole skeptical vibe about it that
was very aggravating.
Length lifted her head from a nearby
sandpile, squinting blearily.
Who said you weren't?
She mumbled.
I'm a kill him.
Sure, yes.
Later, ish.
Now it's too early.
No stabbing before breakfast.
Her voice rambled off into nonsense as
she slid back down to sleep.
Snowfall considered making her wake up
which was a thing a queen could certainly
do, except then the queen would have to
explain that she'd been freaked out by a
bad dream and just wanted company, which
didn't seem very regal at all, really.
It wasn't so much the content of the
dream, although it had been unsettling.
But she'd spent the whole day with that
nervous, forlorn tribe of meek rainbow
dragons.
It wasn't all that weird that she might
dream about their situation.
The freaky part was that she'd really
felt like she was someone else.
In the dream, she'd completely been one
of those homeless silk wings, completely
inside another dragon.
Not even a thought of the Ice Kingdom.
No hint of snowfall left at all.
She did not like that?
No, sir.
And now there were all these lingering
feelings.
The terror skittering along her scales
was one thing.
She was used to worrying about dangerous
things out there.
Not these specific dangerous things, but
she could slide that all into one
compartment.
It was the boring, exhausting, sadness
she didn't like.
How could she be feeling this depressed
about a continent and a few dragons she'd
never seen?
Dragons who didn't exist, mind you
because her brain had conjured them out
of nothing?
Snap out of it.
I'm fine.
It's just these stupid, pathetic dragons
messing with my head.
She glared balefully up the beach at the
slumbering forms around Jerboa's hut.
Wait, what if that was literally true?
Maybe this was some kind of sinister
dragon magic from across the sea.
Maybe they've given her a sappy nightmare
to trick her into feeling sorry for
them.
Which was an unimpressive bit of magic, if
that was all they could do.
If she had the power to give dragons
specific dreams, she'd make them all
dream about how strong and amazing she
was.
So they'd be totally in awe of her and do
everything she said, and never have any
doubts about her ever.
Snowfall leaned over and poked the links
in the shoulder.
Hey, she said.
Links.
Lynx.
Wake up.
I have an important question.
Did you have any weird dreams?
Wing said in a muffled voice, trying to
roll away from Snowfall's claw.
Go away.
You can't tell your queen to go away
Snowfall pointed out.
Your queen demands that you answer her
question.
It's a royal command.
What?
Things protested without opening her
eyes.
Did you have any weird dreams last
night?
Snowfall said impatiently.
No, Lynx mumbled.
Slept great.
Would still be sleeping great if it were
up to me?
Unless I'm dreaming that my queen is
waking me up at a horrifying hour to ask
about my dreams, in which case, yes, this
one is a bit weird.
You are a useless minion.
Snowfall observed.
Friend, length enunciated clearly, before
edging away and burying herself farther
into the sand.
Her voice came sleepily over the dune.
The word you're looking for.
His friend.
Humph.
Snow falls down to hole in the beach and
shoved a passing crab into it.
Come to think of it, Sheep slept well
too.
Really, truly slept.
Despite the dream, she felt rested for
the 1st time in forever.
Okay, so shake it off.
It was just a dream.
Time to get these dragons to sanctuary
and make them some other queen's problem
so I can go home.
Two of her guards jumped to their feet
and followed her as she marched up the
beach.
Most of the Pentalan dragons were still
asleep, but the one who'd been here
before the rest, waiting with Treboa, was
gathering wood into a pile, and a few
others were helping her.
Snowfall slowed down as she approached
her eyes drifting over the strangers.
She knew her brain had simply jumbled
together a bunch of ideas from her
subconscious, but She felt her heart do a
startled little spasm in her chest.
There.
Asleep with her back pressed against one
of the green dragons, peach orange scales
sapphire blue spots, and the leaf wing
beside her?
Wasn't he the one who'd spoken to her in
the sky?
Except I made that up.
In my head, in a random dream.
She must have seen the 2 dragons flying
together yesterday, even if she hadn't
thought about it consciously.
Her subconscious brain probably saw them
being friendly, and stuffed that image
into a box labeled, gross, intertribe
flirting, not okay.
Dream about this later.
And if it did turn out that the Silk
Wings name was Atala, that was also
definitely a coincidence, with a
reasonable explanation, and so she did
not at all need to find that out.
Snowfall sat down and watched the dragons
building the fire instead.
As far as she'd seen yesterday, neither
silk wings nor leaf wings could breathe
fire, so she expected the night wing or
one of the sand wings to emerge and light
it for them.
But once the wood pile was high enough
the 1st silk wings stepped forward and
held out her front talons.
Their peculiar dragon silk started
spiraling out from her wrists.
Except...
Snowfall shot to her feet and paced
closer.
This dragon's silk was the color of
gold.
And where it touched the wood, licks of
flame growled to life.
Whoa.
What is that?
Snowfall demanded of the nearest silk
wing.
He was smaller than her, all pale gray
and brown with hints of purple.
He blinked, yawned, stretched, yawned
again, and finally, about 300 years later
answered her question.
Oh, he said.
Right.
Balloon is a flame silk.
He started to yawn again, and Snowfall
was tempted to throw lobster at his
face.
That means nothing to me.
She snapped.
Use more words that convey actual
information.
If you please.
Um, he said. swallowing his yawn
nervously.
Like her silk can be fire, if she wants
it to be?
Snowfall narrowed her eyes at him.
Can you all do that?
No, no, no, he said.
He shook his head and flicked his tail
toward Luna.
Flame silks are very rare.
That's why she ran away, you know, before
any of us, because Queen Wasp keeps them
all trapped, and she escaped, and okay
that's enough words, Snowfall said, waving
him away.
He blinked a few times, and then resumed
his stretching.
The sound of clanking drew Snowball's
attention back to the fire.
Luna had taken one of the threads of her
flame silk, and twisted it into a long
wire, which she held between her talons.
She can hold fire.
Snowfall watched as Luna bent over a silk
wing's talons, and carefully traced the
flame thread across the metal cuff on the
silk wing's wrist.
A singed line appeared on the metal, and
then, as Luna traced it over and over, the
fire burned through the cuff, and it
thunked into the sand.
Luna and the Silkwing grinned at each
other.
And then she turned to the next dragon's
cuff to do the same.
As strange powers went, this one wasn't
the scariest.
Snowfall had fought plenty of dragons who
breathed fire.
The flame silk was just a weirder, slower
moving version of that, basically.
Which probably means they can do
something else.
But they're hiding it, she thought
huffily.
Even the rain wings aren't as harmless
and mellow as these twits.
The silk wings probably have secret venom
too, and they're just waiting for a
chance to spring it on us.
Snowfall rubbed her own wrists under the
gift of stealth.
In her dream last night.
She'd been wearing a wrist cuff like all
the silk wings.
It was horribly heavy, she remembered
now.
She, Dream her, had felt as though it
might drag her down into the ocean.
There was an inscription on it that
allowed her in and out of Yellow Jacket
Hive.
Yellow jacket hive.
What a melodramatic name my dream brain
came up with.
Or probably I heard someone say it
yesterday and just don't remember it.
She glanced around, but the sapphire
spotted dragon, Atala, was still asleep.
Snowfall felt an irrational desire to run
over and shake her, to yell, Luna's
burning off the wrist cuffs.
You can finally be free of it.
Hurry, get it off.
Wait.
There had been letters carved into her
palm too.
Letters that signified her parents and
her own name.
Why would I know that?
Her scales prickled uncomfortably.
Hey, she said. to the same silk wing she
had interrogated before.
He was now standing in line to get his
cuff burned off, and he jumped when
Snowfall accosted him again.
Show me your right talon.
Um, he said, but he held it out
agreeably.
Sure enough, 3 letters were carved into
his palm, a triangle of old, deliberate
scars.
What do these mean?
Snowfall asked.
The big one is an L?
for my name, he said.
Which is laughing, if that's not too much
information, then the 2 little ones are
on my parents' initials.
Why would your parents do this to you?
Snowfall frowned.
The cuts must have been deep and fairly
painful to leave permanent marks like
these.
They didn't.
He said.
The hive wings did this.
Something flashed in his eyes.
The 1st strong emotion she'd seen from
him.
They do this to all the Silkwing
Dragonettes.
It's one of the ways they keep track of
us.
So they can control us.
You, I mean, obviously, you.
Snowfall corrected herself quickly.
The Hive Wings and Queen Wasp.
They control your whole tribe.
He pulled back his talon and clenched it
into a fist.
They did.
He said.
But we were going to fight them.
We've been planning to change things.
We just didn't know how.
That's what the chrysalis is, Snowfall
realized.
Your resistance group.
Lappet gave her a very confused, slightly
suspicious look.
How do you know about the chrysalis?
That is a really excellent question
Leppett.
I must have heard someone talking about
it yesterday, she said.
Or, Or her dream was actually real after
all.
And she'd actually been inside one of
Atala's memories.
She didn't want to ask, but she kind of
had to.
Do you know that dragon?
she asked, pointing at the silk wing with
blue spots.
What's her name?
Attala?
He said cautiously.
Arr, no.
It could still be a coincidence.
Maybe I heard someone say it.
Maybe my subconscious gathered a whole
heck ton of information without my
realizing it.
Or a theory too.
Giant, magical conspiracy.
Equally possible.
What else can you do?
She demanded.
Do silk wings have other powers, like
sharing dreams, or possessing other
dragons or anything like that?
No, Lappett said, edging a step away from
her.
Flame silk is the only power soak wings
have, if you call it that.
Shooting fire from your wrists?
Yeah, that counts as a power, butterfly
dragon, she amended, before she could say
butterfly brain.
Would that even be an insult to a
silkwing?
What about the leaf wings?
Do they have any dream powers?
Not that I know of?
He said.
Why?
Did, uh, did something happen?
No, she barked.
Three moons.
Stop being so nosy lap it.
She turned in a flurry of sand and
stomped down the beach toward the water.
If he was telling the truth, and she'd
had a real, inside another dragon's head
dream, and it really, really wasn't sent
by one of the weird new tribes, then this
was someone else's fault.
Or rather, something else's fault.
Theory 3.
The most annoying one, because of the
face, links will give me if it's true.
If something else had sent her that dream
Snowfall had an awful suspicion that she
knew exactly which smug little accessory
was to blame.
Chapter 7.
Everything is fine.
Snowfall muttered to herself.
She glowered, the silvery fish flickering
around her talons.
The ocean was unpleasantly warmer here
than it was up around the ice kingdom.
There's nothing to worry about.
I'm definitely not wearing a piece of
haunted jewelry.
It'll slide off easily any moment, and
then I'll feel silly.
The gift of vision.
No, she barked at the ring.
It's not possible.
How could an ice wing object give me
weird dreams about weird faraway dragons
that weren't supposed to exist?
The last thing she needed was mystical
visions of total strangers.
How is that supposed to help her be a
strong, powerful, excellent queen?
Who was the idiot animas that would come
up with something like this?
If she had to have a magic vision?
Couldn't it be of someone useful?
Like, say, a certain scheming sister who
might be plotting to take her throne?
And even if it was the source of the
dream, that didn't explain why it
wouldn't come off now?
She soaked the ring until her claws
started to feel numb, and then she yanked
on it as hard as she could.
Ow.
It wasn't even budging.
Great, ice spirits, she hissed at the
opal.
What is wrong with you?
She tried wedging a claw underneath the
band?
But it was on too tight.
She tried wiggling it furiously.
But it wouldn't even spin around her
claw.
She tried smashing the opal into a rock
sticking out of the water, but that just
made her talons hurt, and the opal
twinkled saucily at her, completely
intact.
What are you doing?
said Lynx's voice behind her.
Nothing, Snowfall called over her
shoulder.
She stuck the ring back in the water and
turned around with her most serenely
regal face on.
Links did a thing with her eyebrows that
meant something like, I know you're lying
but I can't say you are. because you're
the queen, but maybe you should just
admit it because my eyebrows are so onto
you.
Well, you were doing that nothing very
vigorously, Lang said.
So I wondered, you know, a whole lot of
vigorous nothing before breakfast.
Maybe I have had breakfast, Snowball
observed.
You would know, since you've been asleep
half the morning.
I do know that you have not.
Link said, because I asked your guards
and they said you've been out here for
ages, doing battle with either your own
claws or an invisible shark.
Snowfall bristled and shot a dark look at
her guards, who were lined up on the
beach with concerned expressions.
Is that what they said?
No, Links admitted.
They just said you haven't had breakfast
yet.
I interpreted the rest by watching you
for a few minutes.
I am having a swim, Snowfall said, lifting
her chin.
There is nothing unusual about that.
I've seen you swim, Link said.
You don't usually look quite so much like
an agitated squid.
I'm just going to start making a mental
list, Snowfall informed her, so that when
we get home, I can execute you for all
your treason at once.
Once would probably be enough, Lang said
laughing.
She flicked a spray of water at snowfall
with her tail.
Come on, Snowfall.
Even queens need someone to talk to.
Tell me what's wrong.
Nothing is wrong, Snowfall protested.
I'm just having a small problem with this
ring, I can't get off, but it's not
important.
I mean, not compared to what are we going
to do with all these homeless dragons and
the bad things they're running away
from?
Like, seriously?
Length tilted her head and studied
snowfall for a moment, as though she were
a palm tree that had suddenly sprouted in
the middle of the ice palace.
They'll be all right now that they're
here, she said finally.
Let me see that ring.
Snowfall grudgingly held out her talons
and links gripped the ring between her
claws.
She pulled and wiggled it, and tried
sliding her claws under it, and yanked
some more, until Snowfall finally got fed
up and snatched her arm back.
Well, you're no use, Snowfall hissed.
No surprise there.
She dunked her claws in the water again.
But now Links looked worried, which meant
she was about to get very annoying.
It's really not moving at all, she said.
Snowfall.
Was that ring from the forbidden
treasury?
Is it animus touched?
Snowfall frowned and took a piece of
seaweed off her tail.
Yes, but it doesn't work.
Are you sure?
Lengx asked.
What is it supposed to do?
It's, Supposed to make your eyesight
sharper, Snowfall said.
But it didn't make any difference at all
which is why I want it off.
Were there any notes?
Links pressed. about how to use it, or
what it did for other queens, or who made
it?
No, Snowfall said.
Nobody wrote an encyclopedia about it.
It's not that complicated.
Put on the ring, get better vision.
But that isn't what happened, Link said.
Wait, were there any notes?
Her expression shifted to the most
absolutely irritating, wide-eyed alarm.
Did you just put it on without knowing
anything about it?
Why not?
Snowfall snapped.
Better Vision would be helpful.
But what if there's a catch?
Langs cried.
What if there's a secret downside to the
spell?
What are the animus dragon who made it
added a curse to the magic?
Or what if it does something entirely
different than I thought it did?
Snowfall shoved that thought away.
Then we wouldn't have kept it, she
snarled at length.
It wouldn't still be in our treasury if
it was evil.
Some cursed queen before us would have
destroyed it.
Unless it was enchanted so it could never
be destroyed.
Length yelped, sounding uncomfortably
like snowfall's inner monologue.
Maybe it magically shows up in the
forbidden treasury once every 100 years
to ensnare some new hapless queen.
I'm not hapless, Snowfall shouted.
Who's being paranoid now?
It was a gift for ice wing queens.
So it's supposed to make us stronger and
safer, like the wall, and the ice cliff.
Personally, I don't think it makes our
tribe stronger for us all to be
constantly pitted against each other.
Langs cried.
And I don't think cutting us off from the
other tribes makes us safer either.
Wow.
Snowfall said with a hiss. questioning
the most fundamental gifts that hold our
tribe together?
You really don't belong in the 1st
circle.
What kind of ice wing are you?
The kind who actually thinks for herself
sometimes, Link said, flinging up her
wings and accidentally splashing a small
fish into snowfall's face.
The kind who wants you to be a better
queen than the ones we've had before
because I know you, and I know you can
be.
But feel free to keep living your life by
the rules of that oppressive wall, if
that's all you want, and feel free to
move me down to the bottom of the list
when we get home.
She took a step toward the beach, then
turned back for one more shot.
If that mysterious magic ring even lets
you get home.
After everything animus magic has done to
us, I can't believe you'd throw yourself
into its talent again.
She splashed away furiously.
Snowfall threw herself under the water
and screamed out her rage in a flurry of
bubbles.
This was why she didn't tell anyone her
problems.
Because they would definitely make them
worse.
Lynx was not right.
It was just a stupid broken ring.
Snowfall had definitely not
misinterpreted what a gift of vision
might mean, and this had nothing to do
with her dream last night.
No.
She would not stand for it.
When she surfaced again.
Lynx was with the strangers by the fire
where some of the littlest dragonettes
were building a kind of tree like termite
mound out of the sand.
Snowfall squinted at them, as 2 young
leaf wings pounced on the shape and
stomped it flat.
The opal ring winked gold blue lavender
in the morning light.
I'm not afraid of you, Snowfall thought
fiercely.
I am getting rid of you today, even if I
have to cut off my own claw to do it.
She would get this ring off and throw it
into the ocean, and then she would make
sure the strange dragons went to
sanctuary, and then she would go home, and
everything would go back to the normal
everyday anxiety festival her life was
supposed to be.
Snowball splashed her way back onto the
beach, waving regally at her guards.
Nothing to see here.
No queens losing their royal minds.
Certainly not.
She waited until she was sure Lynx wasn't
watching her, and then she tried
smothering her claws and palm oil from
one of the jars outside Jerboa's hut.
That didn't work either.
It only left snowfall's talons feeling
greasy.
Oh, please.
Treboa said acidly from the doorway.
Help yourself.
My stuff is everybody's stuff, evidently.
This is your fault, Snowfall said
brandishing the now extremely shiny
ring.
That you're wearing too much hideous
jewelry, Turboa said.
Make sense.
I do have that effect on dragons.
I wouldn't need this if your stupid magic
worked, Snowfall said with a flick of her
wings.
Have you checked today?
Is it working now?
The frown lines in Jerboa's face
deepened.
No.
It's not working for anyone.
She glanced back into the hut.
Snowfall wasn't sure why.
Really definitely?
Snowfall asked.
She held out her front talons.
Let's test it.
Tell this ring to slide off my claw.
Turboa's side and cast another glance
around.
But no other dragons were close enough to
pay attention to them.
The sand wing reached out and tapped the
ring twice.
Come off the queen's claw this instant
she said.
The ring didn't move.
Snowfall tried pulling on it again, but
it was just as stuck as before.
She growled softly.
Is it?
Anna's touch?
Treboa asked, finally sounding curious.
I thought so, Snowfall said, but it seems
to be flipping broken.
Animas touched by who?
Jaboa frowned again.
When?
Like 1000s of years ago, Snowfall said
with a sigh.
By the worst ice wing animus in history
I'm guessing, some kind of worm brained
fan snorter.
Why would anyone enchant a ring to stay
on someone's claw?
What kind of stupid waste of magic is
that?
Treboa scratched her jaw thoughtfully, but
her tense expression had relaxed.
Maybe.
It's enchanted to frustrate easily
annoyed queens into learning some
patience.
Boo, hiss.
Snowfall shouted.
Several of the silk wings jumped and
turned to see what the noise was.
She lowered her voice again.
I don't need an ancient accessory to
teach me anything.
I'm very patient.
I've been queen for months without
stabbing anybody in the face with an
icicle, despite lots of dragons highly
deserving it.
Well, Treboa said, if my magic comes back
I'll make removing your ring my top
priority.
How about that?
No need, Snowfall said.
I have another plan.
She narrowed her eyes at your boa and
added in a whisper, But if it does come
back, tell me right away.
Turbo's expression was quite far from
reassuring, but she ducked into her hut
without saying anything else.
Snowfall caught a glimpse of the night
wing inside, still fast asleep.
She moved away as quickly as she could.
The last thing she needed was that dragon
poking around inside her head.
It was bad enough to have links making
worried eyes at her all the time.
She didn't need any night wings thinking
she was weak or cursed by weird jewelry.
Over by the fire.
Luna was finally alone more or less
surrounded by a mound of discarded wrist
cuffs.
Most of the other silk wings had gone off
to gather coconuts or lie quietly on the
warm sand, and lynx was up in the sky
flying with one of the leaf wings.
Snowfall sidled up to Luna.
The Silkwing dropped the cuff she'd been
holding, and eyed Snowfall with alarm.
Hey, Snowfall said gruffly.
That fire thread thing?
Can you try that on my ring?
It's stuck, and it's annoying me.
You're that queen of the ice wings
right?
Luna said, lifting her chin.
The one who kicked my tribe out of your
kingdom yesterday?
Lucky for you?
Snowfall pointed out, or they wouldn't be
here.
Having this touching reunion with you.
Luna rolled her eyes and held out her
claws.
Show me.
Snowfall gingerly offered the talon with
a ring on it.
Luna picked up a filament of fire from
the sand beside her and bent over their
twined claws.
The burning filament brushed the silver
curve of the ring once, twice, 3 times
without even leaving a trace on the
metal.
Luna frowned and tried again.
The heat was enormously uncomfortable
that close to snowfalls scales.
And she didn't like the feel of this silk
wing gripping her talons either.
But she held still, glaring into the
opal's shimmering depths, until Luna
finally said, That's so weird.
Sorry, your majesty, it's not working.
Snowfall lifted the opal to eye level and
hissed at it.
How could fire not work?
Don't tell links, she said to Luna.
Uh, sure, Luna agreed.
You're welcome.
For what?
Snowfall snapped and stomped away.
She found a large boulder in a shaded
spot near the tree line, and perched on
it to brood for a while.
Her guards fanned out in a discreet
circle around her, and one of them
brought her a fish to eat, and she even
remembered to thank him for it.
So, at least I did one excellently
queenly ding today.
The other animus touched things came off
easily.
No problem.
The stealth wristbands, and the tiara of
strength, off and back on.
Nothing sinister about them at all.
Snowfall had always assumed that if
something was made by an ice wing animus
it would be something great.
Something good and helpful and smart and
clever.
Like an ice wing.
An ice wing animus would make a secret
evil spell like a night wing would, surely
right?
The ring was not a big deal, she told
herself.
It was Linx's fault that she was even
worrying about it at all.
But really?
If she thought about it, she felt fine.
Better than usual in fact.
Probably because she hadn't had to see
Aunt Tundra's smug face for a whole day.
Moreover, if there was a secret spell on
the ring, it hadn't given her a terrible
illness yet, or turned her into a
different dragon.
Ha!
It could try.
She was always snowfall and always would
be.
It hadn't tricked her into letting
strange invader dragons into her
kingdom.
She was the same as always.
Everything was normal.
Even the lingering sadness from the dream
lifted a little as the day went on.
She could see Atala from her spot, and
the Silk Queen didn't look totally
miserable, so that helped.
Atala got her wrist cuff burned off, ate
a talon full of dates, laughed at a leaf
wing when he tried to catch a crab, and
it tweaked his nose, and took several
naps.
The silk wing also spent a while staring
out of the ocean.
Thinking about the family she left behind
snowfall guest.
I hope they're safe.
No, I don't.
I don't care at all.
She shook herself vigorously.
I don't know them.
Why would I care?
Stupid dream.
Or vision or whatever.
Shortly before sunset, Snowfall heard the
cracks and snaps of talent steps in the
trees behind her.
She turned and spotted the frowning weaf
wing pacing between the palms, throwing
fallen coconuts into a sack.
Another green dragon followed her.
This one with pinkish streaks on her
wings and horns.
We jazz.
Just got here, said the pink tinted leaf
wing languidly.
Why are you acting like such a frustrated
panther already?
Wasn't this the goal?
But we can't stay, Cobra Lily, cried the
other one.
We can't just find a nice, safe spot to
settle down and get comfortable.
That's not the plan.
I won't give up on our whole continent
and everyone there.
Cobra Lily shrugged.
An elegant lift and fall of her wings.
You can be that upset about losing nettle
and belladonna, and if you use silly silk
wings, she said.
Seems like an upside to me.
No more nettle annoying us.
No more belladonna telling you what to
do.
The scowly one fixed her with a
particularly ferocious scowl.
Queen Sequoia is back there, plus half
the dragons we grew up with, a monster
has stolen our home.
And by the way, those silly silk wings
risked a lot to help us.
Don't get excited, Cobra Lily said.
I'm just saying, this place is already
significantly nicer than a jungle full of
carnivorous plants, or a land full of
mind controlled bug dragons.
Maybe we could stay here.
Make a new home.
One queen over both the silk wings and
the leaf wings.
I bet most of these dragons wouldn't mind
following a queen's sundew.
No sundew growled.
Stop saying that.
Hazel is our queen.
She half turned and finally spotted
snowfall lying on her boulder.
Her tail lashed for a moment, and then
she spread her wings and lifted off into
the sky.
That's interesting, Snowfall thought.
Sundew.
She is a threat to Hazel's rule.
Even if she doesn't mean to be, other
dragons want her to be.
Just like the dragons who probably still
want Crystal to be queen instead of me.
How many of them are there?
Are they hiding her?
Are they planning something?
Gathering an army?
Conspiring with night wings?
Where is she?
Snowfall brooded about this until one of
her guards came over to inform her that
the strange tribes had decided to stay
one more night before setting out for
sanctuary in the morning.
Snowfall could tell that Hazel would have
liked to stay longer.
The leaf winged queen kept leaning
wistfully on the palm trees, and gazing
up at their swaying leaves.
But moon was bustling around, reassuring
everyone that sanctuary would be even
better, with more trees and lots of space
and food for them.
Highly suspicious.
Possibly some kind of nefarious plan at
work if a night wing was all excited
about it.
As the sun set, Snowfall dug her sleeping
hole with extra vigor, throwing all the
excess sand in Lynx's direction.
She was not going to worry about this
ridiculous ring.
She refused to have another vision of
mystery dragons she didn't know.
She was the queen, and she would simply
order her brain to have an ordinary night
with perfectly ordinary dreams.
Yes.
She curled up, closed her eyes, and
dropped almost instantly into another
dragon's scales.
Chapter 8.
She is alone in the kitchen, rolling
antelope meatballs, trying to keep her
claws busy.
She's trying not to think about cinnabar
or how she should be with the rest of the
chrysalis, finally trying to change the
world.
She is trying not to hate her misshapen
wing.
I'm sorry, Tal, Cinnabar had whispered.
Clasping her front talons between her
own.
We talked about this.
You knew if there was fighting.
You wouldn't be able to join us.
It would be too dangerous for you.
You mean, I couldn't keep up with you.
Tao had answered ruefully.
Think about who we're fighting, though
Cinnabar had pressed.
What if you saw tree hopper on the
battlefield?
All wide eyes and zombie brain?
What if he attacked you?
Or me?
You're better off not having to face him
like that.
You'll be safe here until we win and come
back for you.
You'd better win.
Tao had hugged her, her heart beating
Biercely.
Being left behind was worse than she'd
expected, though.
Not knowing what was happening?
All her friends all fighting a battle
without her?
Wondering if they really did find an
antidote to the mind control.
Is Tree Hopper finally free of Queen
Wasp?
Or is he killing silk wings right now
dead eyed and soulless?
She shivers.
How will he ever forgive himself if Wasp
forces him to hurt his cow's friends?
There hasn't been any sign of the hive
wings since every single one of them
suddenly froze, pivoted to the nearest
window, and flew away north.
It's peaceful, with all of Jewel Hive
nearly empty, but also unsettling.
Tow.
Right.
Not every hive wing.
Lady Scarab marches into the kitchen and
eyes the meatballs so intently.
She practically sticks her nose into one
of them.
What is this?
She demands.
What herbs are you using?
Why does it smell like that?
Antelope meatballs?
Tao says patiently.
I have the only good recipe for antelope
meatballs, Lady Scarab announces.
If you didn't put chives in it, these
won't be worth eating.
I did put chives in it, Tao says.
Probably too many.
Lady Scarab sniffs.
Something crashes in the hall behind them
and they both turn toward the sound of
galloping talon steps.
Lady Jewel bursts into the kitchen, and
the sight of her face sends Tao straight
into full-blown panic.
Cinnabar was just here.
Joel gasps.
With a message.
The hive wings won.
They're burning the poison jungle.
And when they're done, they'll come here
and now they can mind control silk wings
as well.
What?
Tao clutches the counter, her talon
slippery with grease.
She can't process any piece of that
information, let alone all of it.
She latches on to the 1st thing.
Cinnabar is here?
Is she all right?
She only had time to give me the message
Jules says.
They have to get to the other hives as
fast as they can to warn the rest of the
silk wings.
I told her we'd get everyone here to
safety.
She glances around the room wildly, as
though she's considering trying to fit
every silk wing in the hive into one of
her potato barrels.
But how?
Tao asks.
Where can we go?
Her heart feels like it's squeezing
inward, shrinking into a nest of fear and
spikes.
They weren't supposed to lose.
It wasn't supposed to get worse.
Well, this is a fine mess.
Lady scarab hisses.
Now, who's going to take down my dreadful
niece?
Certainly would be nice if I had a
daughter, willing to fight for the throne
that should actually be ours.
Not now, mother, Jules says.
Cinnabar said to bring everyone to Lake
Scorpion.
There's somewhere we can go from there
she said, but we have to all go
together.
She presses her claws to her temples for
a moment.
We need messengers to check every level
of the hive.
Someone to go to the webs.
Dragons to carry the cocoons of any silk
wings and metamorphosis right now, others
to carry all the silk wing and hive wing
eggs in the hatcheries.
No, Scarab says.
Not the hive wing eggs, jewel.
We can't leave them behind, Joel
protests.
Oh, those tiny dragonettes.
They're already infected.
Scarab says bluntly.
As soon as they hatch.
Wasp will be able to see through their
eyes, and then she'll find us.
You can't bring them along, or you doom
everyone else.
Joel curls her talons and takes a deep
breath.
Tao knows she is thinking of her own
children, who are out of reach now
summoned along with everyone else.
Jewel had thought they were free of the
mind control, until they flew away with
all the other hive wings.
Maybe Scarab must guess Jules' thoughts
too.
Because she says, with unaccustomed
gentleness, I miss them too.
But it's better that we know at least.
She could have used them against us if
she'd left them here.
She still can, Jules says quietly.
Only if she can find you to threaten
you.
Scarab points out.
They'll be safer if you vanish.
Jewel doesn't answer, but her tail lashes
across the floor, knocking over a stack
of lemons.
Maybe we can bring some of the hive wing
eggs, Tao suggests.
The ones who have only been stabbed
once.
Remember?
Cricket said that wasp has to inject each
egg twice to be able to control them.
That was her theory.
Scarab growls.
She could be wrong.
It's too risky.
But if we can save some of them.
We have to, Joel says.
I'll think about it.
In the meanwhile, you 2 go bring as many
silk wings here as you can.
And then we'll split into teams.
She hurries out of the kitchen again
murmuring lists of tasks to herself.
Tao doesn't stop to hear any more of
scarab's grim warnings.
She runs out of the kitchen, through
Jules mansion, her talons skidding on the
floor.
She'll start with the other servants and
the prisoners and jewels dungeon.
How many silk wings are there in the
whole hive?
Will they all listen to her?
Or to Lady Jewel?
How fast can they escape?
Only as fast as our slowest dragons.
Which includes me.
The terror drives her onward, calling
dragon after dragon to the ballroom.
She can't get the images out of her
head.
Images of her friends, with white eyes
like the mind controlled hive wings
images of tree hopper slicing ruthlessly
through any silk wing who tries to stop
him, images of Queen Wasp, burning the
jungle, killing all the leaf wings
laughing her merciless laugh.
But Cinnabar got away from her.
So it's possible, if we can move fast
enough.
We have to escape.
We have to, or none of us will ever be
free again.
Snowfall woke up, extremely grumpy.
That is, first, she woke up in a state of
heart pounding panic, confused and
terrified about how she was suddenly
asleep on a beach when she should be
gathering dragons to escape jewel hive.
But as her heart rate gradually slowed to
normal, and she remembered who she
actually was, her natural grumpiness
returned to the power of 10.
What?
The moons was that.
She glanced down and saw that her claws
were shaking.
She shoved them as far into the sand as
she could until they stopped.
I said, no more visions.
She hissed the ring under her breath.
And this time, she couldn't even pretend
she'd just happened to dream about
someone she'd seen.
She'd never laid eyes on Tao in her life
and probably never would.
So either she had conjured an entire
imaginary dragon with a forbidden love
and revolutionary friends, and an entire
hive, and about a 1000000 more dragons to
worry about, where the stupid magic had
dragged her brain all the way across the
ocean, to torture her with scary things
she could do nothing about.
What is the point of this?
Snowfall heard someone floundering
through the sand toward her.
She lifted her head out of her hole, and
of course, it was lynx, looking all kinds
of wound up.
I have a theory.
Length cried.
As soon as she spotted Snowfall's face.
No, good morning, or hello, Your Majesty
or sorry for being a judgmental walrus
yesterday.
Snowfall shook out her wings irritably.
Marvelous, she said.
Let me guess, it involves me doing
something wrong.
You woke me up to ask me about weird
dreams yesterday.
Link said, pointing at her.
Because you had a weird dream.
And that ring you can't get off is called
The Gift of Vision, isn't it?
That's why you thought it was about
eyesight, but it's not.
I think it's giving you weird dreams
because they're not dreams.
They're visions.
Get it?
See what I mean?
Gift of vision.
Great eye spirits.
Stop talking already.
Snowfall growled.
I figured that out about a 100 years ago
but even if that's the case, it does not
explain why the ring is stuck on my claw
I still think it's broken.
But it is doing something.
Leng flicked her tail, and now her
expression was definitely veering toward
excited.
Maybe it's important.
Did you have another vision last night?
What was it about?
I thought you didn't trust animus magic
and wearing this was a terrible idea
Snowfall said accusingly.
I'm still right about that, Ling said, but
as long as you're stuck with it?
We should figure out what it's trying to
tell us.
It's not trying to tell me anything
Snowfall protested.
It's a ring, an inanimate object, with no
agenda or feelings.
Except maybe smugness.
You're very smug.
She snapped at the opal.
Snowball.
Tell me what you saw.
Links lashed her tail. sending up gusts
of sand.
Something happening back in the ice
kingdom, something that's going to
happen.
No, Snowfall barked.
Nothing useful.
Nothing about my tribe or my problems.
Nothing important at all.
If this is stupid magic, then it's really
stupid magic.
Why would I, queen of the ice wings, need
to know about all the inner emotions, of
a bunch of rainbow dragons from a
completely irrelevant continent that I'll
never see?
Inner emotions?
Links asked.
Like, you could feel what the silk wings
were feeling.
First, I was one of those stats now
Snowball said, pointing up the beach.
Her name is Atala, total tragedy vase.
And then last night, I was some random
dragon named Tao, who was stuck back over
there and freaking out.
Why would I need to see that?
It's not like I can do anything to help
her.
Not that she would have, even if she
could.
She wasn't going to invite more invasive
strange looking dragons here.
Hmm, Lang said.
Maybe you can.
Somehow.
Maybe, we just need to lay out everything
you learned from your visions and figure
out what to do about them.
That's not a gift.
That's homework. snowfall snapped.
I've had quite enough of that.
Thank you.
I'm queen now.
Other dragons should have to do the
things I don't want to do.
So tell me about it, Lang said eagerly.
And everything about the 1st one before
you forget it, and I'll figure out what
they mean.
Snowfall pointed one claw at her.
No.
I am going to ignore this nonsense.
Are these slow slug dragons ready to fly
to sanctuary yet?
Lanx looked as if she wanted to keep
arguing.
But she stayed quiet as she followed
Snowfall up the beach to investigate.
And no, of course nobody was ready to
go.
Of course, it took the foreign tribes the
entire morning to get organized.
And then they decided to leave half the
dragons behind, so the stronger ones
could go ahead and make sure there was a
place for everyone.
So then they had to resettle the ones
they were leaving behind, and then they
decided to take a break to eat
something.
By the time their wings finally lifted
into the sky, the sun was high above
them.
Snowfall was stalking back to summon the
rest of her guards.
When she heard someone say Queen Thorn's
name.
Her ears pricked, and she turned to see
Moon talking to the sandwing who wasn't
Jerboa.
I'll fly ahead and visit Thorn on the way
he said.
You know, in case she wants to know why
there's a flood of unusual looking
dragons flying over her kingdom.
Seems like something she might want to
heads up about.
Tell her where they're going.
Moon suggested.
Sanctuary is technically on the border of
Sandwing and Skywing territory, so she
should know that they're there.
Ha!
Snowfall thought to herself, pacing
forward again.
Let's see how she likes it.
If Thorn lets all these dragons flap
around over her desert and settle on her
border.
Maybe she isn't as strong a queen as
everyone thinks.
She wondered how Queen Ruby would feel
about these new dragons living on the
edge of Sky Wing territory.
Sanctuary was supposed to be a small
enclave, where dragons who couldn't go
home to their own kingdoms could live.
Dragons like Snowfall's cousin, Winter
who'd been banished, or the remaining
talons of peace, who wanted to stay with
one another more than they wanted to
return to their tribes.
Snowfall didn't think Ruby or Thorn had
ever imagined it, as a refuge for 100s of
strange dragons, when they agreed to let
the talons of peace build it.
And what happens if even more dragons
follow them here from Pantala?
Is Cinnabar trying to bring all the rest
of the silk wings over too?
All of them?
From all the hives?
Where else can they go?
With Queen Wasp and her brain washed hive
wings controlling all of Pentala.
Snowfall cut off that train of thought
with a hiss.
That's their problem.
Not my problem.
I have ice wings to take care of.
I'm not responsible for anyone else, and
I don't care about them.
The terrors seemed to still be lingering
in her veins though, and she couldn't
shake the urgent, panicked feeling that
she had to get an entire city of dragons
to safety before it was too late.
She wondered how old the vision was.
Had that scene happened last night, while
Snowfall dreamt it?
Or days earlier, like her vision of
Atala?
If it happened days ago, Where were Tao
and Duel, and Scarab now?
Safely hidden or captured?
Don't care, stop thinking about them.
Let's go, she ordered her guards.
They took up their positions in formation
around her, and followed the silk wings
and leaf wings away from the ocean, east
into the desert sky.
Snowfall glanced back and saw Jerboa
sitting outside her hut, watching them
leave.
Why doesn't she seem to care more that
her magic isn't working?
Snowfall wondered.
If she'd been an animus dragon, and then
suddenly her power was gone.
She'd have absolutely freaked out.
Jerboa, on the other talent, seemed
mostly amused by how much that annoyed
Snowfall.
It was still possible she was lying to
But if animus magic was working, wouldn't
tsunami's gang of righteous do-gooders
have used it to bring all the Pentalin
dragons to safety, or to stop Queen
Wasp?
They definitely would.
They used it to end the plague and stop
Dark Stalker.
They could solve all the Bental and
Dragon's problems with a snap of their
claws if they had magic right now.
So why don't they?
Why would magic just?
Stop working.
Snowfall, eyeball, the oval ring.
Do you know anything about this?
She growled at it.
Why do you work and actual useful magic
doesn't?
She shook out her talons grumpily and
glared at it again.
You know what?
How about instead of filling my head with
sympathy and nonsense, you give me some
information I really need.
Like a vision that explains what happened
to magic.
Maybe that's what she was doing wrong.
Maybe she needed to tell the ring what
vision she wanted.
Oh, that would be simple and so great.
Visions of anything she wanted.
Why hadn't she thought of this earlier?
Yes.
She said firmly.
You hear me, Ring?
Tonight?
No more silkwing nightmares.
Just a nice, uncomplicated scene where I
find out why animus magic isn't working.
This is a good plan.
Theopal caught the light and sparkled
rainbows at her.
Snowfall couldn't tell if those were
absolutely, Your Majesty, anything you
say, rainbows, or, ha, ha, ha.
I'll give you whatever I want to give you
and there's nothing you can do about it.
Ha ha.
Rainbows.
I guess I'll find out tonight.
She flew after the ribbon of dragons
stretched across the sky. trying to feel
confident that she'd solved her problem.
But it was hard to shake the ominous
feeling that maybe, just perhaps, she'd
stumbled into a more dangerous magic than
she'd expected.
Chapter 9.
The ice wings, leaf wings, and silk wings
flew in their weird, mismatched crowd
over the desert, which, incidentally, was
a dreadful place.
The sun beat down mercilessly, trying the
scales on snowfalls back until she felt
as if they might crack off.
How could anyone live in a place like
this?
It was so hot.
Blech.
The leaf wings looked almost as unhappy
about the heat as she was.
Their wing beats slowed as they flew
farther and farther from the ocean. and a
vast treeless landscape spread out below
them.
Rocks and sand, and sand and rocks, and a
whole lot of nothing.
Trubella kept saying that nobody would
want the ice kingdom, but who would
prefer this?
Of course, dragons would rather live in a
cool, beautiful, snowy, crystalline place
full of polar bears and walruses.
What did they have to eat here?
Tiny, brittle lizards, bony, gross
smelling camels?
It made much more sense the dragons would
want to invade the ice kingdom than
here.
Snowfall was absolutely right to worry
about defending it.
Moon had some kind of map from her
sandwing friend that showed each oasis
along their route, so they were able to
stop twice for water.
Snowfall waded all the way into the tiny
springs, trying to soak every drop into
her scales.
It suddenly seemed slightly insane to her
that her tribe had ever fought with the
sand wings.
When this territory was the absolute
worst, and they couldn't possibly want
anything here.
It was late in the afternoon when they
caught their 1st glimpse of the mountains
ahead, like a long giant dragon's spine
curled across the horizon.
They were mostly green and brown, but
dappled with glorious snow at the peaks.
Tao has never seen mountains, Snowfall
thought, and then caught herself thinking
that and was furious.
So what?
She demanded of her brain.
I've never seen one of these hive cities
and I'm perfectly happy about it.
She put on a burst of speed to catch up
to Hazel, who looked a little surprised
to be approached, but too tired to have
much more of a reaction.
Hello, question for you.
Snowfall said.
How many dragons did you leave behind?
On Jerboa's beach?
Hazel asked.
About, no, no, Snowfall interrupted.
Back on Pantala, how many dragons did you
leave there?
Oh, Hazel blinked.
Well, the, the leaf wing army, I guess
you'd call it?
Everyone who went with Queen Sequoia to
fight.
They must have been exposed to the breath
of evil right away.
They're probably under wasps' power now.
She bit her lip and burrowed her brow and
did some more odd things with her face
which Snowfall eventually realized were
all Hazel tried not to cry.
I hope some of them managed to escape
though.
And then there's the rest of the silk
wings and all the hives.
Hundreds of them, but I don't know
exactly how many.
The ones who flew over with us are only
from 3 of the hives, and they were in a
group called the chrysalis.
They'd come to the jungle to help us
fight the hive wings.
But that went horribly wrong, Snowfall
said.
And now all the silk wings you left
behind are in danger.
Yes?
Hazel trailed off and gave her a sideways
confused expression.
You sound kind of worried about them?
I'm not, Snowball cried.
I'm definitely not.
Maybe just a little worried about Tao, but
not really.
Only because of a dopey magic spell
giving me weird dreams.
No, she added firmly.
If I am at all worried, it is because I
am wondering whether all those dragons
are going to end up floundering into my
kingdom sometime soon as well.
It is very hard to get across the ocean
Hazel said.
I I mean, we hope they'll try.
But I can't predict how many, or if
they'll succeed, or when, if that's what
you're asking.
Nightwing!
Snowfall bellowed, startling Hazel into
losing her flight rhythm for a moment.
Up ahead, Moon twisted around, looking
puzzled.
Snowfall beckoned to her.
And Moon came soaring back to fly on the
other side of Hazel.
Yes?
Moon said cautiously.
You can see the future, can't you?
Snowfall demanded.
Winter told me you had some prophecy
about Dark Stalker, not that it helped
anyone at all.
Are you ever useful?
Can you predict if the other silk wings
are going to make it to this continent?
I, that's not, Moon stammered. flustered.
My visions aren't specific like that.
I caught a glimpse of this group arriving
but I haven't seen any other Pentalon
dragons.
That doesn't mean they won't make it
though.
And we can't poke your head to find out?
Snowfall asked.
Like summon a vision or whatever.
I thought you could, Hazel admitted.
I mean, I thought Clearside could.
From what I've read.
So I thought you all could see whatever
you wanted.
Moon shook her head.
Clearsight's power was unusual.
All I get is flashes whenever the
universe feels like giving them to me, and
the occasional cryptic prophecy.
She shut her mouth quickly, but Snowfall
had already caught the shift in her
eyes.
Aha, she said.
You had a cryptic prophecy about all this
didn't you?
That's right.
Tsunami said you did.
Hazel's eyes lit up.
Did it mention the breath of evil?
Did it tell you how we can rescue
everyone and save Pantala?
Not exactly.
Moon admitted reluctantly.
I mean, the key word here is cryptic
remember?
Tell us anyway, Snowfall commanded.
We will uncrypticate for you.
Moonside, and then recited.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire. to
the land across the sea, where dragons
are poisoned and dragons are dying, and
no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book.
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive.
Face a great evil with talent united, or
none of the tribes will survive.
There was silence for several wing beats
after she finished.
Hazel stared off into the sky ahead of
them, her brow furrowed, her mouth moving
as she repeated the prophecy quietly to
herself.
Well, Snowfall said finally.
I do not like that.
No, I do not.
Dark soccer was quiet enough great evil
for me.
She saw Moon flinch when she said Dark
Stalker's name, which was interesting.
Did the Nightwing feel guilty about
everything that had happened with him?
Or did she feel guilty because she was
totally lying about him actually being
gone?
Wasn't it possible that he was the great
evil?
After all, how many great evils could
there possibly be?
Hang on, she said, her thoughts swerving
onto a new track.
Did you say none of the tribes will
survive?
That's the prophecy.
Moon said, spreading her front talons in
an, I have no idea gesture.
But you mean none of the Pentalan
tribes.
Snowfall clarified, right?
Just those three?
Not the 7 tribes on this continent.
It has nothing to do with us, right?
I think it might mean all of us, Link
said.
Suddenly and very unwelcomely.
Snowfall hadn't even noticed her pop up
below them.
I mean, it starts off talking to us.
Turn your eyes to the land across the sea
right?
And then face a great evil with talons
united.
That sounds like it's talking about all
the tribes here and there.
Bosh. said Snowfall.
We can't unite to face an evil that's all
the way across the ocean, even if we
wanted to, which, to be clear, the ice
wing tribe does not.
There are 7 tribes here?
Hazel asked Moon.
Each with its own queen?
Moon nodded.
Yes.
We should call a council and see if
they'll all come, she said.
They should know about you and Pentala
and everything happening over there.
Oh, marvelous, Snowfall thought
gradually.
All the queens who annoy me in one place
arguing and telling me what to do.
On the plus side, staying in sanctuary
for a queen council would mean avoiding
the wall for a few more days.
But listening to Thorn, and Ruby, and
Morehen, and Coral, and worst of all
glory, go on and on about unity, and
working together, and mutual trust, and
all that sort of nonsense, was basically
Snowfall's nightmare.
Blur.
I'll tell Tsunami, Moon said, tilting her
wings.
I'm sure she can organize some dragons
from sanctuary. to take messages to the
queens.
She flew off toward the pair of sea
wings.
It's amazing that all your queens get
along so well, Hazel said wistfully.
I wish we could have 3 tribes peacefully
coexisting on Pentala.
Ha!
Snowfall said.
Peacefully coexisting?
We just got out of a war.
Two, technically, if you count the ice
wing night wing war, I tried to have
before that busybody animus interfered.
You did?
Hazel said, wide-eyed.
Long story.
Snowfall added with a snort.
I'll explain it.
Links offered, and then spent the rest of
the flight telling Hazel about the War of
Sandwing succession, and how it started
and all about the prophecy, and how the
shiny heroic dragonettes finally ended
it.
Personally, Snowfall thought they got an
awful lot of credit considering the real
heroes were a deadly snake, and an old
enchanted orb.
If there'd been an ice wing in the
prophecy, she probably would have ended
the war way sooner and more neatly.
But whatever, not snowfall's problem.
As they started their descent into
sanctuary, Snowfall was startled to see
how much bigger it was than she'd
imagined.
The new Dragon Village was built along a
stream, trickling downhill from a lake in
the foothills of the Claws of the Clouds
Mountains.
Some of the new dragon buildings were in
the wildflower meadows, while some were
under the trees of the forest.
It was very disorganized.
As far as snowfall could see.
Each dragon home looked completely
different from the next.
Here there was a weird mound of clay, with
a hole at the top.
Then right beside it, there'd be a rough
cabin made of logs and leaves.
While over by the lake, there were a
couple of crooked structures poking half
in and half out of the water.
Upon landing, Snowfall noticed that there
were also more dragonettes than she'd
expected, and some of them were really
odd looking.
The 1st one she saw was a tiny thing
playing in the stream, pouncing on fish.
Its scales were a deep mahogany brown
like a mud wings.
But speckled with phosphorescent bluish
scales along its spine and wings, and as
far as she could tell, its talons were
webbed like a sea wings.
Nearby, a little cluster of orange and
red dragonettes were gathered around a
sky wing, listening as he read them a
scroll.
But 2 of the red dragonettes had scorpion
like tail barbs, and one of the orange
ones had a scattering of black scales
across its nose.
Snowfall's brain was still contorting
itself around this information when a sky
blue sea wing came bounding out of the
trees toward them.
Tsunami, he cried, as though the sun
itself had arrived to visit him.
His whole face was full of joy, which
made no sense, because who could possibly
be that excited to see the very absolute
most annoying member of the Dragonette
prophecy.
Hey, riptide, she said, in a voice that
sounded as confident as she usually did
but didn't quite match the funny look on
her face.
The 2 sea wings awkwardly tried to hug
and their wings all went in the wrong
directions, and they ended up bonking
heads and then jumping back and flapping
about for a bit.
Snowfall guessed, there was something she
could infer from their strange
interaction.
She wasn't all that interested.
She was looking around for her cousin
Winter.
Was that a flash of white scales in the
trees?
Snowfall squinted, but whoever it was had
vanished again.
Or maybe it had been a trick of the
light.
It's so great to see you, Riptide was
saying to tsunami.
I was hoping you'd come see all the
changes we.
His voice trailed off as his eyes
followed the line of dragons behind her
up into the sky, where more and more
dragons were arriving as the slowpokes
caught up.
What?
Riptide tried.
Um, Surprise, tsunami said buoyantly.
New dragons for sanctuary.
New.
All these, but Riptide sputtered.
Are those rain wings?
asked a new voice from Snowfall's right.
She turned and saw Winters flashing
through the stream, staring up at the
arriving silk wings.
Hmm, So that couldn't have been him in
the woods.
Winter, Lynx cried with delight.
He jumped and dropped his gaze to her, and
then to snowfall standing right next to
her.
Lynx, he said in a wondering voice.
Snowfall?
What are you doing here?
Length cleared her throat and bobbed her
head meaningfully in Snowfall's
direction.
I mean, apologies.
Your majesty, he said to Snowfall.
Welcome to Sanctuary.
He even bowed properly, which was
mollifying.
I have come to inspect this new city
Snowfall informed him.
And to make sure these peculiar dragons
settle here, and don't try to come back
into the ice kingdom.
Not that they can, Links observed, given
the cliff and everything.
Are they hybrids?
Winter asked, tilting his head at a leaf
wing who was burying her snout in the
stream.
We have a lot of those here.
Suing rain wing maybe?
But there's so many.
His eyes widened as a silk wing landed
stumbling beside tsunami.
That dragon has 4 wings, he whispered to
Lynx.
Wait.
So does that one, and that one.
They're from the other continent.
Links burst out.
Flinging excitement in all directions.
It's real winter.
It's full of dragons, totally different
tribes.
The colorful ones are silk wings, and the
green ones are leaf wings, and there are
also two...
There, see the yellow and black ones.
Those are hive wings.
Snowfall had almost never seen her cousin
look confused, let alone this
discombobulated.
It kind of made the whole trip to
sanctuary worthwhile.
Something caught her eye in the trees
again.
A flash of reflected light in the bushes
a shimmer of scales behind the leaves.
But when she turned toward it, there was
nothing but wind aimlessly stirring the
forest floor.
She trusted her instincts though.
Another ice wing was hidden over there
watching her.
And whoever it was, they did not want to
be seen.
Chapter 10.
Are there other ice wings here?
Snowfall asked Winter.
A few, he said, with a guarded
expression.
Didn't you know that?
She looked down her snout at him.
Of course, I know that.
I merely wish to know how many, and who
exactly.
I think I shouldn't be the one to tell
you that.
Your Majesty, he said.
I don't know their reasons for being
here.
But I'm sure they'll tell you, if you
want to ask them.
Snowfall considered finding this
irritating enough to yell at him.
She could do that now that she was the
queen, and he wouldn't be able to argue
back at her or run away the way he
sometimes did when they were
dragonettes.
She missed her chance, though, because
while she was thinking, that awful night
wing landed and sucked up all the air
around Winter's head.
Moon, he said, in a quiet, wondering
voice.
Hey, Winter, Moon said nervously.
She batted one of her wings at him
without actually touching him.
We really miss you at Jade Mountain.
I miss you too, he said.
All of you.
I mean, everything, I miss.
I miss everyone.
So why aren't you still there?
Links asked.
For some reason, they all looked at
snowfall.
She waited a beat to see if that was a
mistake, and then when everyone kept
looking at her, she said, what?
You're the one who said he couldn't go
back to the academy, Moon offered.
I did?
Snowfall considered this news for a
moment.
She couldn't remember making a royal
decree like that, or even thinking about
it at all.
She knew 2 new ice wing dragonettes had
been chosen to go to the academy, and now
that she thought about it, Those were
probably replacing icicle and winter.
But she had no recollection of anyone
asking her whether Winter could keep
being a student there or not.
She had decided he was still banished
from the ice kingdom, but she didn't
particularly care what he did outside the
ice kingdom.
I don't actually care.
She informed Winter.
You can go ahead and study hugs and
whatever nonsense happens at that school
if you want to.
I have much more important things to deal
with, like these homeless dragons and all
the ones they left behind.
She waved her wings of the tribes that
were still landing around them.
The meadow was starting to get a bit
crowded.
Riptide was starting to look slightly
panic stricken.
The ones they left behind?
Links echoed, giving her almost the exact
same puzzled look Hazel had given her
earlier.
As if it was so weird for snowfall to
feel even a hint of concern for all the
silk wings, still trapped with a creepy
evil thing over there.
I'm not saying they should come here.
Snowfall snapped at her.
But I don't expect these dragons to just
give up on them.
One of the leaf wings by the stream
looked up, and gave her a fierce, intense
stare.
Snowfall recognized her from the day
before.
She was the one who might be a threat to
Hazel's crown.
Sun something.
The one who was always frowning and
glaring and looking ready for a fight.
What?
Snowfall demanded.
We are not giving up on them, the leaf
wing said with a hiss.
We won't abandon them.
The leaf wing beside her brushed her wing
gently.
No one is saying we will, she said.
This pile of icicles just did, snapped
the 1st leaf wing.
No, love.
The 2nd one said calmly.
Actually, if you were listening, Queen
Snowfall is saying exactly what you've
been saying for the last 3 days, that we
need to make a plan to go back and save
everyone.
Yes, exactly.
That is what I meant.
Snowfall thought.
Not because I care about any of those
dragons over there.
Just because I want all of these ones to
be able to go away again.
I'm Willow.
The 2nd Leaf Wing said to Winter.
And this is Sundew.
We're very worried about the dragons who
are still stuck back on Pentala.
We should go back now, right away, Sundu
said.
Even if it's just you and me and Cricket
we should take them by surprise before
the breath of evil gets any stronger.
Moon shuddered.
And Winter turned to her quickly.
No, not a vision, she said, before he
could ask.
Just those words, breath of evil.
They scare me every time.
Imagine how you'd feel.
If you were stuck on the same continent
with it, Snowfall said.
And then half of them gave her the weird
look, again.
Maybe the ring was also turning her
horn's bright pink or something?
Otherwise, it made no sense that everyone
kept reacting as though she'd vomited
miniature caribou each time she spoke.
Fortunately, tsunami and ribtide and
Hazel arrived to create a distraction.
Riptide has plenty of room here, Tsunami
announced briskly.
Everyone can stay.
That's not what I said.
Riptide objected.
I said, I don't know where we can
possibly put them all, but they can stay
for a few nights while we figure this
out.
Ha!
Snowfall flicked her tail at tsunami.
C, even your precious friend and his
heartwarming togetherness project.
Don't want all these sad snouts.
I'm not the bad guy.
My reaction is the normal one.
No offense, she added to Hazel.
Tsunami shot a glare at riptide, and he
backpedaled quickly.
Of course, I want them, he said.
We can make this work.
I mean, this more than quadruples the
number of dragons living here, but, but
um, I just have to, and maybe if we...
But then the.
I mean, yes, yes, of course, they can
stay.
Great, tsunami said.
Now beaming at him.
I knew we could count on you.
We can help, Hazel promised.
Leave wings prefer to build our homes in
the trees anyway, so we won't take up any
extra ground space, and the silk wings
can make their own webs.
Maybe their silk could be useful.
Snowfall could tell that Hazel was trying
really hard, not to glance pointedly at
some of the more ram shackle buildings
around them.
Besides, we're not staying long.
Sundew cut in.
We're going back to Pentala, just as soon
as we figure out how to defeat the breath
of evil.
Hazel and Willow exchanged a glance that
made even snowfall feel all bristly.
She wasn't surprised when sundew let out
a hiss and stalked off toward the lake.
Clean snowfall, Hazel said.
Would you be able to stay with us a few
more days?
Me?
Snowfall said, fluffing out her wings.
Here, why?
So we can summon the other queens, of
course. tsunami said, for a big old queen
summit.
Not because we want you around.
Don't worry.
Don't be rude to my queen, Link said
sharply.
I'd really appreciate it, Your Majesty
Hazel interjected, her eyes wide.
You're the only one I know.
I'd feel so much better if I had a friend
among the queens.
Three moon, Snowfall.
Tell me you are not melting into a puddle
just because this strange green dragon
called you a friend.
She doesn't know you at all. and vice
versa.
Why would I even want a friend from
another tribe?
What good can she possibly do for the ice
wings?
It's not like an alliance with her would
make us stronger.
But there are other perfectly logical
queenly reasons to stay.
I mean, I don't want all the other queens
meeting without me.
Who knows what they would say about me if
I wasn't here.
They might plot and scheme, and make smug
faces.
Staying is the right thing to do for the
ice wing tribe.
I need to know what everyone is up to
anyway.
Very well, Snowfall said, trying to sound
bored.
We can stay until the other queens arrive
but tell them to make it snappy.
I can't be gone from my palace for too
long.
Let's go choose the messengers, Riptide
said to tsunami, tugging her away before
she could say whatever snarky thing was
building up inside her snout.
Show me around.
Leng said to Winter.
I want to see everything.
Of course, he said.
And then after a moment of hesitation
added, Moon, do you want to come too?
The Nightwing nodded a little vaguely.
She had a kind of distracted air about
her most of the time, as though invisible
dragons were whispering in her ears while
everyone was talking.
Oh, Snowfall realized.
Because she's listening to our thoughts.
I know you can hear my thoughts
Nightwing.
Here's one for you.
I think your entire tribe is a bunch of
malevolent fire snorting toads.
Moon jumped slightly, gave Snowfall a
wounded look, and followed winter and
lynx off into the meadow.
Hazel and Willow stood around for a
moment, as though they weren't sure that
Snowfall was done with them, and then
finally went off in the same direction
Sundew had gone.
Snowfall waded into the stream, which was
brilliantly cold, like melted snow.
She stood there, letting her scales cool
down, as she studied the dragon scattered
across sanctuary.
From where she stood, she could see
dragons from almost every tribe.
Sand wings, sky wings, sea wings, mud
wings, even a couple of rain wings.
Although at 1st glance, she mistook them
for silk wings.
But no ice wings, as far as she could
see.
She was about to think, well, ha.
That makes sense because our kingdom is
so amazing.
Why would anyone want to leave it?
But then she had to admit, she didn't see
any night wings either, which sort of
undercut her theory.
And Winter said there were other ice
wings here.
So where were they?
Why hadn't they come out to see the giant
throng of new visitors?
The sanctuary dragons seemed curious
rather than afraid of the strange
tribes.
Snowfall wondered if that was because
some of them were so odd looking
themselves, or because they were used to
living with other kinds of dragons
already.
She watched the little brown dragon with
phosphorescent blue scales dart up to a
silk wing, circle his talons slowly, and
then sit down to gulp up at his 4 indigo
and orange wings.
And then another flicker of white caught
her gaze.
Moving through the trees on the other
side of the meadow.
That was definitely an ice wing.
Snowfall bounded out of the water and
charged across the grass, scattering
clumsy dragonettes in her wake.
In the shadows of the trees.
There was a whirl of white wings as the
ice wing turned and fled.
Fled from her.
Queen Snowfall, the indignity.
Snowfall doubled her pace as she plunged
into the trees.
Pine needles slipped under her talons, and
the smell of damp leaves filled her
snout.
Squirrels shouted angry chirpy things at
her as she raced past, dodging tree
trunks.
Ahead.
She could see her praise white tail
flickering.
The shady forest at twilight wasn't
exactly the best place for an ice wing to
hide.
The best place is the Ice Kingdom
Snowfall thought irritably.
Why would any sensible dragon ever leave
it?
Because of me.
Her brain offered with an awful jolt.
Because they think I'm a terrible queen.
Just like all the dragons in that night
wing battle.
Maybe ice wings are sneaking out of the
kingdom in droves, because they're afraid
I'm going to ruin the whole tribe, or do
something dreadful.
She shook her head fiercely.
It was unlikely she'd catch this dragon
with speed, since she was tired from
flying all day.
She could try throwing a spear or a knife
although that would be kind of a violent
way to find out who it was.
But wait.
She had magic.
Snowfall skidded to a stop, and banged
the wristbands of stealth together
imagining herself invisible.
And then she was.
She couldn't even see her own talons.
The bushes behind her seemed to shiver in
a non-existent breeze as she flicked them
with her tail.
She carried on after the fleeing ice wing
but now she moved more slowly, trying to
sneak up on whoever it was.
It was hard to be quiet in such a noisy
crackly yippy place, but soon she heard
someone gasping for air up ahead.
The ice wing thought snowfall had lost
its trail.
It had stopped, panting, next to a giant
boulder half covered in poison ivy.
Snowfall crept toward it, one talon, then
the next, keeping her eyes fixed on the
shimmering white scales beyond the
foliage, and then...
She pounced.
Debris flew up in all directions as she
slammed into the ice wing, tumbling
talons over wings until they both crashed
into the bare side of the boulder.
Snowfall were covered first.
She shook out her wings and leaped to pin
down the other dragon.
Her captive shrieked.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Snowfall blinked down at the pale blue
eyes, the long, graceful neck, and the
unmistakable face of her missing sister.
Part two.
Sanctuary and scavengers.
Chapter 11.
Crystal?
Snowfall blurted.
She set up and used the bracelets to turn
herself visible again.
Her sister's eyes widened as snowfalls
shimmered into view.
Did you follow me here?
Follow you?
Crystal said indignantly.
You're the one who chased me through the
woods.
Because you were lurking suspiciously
Snowfall cried.
How long have you been watching me?
I have not been watching you.
Crystal objected.
I don't have any desire to watch you.
I've been staying far away from you.
You're the one who came to my nice, quiet
place.
What are you doing here?
She pushed ineffectively at Snowfall's
talons.
Also, can you please get off already?
Wait.
Snowfall said, backing up so Crystal
could climb to her feet.
You mean, you've been here?
In sanctuary?
This whole time?
She was having about 80,000 emotions at
once, and it was very overwhelming.
Did this mean Crystal hadn't been
skulking around the ice palace at any
point?
But what about her nefarious plot?
And why would she come here?
Was snow fall in danger?
Was this all a trap?
Admittedly, even she couldn't quite
imagine how Crystal could have engineered
an invasion of mystery dragons just to
get snowfall to visit sanctuary.
But her pounding heart and shaking claws
were having some trouble coming up with
any other explanation for this.
Crystal.
Here.
Lying in wait.
Crystal glanced around as though she had
never thought about where she was.
I mean, I suppose I've been here since
mother died, more or less.
She said.
Doing what?
Snowfall demanded.
Plotting, gathering an army, hiring
assassins?
Her sister looked faintly amused.
If I wanted to hire an assassin, I
wouldn't start in a community of
scavenger huggers like this.
I'd go straight to the Scorpion Den.
So you have thought about it.
Snowfall said accusingly.
A sudden crashing in the undergrowth
warned Snowfall just in time.
She spun as a dragon threw himself out of
the trees at her head.
He flew past, clipping her on the nose
with his wings and ricocheted off the
boulder.
She ducked again as he lunged back toward
her, but this time, he was able to pivot
and slam her into a tree.
I knew it.
I knew Crystal was planning to kill me.
Crystal was shouting something, but
Snowfall couldn't hear the words over the
grunts and snarls of her opponent as she
kicked him in the chest.
He had brown scales, and a flat square
head, and heavy talons, a mud wing.
Crystal had formed an alliance with a mud
wings.
Did she have Queen Moorhen on her side?
Snowfall had always found Moorhen the
least annoying of the other queens, but
maybe her quiet demeanor was all in act
while she conspired with Crystal.
With a hiss of rage, Snowfall summoned
the strength magic.
She sank her talons into the mud wing and
threw him off into the forest.
He hurtled out of sight, smashing a path
through the branches.
A moment later, there was a resounding
bud in the distance.
Crystal shrieked and pelted after him, and
Snowfall chased her into the trees.
That's what happens, she shouted at her
sister.
I'm not as easy to kill as you think.
Crystal didn't even look back.
She ran full tilt along the path of
destruction until she found the mud wing
lying flat on his back at the other end
wings flung out to either side.
Carry on, she cried, crouching beside
him.
Gary, are you all right?
Saving.
Ew.
He wheezed.
Not very well, you great hippo.
Crystal scolded.
She wasn't even attacking me.
But...
Dangerous.
He managed to gasp.
Crystal looked over her shoulder at
Snowfall, who had paused the edge of the
glade, puzzled by the tableau.
Crystal was clutching the mud wings front
talons in her own, and he had this
bonkers moony expression on his face as
he gazed up at her.
He must have hit his head really hard to
be making that face, especially a crystal
of all dragons.
Are you here to kill me?
Crystal asked Snowfall.
No, Snowfall said.
I mean, not unless you're planning
something.
Should I?
Kill me?
No, thank you, Crystal said.
Snowfall, how could I possibly be
plotting against you or trying to kill
you?
We swore an oath to our mother, remember?
I promised not to try to take the throne
from you.
Yes, Snowfall said, but...
You...
But still, what if you...
She trailed off.
Somehow it had never occurred to her that
Crystal would take that oath so
seriously.
I mean, if you're not plotting something
why did you disappear?
She demanded.
Well, Crystal said, to be honest, I was
pretty sure you were going to kill me.
The oath said not to fight for the
throne.
It didn't say anything about keeping your
sisters and possible threats alive.
Snowfall snorted.
I'm not the kind of queen who kills all
her heirs just to feel safe.
That's pure stupidity.
I also.
I had somewhere else I wanted to be.
Crystal said, looking down at the mud
wing again.
Or rather, someone else I wanted to be
with.
Snowfall tilted her head at them.
This still made no sense to her.
Where else would anyone want to be
besides the Ice Kingdom?
Here, in this noisy, fluttery forest full
of dragons from other tribes?
Why?
Snowfall?
This is Gariol.
Crystal said.
We met during the war, when his troop
joined our army to fight blister.
Once I was home again, I couldn't stop
thinking about him.
Oh, Snowfall said.
Oh.
Now Crystal was making the same schmoopy
face as he had, and she didn't have a
head injury as an excuse.
Crystal was in love with this mud wing.
Of all the absurd brain melt.
This is the secret length guest she had.
I think, I think mother knew, actually
Crystal said, or guessed, at least.
I think that might be partly why she
didn't give me the crown.
Because she was so horrified.
Snowfall supplied.
Crystal whipped her head up and frowned
at her.
No, because she knew it would tear me
apart if I had to choose between the ice
wing throne and the dragon I love.
He could never come to the ice palace.
If I were queen, there'd be no future for
us.
This was the silliest thing Snowfall had
ever heard.
Choosing a romance over being queen of an
entire kingdom?
A romance with a mud wing?
No less.
For the 1st time since the Battle with
the Night Wings.
Snowfall felt a brief, shining moment of
you know what?
My mother did pick the right dragon to be
queen.
All that worrying.
The endless nightmares and stress, and
peering around corners, thinking crystal
was lurking in every shadow with
murderous intent, and the whole time
crystal was here, throwing away her
kingdom, and being a total sap about
someone who was, frankly, a very ordinary
looking brown dragon.
Well, Snowfall said, sitting down, folding
her wings neatly and letting out a yawn.
You could have told me instead of
sneaking off and giving me a month long
panic attack.
Could I have told you?
Crystal said skeptically.
Wouldn't you have made that exact
disgusted face and tried to forbid me
from leaving?
Snowfall made an effort to rearrange her
expression, but she could tell it wasn't
working.
Probably, she agreed.
Because what are you thinking?
A mudwing?
I'm right.
Here.
Gary All said weakly.
You don't know anything about love.
Crystal said haughtily, flicking her tail
at snowfall.
Or mud wings, for that matter.
Yeah, and I'm way better off that way
Snowfall pointed out.
She got up and turned back toward the
center of sanctuary.
Very well then.
If you're really not planning to
assassinate me, I'm going to bed.
Nice to meet you.
Gary old wheezed as she left.
Snowfall's wings ached from flying all
day, but she felt lighter than she could
remember feeling in forever.
As though her scales were made of
moonlight.
Shining to the dark clouds that had been
around her.
Mother knew I'd be a better choice than
Crystal.
Because I care about the kingdom more
than anything.
She glanced up at the 2 moons that were
already visible in the twilight sky, and
her talons stumbled over a fallen
branch.
Or, She knew Crystal's secret, so she was
forced to choose me.
Maybe she would have picked her, but she
was stuck with me instead because she
knew Crystal might leave.
Snowfall sighed.
That shining moment hadn't lasted very
long.
She found her way back to the sanctuary
lake, and waded in to wash off all the
dirt of the forest, and clean the
scratches that Mudwing had given her.
Her guards looked surprisingly pleased to
see her, although she guessed that was
because they'd have a hard time
explaining how they'd lost the queen to
everyone back home.
They followed her to a spot on the lake
shore, a fair distance away from all the
other dragons, and formed a perimeter
around her while she tried to scratch
together enough moss for a comfortable
sleeping spot.
Snowfall wondered where Lynx was.
Having a jolly, marvelous time with
winter and moon, no doubt, romping around
sanctuary, telling stories about
everything Snowfall had already done
wrong as queen, laughing at her.
Can you believe she was dumb enough to
get an animus touched ring stuck on her
claw?
That sort of thing.
She tried once more to pull it off, and
when that didn't work, of course, she lay
down and stared gloomily at the ring in
the darkness.
It had nothing to say for itself.
Not even a smug twinkle tonight.
Remember what I told you, she thought
added fiercely.
I demand a specific vision.
I want to know what happened to animus
magic.
If you must haunt my dreams tonight.
That is the vision I choose to summon.
I am your queen, and that is my command.
You hear me?
Impudent silence from the ring.
Snowfall sighed, closed her eyes, and
drifted uneasily towards sleep.
Chapter 12.
Her wings are green and they miss the
sun.
Her claws hurt from walking on stone
instead of dirt for days.
She is hungry.
There is not enough food for all the
dragons they are hiding.
But every time someone goes out to get
more, they fly back with terrifying
stories of hive wing swarms hunting the
savannah.
For them, the dragons who burned
bloodworm hive.
Or for sundew and her allies.
She's not sure.
A gray dragon is curled beside her, asleep
with his head resting on her shoulder, and
his tail twined around hers.
He is the sweetest dragon the world has
ever seen.
He thinks she's a hero for destroying his
home.
He loves her when she's angry, just as
much as when she's cheerful.
She has no idea how she fell in love with
a gentle silk wing, but she will murder
anyone who hurts him.
Another leaf wing enters the cave, and
she motions for him to whisper, so he
won't wake Grayling.
Strange happenings above, he says
quietly.
Pokeweed just got back, and he says he
saw silk wings flying with the hive
wings.
What's strange about that?
she asks.
Silkwings have been working for hive
wings for so long.
I'm sure some have been forced to help
with a hunt, that's all.
No, Hemlock says with a sigh.
All flying the same way, in formation.
Exact wing movements, all in sync.
He took a deep breath.
And they had white eyes.
She blinks at him.
That's impossible.
Wasp's power doesn't work on silk wings.
I guess it does now.
He rubs his face.
Where's pokeweed?
She asks.
I want to know exactly what he saw.
You went deeper into the caves, Hemlock
answers.
Still trying to catch those monkey
looking creatures.
They've seen the underground monkeys
scurrying out of sight a few times, but
none of the 3 leaf wings have managed to
eat one yet.
They're either faster than they look, or
surprisingly clever.
There's something worse, Hemlock says
reluctantly.
One of the silk wings said, she saw leaf
wings up there too.
She flinches so hard, she knocks Grayling
awake.
He sits up, yawning and brushing her
wings with his.
He's too thin.
She wishes she could protect him better
from the hunger.
And from this news.
That can't be right, she says to Hemlock
with a low hiss.
We saw all that smoke in the north, he
says bleakly.
Maybe Queen Wasp burned the poison jungle
to punish us for burning bloodworm hive.
Maybe our tribe lost and now.
No, they're out there somewhere, Graham
interrupts.
He gives her a look with more trust in it
than she's ever felt about anything.
The leaf wings have survived terrible
things before.
They'll fight back.
The hive wings won't win.
They can't.
She wants to feel that way so badly.
She doesn't know what will hurt more.
To believe the worst.
So if it's true, she can't feel any
lower.
Or to hold on to hope, but run the risk
of being crushed.
I wish we could do something, she says.
I wish we knew what was happening.
I thought Belladonna would have sent us a
message by now.
Maybe we should go fight the hive wings
Grayling suggests.
With all the silk wings from bloodworm
hive, there are so many of us down here
couldn't we fight them?
Not if Queen Wasp can control silk wings
and leaf wings now.
She doesn't add that silk wings are kind
of useless fighters.
She takes graylings, front talons as his
face crumbles.
Don't worry.
Wasp is never getting you.
Never, never, never.
But what is she going to do?
They can't hide underground for the rest
of their lives.
But if they can't go back to the poison
jungle either.
Is there anywhere they can possibly be
safe?
When Snowfall awoke, there was another
dragon line close beside her, one wing
resting on hers, and she had to stare at
the dragon's soothing white scales for
entirely too long before she realized it
wasn't graming.
Of course it wasn't graving.
Gray Lane was stuck on the other side of
the ocean.
Grayling was a silk wing, in a cave, under
a continent snowfall was never going to
see, which was great news because that
continent sounded more and more dreadful
every time she visited it.
No, the impertinent dragon sleeping next
to her was lynx.
Snowfall poked her face until Lynx's eyes
fluttered open.
Oh, length grumbled.
Rude.
She turned her face away and buried it
under her other wing.
What's rude is sleeping on the queen's
tail, Snowfall barked.
Get off.
Links rolled away, still muttering, and
then suddenly shook herself and sat up.
What happened last night?
she asked, blinking.
Did you have another vision?
Yes.
Snowfall admitted reluctantly, even
though this was exactly why she'd woken
links in the 1st place.
I was a stupid leaf wing this time.
One of the ones here?
No.
Snowfall shook her head.
Her name is Bryany.
She knows that sundew dragon, though.
Length slammed her talon down on
something small and furry that was
scurrying through the undergrowth.
Ooh, maybe that means you're supposed to
tell Sunu about your vision.
No, I do not need a 1000 more dragons
having opinions about my magic head
trips.
One is far more than enough.
Snowfall glared at the ring.
She was starting to feel a little more
like herself, but the quiet, worried
Briony personality was still shifting
under her scales, and it was so
unsettling.
You stupid broken thing.
She hissed balefully at the opal.
That vision had nothing to do with animus
magic.
Shimmer, shimmer, shimmer.
Theobal winked back serenely.
Snowfall stood up and flapped her wings
trying to shake off the lingering strands
of affection for the adorable gray silk
wing.
He was different from the others.
He was special and beloved, and what was
happening to her?
Melting like a snowball in the desert
over a strange dragon she'd never met, who
was definitely not her type, even if she
did?
Was this how Crystal felt about that
mudwing?
Snowball shot another suspicious glance
at the ring.
Was it trying to hit her over the head
with a lesson about sympathy and
understanding?
Yuck.
Am I going to have dreams like this for
the rest of my life?
Will I still be me?
If I spend every night as an entirely
different dragon?
I saw a crystal yesterday?
She informed Length abruptly.
She lives here now.
Lanx's eyes widened, and she put down her
half eaten prey.
No way.
She was here the entire time?
She grinned.
There was a tuft of mouth for a caught in
her teeth.
So wait.
Doesn't that mean she was not plotting
against you after all?
She ran away to be with a mudwing
Snowfall said with a snort.
Hmm, Lang said.
Sounds like maybe you were being
extremely paranoid and anxious about
nothing then?
And just possibly, that might apply to
other things you are extremely paranoid
about?
You are the most aggravating dragon in
the world.
Snowball observed.
She had a sense that normally she would
be furious with links, and that she
should be yelling, and perhaps throwing
her in the lake, but it was hard to get
worked up about a little insubordination
when Briony was stuck underground, and
Grayling was in danger of being mind
controlled, and she had no idea if Tao
had escaped Jewel Hive, or whether any of
them would ever find one another.
Lynx studied her for a moment, with a
crease of worry along her forehead, and
then she shook herself vigorously.
Come see what our lunatic friend Winter
has done.
Friend seemed like a bit of a stretch. in
Snowfall's opinion, but she was
definitely up for a distraction.
So she followed links along the lake
shore, back through sanctuary.
Not far from the water's edge in an area
that had been cleared of trees.
There was an odd space surrounded by a
tall fence.
The fence was made of entire tree trunks
lashed together, so it was very high, and
snowfall had to crane her neck to see
over it.
Inside, there was a dragon made pool of
water, a pile of leaves and pine needles
with a small leaf canopy over it, and
something that darted around so
energetically, it took snowfall a moment
to figure out what it was.
Great eye spirits, she said to Lynx.
I thought he was over his scavenger
obsession.
Winter poked his head out of a hut near
the fence.
I'm not, he said huffily.
Why would I be?
Scavengers are fascinating.
You are so weird.
Snowball said.
Nobody else keeps their lunch in a pretty
cage for months to study it.
She's not lunch, he said, outraged.
My scavenger is a research subject.
I'm learning so much about them.
They're really smart.
Snowfall rolled her eyes.
What happened to that droopy one mother
let you have when you went off to
school?
Bandit.
I had to let him go, Winter said
tragically.
I have no idea what was wrong with him.
But this one is different.
This one has bitten him 5 times.
Lynx whispered to Snowfall.
She's very brave, he said, with a hint of
pride.
She's come up with all kinds of ways to
escape.
Snowfall peered over the top of the fence
again.
The scavenger had a long tail of dark fur
on her head, tied up with a scrap of
fabric that might have been bright yellow
at some point.
She was now marching up and down the
length of the vents, shoving each of the
logs and testing them for footholds.
Moon says she's really mad.
Ling told Snowfall.
What?
Snowfall said.
Why would Moon be mad about this?
No, I mean, the scavenger is mad.
She really wants to get out of there.
Snowfall frowned at length.
Are you trying to suggest that that night
wing can read scavenger minds as well?
Not exactly, Winter answered.
It's not as clear as reading Dragon Minds
but she gets a sense of their emotions.
She says, they're just as strong and
complicated as dragon emotions, he added
with a little smile.
I'm not going to dignify this
conversation with any more of my
attention, Snowfall said.
That is the most ridiculous thing I've
ever heard.
Winter's being ridiculous.
A new voice suddenly chimed in.
If so, that's me.
I did that.
All credit to me.
I built his entire sense of humor from
the ground up.
The ice wings whirled around to find a
pair of sand wings emerging from the
trees.
The one speaking was in front, bounding
toward winter with an irrepressible grin
on his face.
He was the one from the beach.
Snowfall was pretty sure.
Moon's friend.
Oh, no.
Winter said dryly.
There goes the neighborhood.
Aw, I can see it in your eyes.
You missed me so much said the sand
wing.
He threw one wing affectionately over
Winter's shoulders, and nudged the side
of his neck with his snout.
I missed you too, best friend.
Snowfall raised her eyebrows at Winter
who said, I have no idea who this scruffy
snout is.
His favorite dragon in the world, the
Sandwing said with genuine delight.
Did we ever officially meet your
majesty?
He asked no fall.
I'm Kibley, Queen Thorn's 2nd in command
basically.
Ha, said the other sandwing, and then
started actually laughing as Kibley gave
her an offended look.
Link snudged Snowfall in the ribs, but
she had already recognized the laughing
dragon.
Snowfall had made a diplomatic trip to
each of the kingdoms soon after becoming
queen, very much against her will, but
apparently it was one of those things the
queen was required to do.
Queen Thorn, she said, inclining her head
exactly the right amount.
Queen Snowfall, Thorn replied, doing the
same.
I'm glad you're still here.
Oh, Snowball said.
The spikes along her spine ruffled up as
she braced herself for a lecture about
how real queens behaved.
No, wait.
That was more Queen Coral's style.
Queen Thorn didn't care much for rules
and traditions.
But that also meant she could be horribly
direct about sharing her opinions.
I don't like the sound of that thing
across the ocean, said Thorn.
Thank the moon's pyreas and peace, so we
can all talk about it together, like
sensible dragons, instead of snarling
hyenas.
Pierre is at peace.
Snowfall had never thought about it that
way.
Sure, the war of Sandwing's succession
was over, but her mother had been
murdered pretty recently by a night
wing.
Snowfall wouldn't describe her feelings
about that tribe as exactly peaceful.
That didn't make her a snarling hyena
though, seriously.
The other queens on their way?
Snowball asked.
Rooptide said they could be here by
tonight, Kibley answered cheerfully.
He gave Winter another hopeful smile, and
his earring caught the light of a
sunbeam.
That earring.
The earring.
Or at least, it looked exactly like the
earrings that had saved her tribe from
Dark Stalker in the plague.
She remembered them arriving.
Sacks and sacks on them, brought by ice
wings who lived in possibility. sent by
Queen Thorn in the Sand Kingdom.
Snowfall's very 1st task as queen, had
been making sure that every ice wing in
her kingdom received one to reverse the
effects of the plague.
For a long time, they weren't sure if it
was safe to take them off again.
Every ice wing had gone around for months
wearing them, and then one day someone
took theirs off to see what would happen
and the plague didn't come back.
So gradually they had disappeared off the
dragons.
But everyone kept theirs tucked away into
safe spots just in case.
Just in case they were needed again.
Just in case, he wasn't really gone.
Snowfall had been the last ice wing to
remove her earring.
She still carried it with her, and the
pouch around her neck.
It was so strange to see the exact same
earring on this enthusiastic sand wing
just a regular little accessory instead
of the thing that had saved her entire
tribe.
Are you all right?
Lynx whispered in her ear.
Snowfall pulled herself up and folded her
wings regally.
Yes, always.
And then something flashed behind her
eyes like a bolt of lightning, and her
head split in 2, and everything around
her, sanctuary, the scavenger enclosure
Queen Thorn, length, snowfall herself.
All vanished into thin air.
Chapter 13.
His claws are shaking.
They are his claws, and they are not his
claws.
His claws would never seize a fleeing
dragonette from the webs and drag her
into the hive.
His voice would never shout orders at
terrified silkwings.
His talons would never threaten them with
this spear.
Where did this spear even come from?
How long has he been like this?
The days are blurring together, and he
hasn't been his real self for so long.
The queen is in his head, and his
muscles.
In his talons.
It's worse than he ever imagined, any of
the times he tried to imagine how the
hive wings must feel as she takes over.
If he pulls himself all the way back
inside and stares inward.
He can lose time, knowing his body is
moving without him.
But right now, he can't do that.
He's in his own hive.
The place he fled with cricket and sword
tail not so long ago.
He is storming through familiar hallways
smashing displays in the market, rounding
up all the silk wings who were peacefully
lying in the sun in the mosaic garden.
He sees dragons he knows from school, who
stare at him in paralyzed terror.
They know he would never do this, so this
is how they discover the queen can
control silk wings now, as well as hive
wings.
Except it's not the queen.
It's even worse.
But they don't know that yet.
They look at their own talents, wondering
when it will happen if they'll remember
it.
All the things Blue wondered too.
But there's a process.
The new, stronger breath of evil plant is
needed for the process.
And the dragons who were supposed to make
it grow faster escaped.
Sundew.
No one has found her yet, or cricket, as
far as Blue knows.
She might be safe.
Maybe they're even in the distant
kingdoms now, far from all of this.
Carelessness.
Wasp's voice hisses in his head.
This was a strange discovery, that
although she can't read his thoughts, He
can hear hers, sometimes very clearly.
She's furious about the silk wings that
have slipped through her claws already.
Hundreds of them vanished during the 2
days while her army was rescuing every
last scrap of the breath of evil plant
from the burning jungle.
The jungle she made me burn, he thinks
but has to stop himself from thinking.
They were hunting for leaf wings at the
same time, but found none.
None.
How did they all escape?
Where could they have gone?
I will find them and destroy them.
At least I have their army and their
queen.
Inside his head, the queen is thrilled
and the queen is furious at the same
time.
Wasp wants to kill Queen Sequoia and all
the leaf wings in her power, but the
breath of evil won't let her.
It controls her just as completely. as
she controls the hive wings.
And it needs the leaf wings.
It needs any hint of leaf speak they have
to grow more of the plant as fast as they
can.
Once there is enough, they can take over
the silk wings, but only if they can find
all the silk wings.
And most of them went into hiding while
the jungle burned.
Blue was with Queen Wasp's army as they
searched hive after hive.
Yellow jacket hive, empty.
Except for wasps, mean, bewildered sister
Lady Yellowjacket, wasp hive, empty.
Jewel Hive, empty, and Queen Was was
especially furious about that, because
where did Lady Jewel and Lady Scarab go?
Did they run off with the Silk Wings?
I knew I should have killed them years
ago.
That's when she realized they needed to
get ahead of whoever was warning the
hives.
If there was any chance left to do that
and she sent warriors out to all the
hives.
That's how Blue ended up here, in his own
home.
He'd hoped it would be empty too.
But whoever was coming to warn them was
already too late.
He'd seen his mother's, Burnett and
Silverspot, but he didn't think they saw
him, which was a small mercy.
They were in the crowd being shoved into
the hatchery.
That's where the silk wings were to be
kept until the breath of evil was ready
for them.
And I have to stand guard.
Blue things. over my own friends and
family.
I can't even talk to them, or tell them I
missed them, or then I'm sorry about
this.
When tears come, as they often do.
He can't wipe them away, because his
claws are not his claws.
They're my claws.
Oh, their claws are my claws.
She enjoys looking through this little
silk wing, the flame silk who dared to
defy her, but she has a lot of dragons to
wield, and can't stay entangled in anyone
for too long.
The traps are set in cicada hive and
hornet hive.
Whoever has been warning the silk wings
will arrive to save them, and then her
toothy leaves will snap shut, and they'll
be caught like flies in a plant jaws.
Wasp frowns.
That was not her metaphor.
Get out of my head.
She says with a hiss, but it doesn't
bother answering.
This will all be worth it.
Sometimes, you have to work with monsters
to get the power you want.
Three tribes, all bowing to her.
It's what she's wanted all along, isn't
it?
She knew the silk wings and leaf wings
were a threat from the moment she saw
them, as a young dragonette.
They were different.
Dangerous, strange and terrifying.
Those tribes would have attacked me 1st
if I hadn't attacked them.
If everyone is evil, the only way to
survive is to be the most evil.
Silk wings and leaf wings are different
from us and need to be controlled.
As long as she controls everything, she'll
be safe.
Everyone will be safe.
No one can threaten her when they can't
even lift a claw against her.
Everyone was out to get me, but I showed
them, and now they're all mine.
This is what it means to be a true
queen.
Complete control.
Nothing to fear.
No one to stop her or argue with her or
complain about her.
They fear her, and that is how it should
be.
She is pacing, and she realizes her
thoughts are spiraling down an
uncontrolled path again.
She'll have to kill something to calm
herself down.
Snowfall was wrenched very suddenly out
of wasp, and landed hard, painfully, back
in her own mind.
It felt as though she had just plummeted
from a great height, and midway.
She had turned from one dragon into
another, completely different dragon.
Or more like a 3rd dragon.
Blue, to wasp, to me.
Blue was the most opposite of herself
she'd ever been, and the most powerless.
It was awful, and she hated it.
And she would never, never forgive the
ring for doing this to her.
But WASP?
Wasp was worse, because Snowfall had
heard echoes of her own fears inside
Wasp's head.
I'm not like her, am I?
I would never make the choices she's
made.
Would I?
Such as accepting a strange magic I don't
know enough about, in order to make
myself more powerful.
Asked an uncomfortable part of her
brain.
She realized she was lying on grass, and
her face was wet, as though someone had
flung part of the wake over her head.
The air smelled like scavengers and pine
trees, and distant snow.
She was definitely on her own continent
again.
I'm not wasp, or blue.
I am me, and snowfall.
I've always been snowfall.
I don't want to be anyone else.
Ever again.
Someone was shaking her shoulder.
Wake up.
Please wake up.
The someone said.
Snowfall.
Snowfall?
That must be links, disrespectfully
forgetting how a queen should be
addressed, again.
Snowfall cracked her eyes open.
Her skull hurt as though she'd whacked it
on something when she fainted.
Well, not fainted exactly.
Got taken over by a stupid magic vision.
Oh, no.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
A vision in the middle of the day?
When she was wide awake?
She thought they only came at night, like
normal dreams.
Could she be attacked by visions
anytime?
She shoved herself up to a sitting
position and seized the ring, trying to
yank it off.
Lynx let out a yelp that sounded like joy
and threw her wings around snowfall.
That was terrifying, she cried.
Please, don't ever do that again.
Do. What exactly?
Kibley's voice asked.
Snowfall looked up and realized there was
a whole circle of dragons around her
expressions ranging from puzzled to
curious, to worried.
An entirely oversized audience for her
collapse.
Kibli, Winter, Queen Thorn, and Links
were all there, but at some point, they'd
been joined by Sundew, Luna, and Cricket
who was holding the squirmy little hive
wing.
Cricket.
Snowfall's heart did a hideous little
jump stutter thing at the side of her.
She could almost feel blue leaning
through her scales, shooting out beams of
love at the bespectacled dragon.
Ugh, horrifying.
Cricket was perhaps a scale closer to
snowfalls type than grayling, but still
several continents off.
I'm fine, she snapped.
It's nothing.
I'm fine.
Stop looking at me like that.
Queen Thorn and Winter politely took a
step back and pretended to study the
clouds.
But Cricket couldn't seem to pull her
eyes away.
She was giving Snowfall the most
fascinated look through her glasses.
So, sorry, but, but your expression
cricket stammered, something about your
face, for a moment when you were still
unconscious, it was so weirdly familiar.
She looked like Moon does when she has
visions of the future, Luna suggested.
Can you see the future too?
What did you see?
Snowfall shook her head?
crouching a little lower to the grass.
Her claw hurt from her violent attempts
to pull off the ring, and her head still
ached from being yanked out of wasp, and
she had a weird, flippy feeling in her
stomach that had no reasonable
explanation, except maybe that turning
from one dragon into another all of a
sudden, might have some physical side
effects.
Had she seen the future?
Or was that the past?
Or was it happening right now?
Maybe she's just hungry, Link said, trying
to cover for snowfall.
Dragons faint from hunger all the time
right?
Ice wings don't have the power of
foresight.
Winter said to Luna.
Only Night Wings.
But that looked like magic, Kibley said.
He glanced at Thorn, as if she had the
eyes he trusted the most.
Didn't it?
Like something magic just happened to
Queen Snowfall?
Do you feel all right?
he asked her.
He sounded genuinely concerned, his voice
suddenly gentle instead of playful.
Snowfall saw him reach up and
instinctively touch his earring.
She wondered if he was thinking of dark
soccer, and the plague, and what had
happened to the last ice wing queen, and
other unknown evil spells that might be
lurking about.
Was it possible the ring had been
secretly spirited into the palace by Dark
Stalker?
Could this be one of his curses that was
doing this to her?
In a panic, Snowfall fumbled for her
pouch, pulled out the earring that had
cured her of the dark stalker plague, and
stabbed it into her ear.
Everyone was staring at her again, as she
grabbed the ring and tried to wrestle it
off her claw.
It didn't budge.
If it had been a dark stalker spell, it
should have lost all its power over her
the moment she put on the earring.
She should have been able to pull it off
easily.
With a sigh, she took the earring off and
tucked it back in her pouch.
What is going on?
Sundew said into the silence.
Do you have magic besides seeing the
future?
Luna asked.
Her gaze going from snowfall to Lynx to
Kibley and Thorn.
They do.
Like the invisible Ice Wing Army
remember?
I told you about that?
Cricket said.
I've been wondering about how she did
that for days.
It seems to be jewelry related?
She studied Snowfall's bracelets and the
ring that sat obstinately on her claw.
Kibley gave her a surprised, approving
look.
He held out one talent to snowfall.
May I see?
Snowfall wasn't sure why she placed her
talent in his, letting him bend down to
peer at the oval ring.
Maybe it was the smoky haze of Blue's
brain inside hers, wanting to trust
everyone, which was still better than the
sharp teeth of wasp's brain that wanted
her to bite him instead.
Is that right?
Am I being all snowfall right now?
Would Snowfall normally want to bite him
too?
Are any of my feelings real?
Invisible army?
Winter murmured to Lynx.
She tugged him a few steps away from the
group and whispered in his ear.
At the same time, Kibble was tapping on
the opal and trying to wiggle the ring
around Snowfall's claw.
This isn't an ordinary stock ring, is
it?
He said.
What's the spell on it?
Do you know who cast it?
Sundu drew in a sharp breath behind him?
Spell?
she echoed.
You can cast actual magic spells?
Part of snowfall, really?
Really wanted to tell these other tribe
dragons, nothing.
This was ice wing business.
Nothing to do with anyone else.
There was cricket, and her curious face
that Blue loved so much, and Blue would
never hide anything from her.
And even the parts of snowfall that
weren't all blurry from being blue
couldn't help thinking, she should know
that he's still alive, or at least he was
whenever that vision happened.
Is going to happen?
Arrr!
It would be helpful to know things, you
stupid ring.
It's an old animus touched object from
way back in ice wing history, she told
Kibley.
I found it in our treasury.
It gives me visions of other dragons, like
I'm inside them, thinking their thoughts
feeling their feelings.
She scowled.
It's the worst, if you want to know the
truth.
Wow, Cricket breathed.
Blue would love that.
Snowfall rubbed her head.
The one I just had.
I was blue, actually.
She didn't want to tell them the wasp
part.
Maybe she could keep that to herself, and
by keeping it to herself, forget it ever
happened.
Cricket and Luna stared at her with a
whole new light in their eyes.
Blue?
Luna gasped, and you saw him?
He's all right?
Cricket blurted at the same time.
I didn't see him, Snowfall explained
Snively.
I was him.
I was stuck inside him.
He is the sappiest little butterfly of a
dragon.
I have ever encountered.
That's blue.
Luna said affectionately.
Tiras were running down Cricket's face.
What was he doing?
Is he safe?
Not even remotely, Snowfall said, and
then, ow, as Lynx kicked her tail and
gave her a significant look.
I mean, he's alive.
But that evil queen of yours is
controlling his talons, and he's trapped
with her army, and they were just forced
to round up a bunch of silk wings in
Cicada Hive, including his mother's, and
he was feeling really guilty about that.
What?
She barked, as Lynx kicked her tail
again.
It's all right.
Cricket said to Lynx, although her tears
hadn't stopped.
I want to know the truth.
See?
Snowfall glowered at length.
Have you had visions of other penthal and
dragons?
Sunu interrupted.
Any leaf wings?
Yes, one named Bryony.
Snowfall said.
Sunday's eyes narrowed, but less like she
was mad at snowfall, and more like she
was trying not to have some other
expression.
Was she?
Did Queen Wasp have her?
and the other leaf wings with her?
No, she's in hiding, Snowfall said.
With hemlock and all the silk wings from
Bloodworm Hive.
All the silk wings from Bloodworm Hive
Sundu echoed, confusion taking over her
face.
Yes, Snowfall snapped.
I know your plan was to lead them all to
die with the hive wings, but Briony
didn't let that happen.
Sundew blinked, and it was Cricket who
jumped in to defend her.
Sundew didn't want them to burn the hive
at all, she said.
And she's the one who made sure they
contacted the chrysalis first.
This is so weird, Link said.
I mean, listening to you talk about all
this Pantala stuff, and those dragons
over there as if you know them.
She added to Snowfall.
As if you care about them, her puzzled
eyebrows seemed to say.
It's not great.
Snowfall lashed her tail.
It's pretty aggravating, in fact.
I have enough problems to handle in the
ice kingdom.
I don't want to worry about problems on a
whole other continent too.
Thank you for telling us, though, cricket
said. wiping her eyes.
It means a lot.
Who else?
Sundew demanded.
How long have you been having these
visions without telling us?
Snowfall hissed at her?
Just since you came barging into my
kingdom?
she said.
The other 2 times were silk wings.
In the 1st vision?
I was Atala while she flew over the ocean
with you all, but she's here now and
totally fine.
The other is named Tao.
She was trying to escape Jewel hive
before the hive wings got there.
Tell, Cricket said softly.
Did she make it?
I don't know.
Snowfall threw her wings up in the air
scattering pine needles.
Wait, yes, I do, sort of, because Blue
was thinking about how Wasp's army found
Jewel Hive empty.
So I think she did, but I can't be sure
because I don't even know if I was seeing
the past present or future.
There is no reason for any of this.
And now they're happening during the
day?
She growled low in her throat.
I can be collapsing and getting infested
with other dragon's emotions in the
middle of a council of queens.
Let's cut off my claw.
She said abruptly to lynx.
That might be a bit drastic, Kibley said
and she realized he was still holding her
talon, studying the ring.
I mean, let's make that plan B or like
plan F. What's plan A?
Snowfall shouted at him.
Can you communicate with the dragons in
your visions?
Kibley asked, like, to let them know
where everyone is gone, or that they
should come across the ocean too.
No.
Snowfall cried.
What is wrong with your ears?
I'm not snowfall when I'm inside them.
Snowfall disappears.
I have no way of telling them anything.
I can't even remember what snowfall
knows.
It's like I never existed at all.
She took a deep, shuddering breath.
Queen Thorn nudged Kibli aside. and took
his place beside Snowfall.
The queen needs a moment, Thorn said with
authority.
Everyone who's not me, go away.
But Kibli and Sundu both started to
protest at the same time.
Now, Thorn said with a forbidding look.
The other dragons melted away like
magic.
Real queen magic, Snowfall thought
wistfully.
The magic of saying things and being
instantly obeyed.
The magic of being so queenly that
everyone listens to you, because they
trust you, and know your great queen.
Woof!
Thorn said when they were gone.
Her voice suddenly surprisingly normal.
Have you noticed that it's awfully hard
to get any peace and quiet when you're
queen?
Snowfall thought of her empty, echoing
palace, and the way dragons vanished when
they saw her coming.
The long, long nights that were too quiet
and yet not peaceful at all.
But also the constant pressure inside her
head, knowing the wall was always waiting
for her, and feeling as though dragons
were watching her every move.
I wonder if Tundra has changed any of
their rankings while I've been gone.
Narwhal used to, when Queen Glacier was
away.
Snowfall didn't think she'd officially
authorized that, but maybe tundra would
just assume that power because Snowfall
hadn't told her not to.
Let's go flying, Thorn suggested.
We can figure out what we think before
the other queens get here.
I don't know how to figure out what I
think Snowfall said, standing up.
Should I get my guards?
Nah, just you and me.
Thorn said.
I mean, who would dare attack us?
Brain dead beetles who want to be crushed
maybe?
Snowfall laughed despite herself.
Flying away from everyone was exactly
what she wanted to do right now anyway.
They lifted up into the sky, letting the
late morning sun wash over them and
soared toward the peaks.
Snowfall inhaled the smell of distant
snow.
Along with a scent of not so distant
scavengers.
More than one scavenger?
She glanced down at Winter's little
enclosure.
The creature in there was sprinting
around the space again, making lots of
funny squeaking noises.
But Snowfall's nose told her that wasn't
the only scavenger nearby.
And were those tree branches moving in
more than the wind?
Snowfall shrugged?
She had never cared about scavengers, and
she wasn't about to start now.
She tilted her wings and followed Queen
Thorn into the clouds.
Chapter 14.
Queen Thorn didn't make Snowfall talk, or
ask a bunch of questions, or lecture her
on queenliness.
They just flew and hunted when they got
hungry, and flew some more, until the sun
was high in the sky, warming their
chilled wings.
Snowfall felt her head clearing of the
post vision blue haze.
Her own thoughts sharpened and felt real
again.
Thoughts including, is that going to keep
happening?
Visions in the middle of the day?
What if one happens while I'm flying?
Will I just fall out of the sky and die?
Will they ever stop?
Or will they start coming more and more
frequently until my mind is never my own
anymore?
She shivered.
What was the point of this magic?
Was it set to get worse and worse
gradually?
Maybe so the original animus would have
had time to escape the kingdom before the
queen went mad?
And what was happening with Blue Now?
Or Bryony, or Tao?
If only she could compel the ring to give
her visions.
She actually wanted useful visions.
Instead of walking nightmares, she
couldn't do anything about.
Ready to go back?
Thorn asked, swooping up beside her.
Snowfall made a phase.
I can't wait.
More interrogation.
How thrilling.
You just shut them down whenever you need
to, Thorn suggested.
You are a queen.
But remember that, of course, they're
curious and worried about their friends
so that's why they want to know more.
Yes, yes, Snowfall grumbled.
If Blue had known snowfall was inside him
he would have been over the moons to give
her a message for cricket.
The least she could do for that poor
trapped dragon was reassured, the hive
wing he loved.
Another intertribal romance, she thought
shaking her head.
Were they more common than she realized?
She'd always assumed Ice Wings would
never choose to be with dragons outside
their tribe.
But then, the dragon had brought them the
1st 2 earrings had been a hybrid ice wing
sea wing from possibility.
And now there was crystal and garial.
So it did happen.
Hybrids.
Winter mentioned them.
In the chaos yesterday, she hadn't really
registered it, but now she remembered.
He'd said, We have a lot of hybrids
here.
That meant dragonettes whose parents were
from 2 different tribes, like the ones
she'd spotted yesterday.
Probably a mud wing sea wing, and at
least 2 sky wing sand wings, and maybe a
sky wing night wing?
No wonder those dragons wanted a new city
to live in.
How could they ever return to their
kingdoms, or choose one tribe while
abandoning the other?
Snowfall had to admit to herself that she
would have forbidden crystal to see
Garyel if she'd known about it when she
1st became queen.
And he wouldn't have been able to cross
the great ice cliff alive.
He still couldn't.
So even if Snowfall gave them her
blessing, they'd never be able to come to
the ice palace.
She followed Thorn as they descended into
the central clearing of sanctuary, where
sundew and tsunami were yelling at each
other, surrounded by a wide eyed
audience.
You could save us, Sunday shouted.
It would be so easy for you.
I did save you, tsunami shouted back.
You're here, aren't you?
and alive.
I mean, everyone back there.
Sundu waved one wing at the Western
Horizon.
Oh, the mind controlled dragons.
You could save them with one spell.
That's what?
tsunami sputtered.
Oh what now?
A spell.
Sundu clenched her fists.
The dragons on this continent have real
magic, she announced to the leaf wings
around her.
It's not only seeing the future and
invisible armies, they can cast any spell
they want.
They could make a spell to free all the
dragons in Pantala, but they won't.
They've been hiding their magic from us.
All right.
Hang on, tsunami said over the mutters
from the crowd.
That's a highly confused understanding of
the situation.
So, unconfuse it, Sundew barked.
We don't all have magic.
Tsunami turned to riptide, who had come
up to stand supportively beside her.
Back me up.
Hardly any of us have magic.
It's very rare.
Riptide agreed.
Once in a generation, often less, or at
least it's supposed to be.
So right now you have what?
Sundu demanded.
One magician?
Two?
Tsunami's grunge upper snout.
We call them animus dragons, she said.
And Four, we think, more or less.
Four?
Snowfall tried to think.
Did she know about this?
There was Jerboa, and there was some
animus dragon at Jade Mountain.
She assumed a sea wing, who'd cast the
empathy spell.
So who were the other two?
What tribe did they work for?
That was outrageous.
Animus dragons all over the place, and
none of them ice wings.
No one was safe.
So bring us one of them.
Sundew said in a steely voice, and have
them cast one spell for us.
Tsunami's eyes slipped sideways into the
crowd.
The snowfall didn't catch who she was
looking at, Whoa.
Is there an animus dragon here right
now?
Here's the thing.
Tsunami said slowly.
Animus magic has stopped working.
Nobody knows why.
That's why I didn't tell you all about it
because even though we want to help you
We can't do it with magic.
We just can't.
That sounds like another lie, Sundu
yelled.
Snowfall saw Queen Hazel in the crowd of
leaf wings, at the same moment, Hazel
caught her eye, and gave a little start
as though she'd forgotten she was a
figure of authority around here.
Hey, hey, she said, stepping in between
sundu and tsunami, her green wings spread
out like giant leaf curtains.
It could be true, Sundoo.
If their magic isn't working, why would
they tell us about it?
If their magic isn't working, Why is she
making armies invisible and having
visions of Pentalon dragons?
Sandu asked, pointing at snowfall.
Oh, great.
Now, the 100s of puzzled eyes turned
towards Snowfall.
I'm using old magic, she answered, holding
up her talon with a ring on it, and
chanted a long time ago.
Those still work.
It's only new spells that don't.
Apparently, if we take the animus
dragon's word for it.
Tsunami frowned at her, and Snowfall
scowled right back.
The queens are starting to arrive, Riptide
said, brushing tsunami's wing with his
own.
A wing of dragons was soaring down toward
them, and farther off in the sky, Snowfall
could see another group approaching.
Everyone turned to look at them
whispering and murmuring, who would get
here first?
Would they come with any friends or
family of the sanctuary dragons?
Time to put on my super queen face?
My, the Ice Kingdom is just fine, thank
you, Bass.
No advice needed.
Don't tell me what to do.
I am an excellent queen who can handle.
Who can?
What?
Oh no.
It was happening again.
Darkness was crowding in around the
corners of her eyes.
Snowfall looked around wildly, spotted
winter. and sank her claws into his
tail.
Yowch, he yelped, whipping around to look
at her.
Get me somewhere safe, she hissed.
Don't let them see.
He didn't argue.
Didn't ask questions.
Didn't stand there with a dopey
bewildered look on his face.
He grabbed Kibley, and the 2 of them
spread their wings around snowfall
hooking their arms under hers, and
carrying her away from the circle of
dragons.
But everyone looking up at the sky.
Snowfall had to hope they wouldn't notice
her being spirited away, but she only had
a moment to worry about it before.
Tall grass brushes her wings and tickles
her snout.
She crouches lower, spreading her long
wings.
She's lucky there are dark color.
So it's easier to creep up on the hives
at night.
The dragon city towers over them, light
glowing from the windows and archways on
the higher levels.
But she can't hear anything.
Voices, music, any of the sounds that
usually carry across the savannah at
night.
It's too quiet.
And nothing moves in the webs overhead.
They're empty and still, like she's never
seen them before.
All the silk wings.
Where are they?
Was this your hive?
The small, dark orange dragon beside her
whispers.
Yes, she whispers back.
They should have come here 1st.
All her chrysalis friends, her parents.
Is she too late to save them?
She studies the map of Pantala in her
head.
They'd recruited silk wings from yellow
jacket hive, wasp hive, and jewel hive to
bring to the poison jungle, those had
gone across the sea with the escaping
dragons.
The silk wings from bloodworm hive
vanished into thin air after the hive
burned.
No one knows where they are.
But they can't be dead.
No bodies and no survivors, has to mean
they all escaped somewhere, doesn't it?
She'd sent 2 dragons to Set Sea Hive.
So it had only made sense for her and
Cinnabar to fly the other way, stopping
briefly at each hive to warn whoever they
could, then straight on to mantis hive.
It was as far from the poison jungle as
one could get.
Her wings were still sore from the
frantic full speed flight.
Which meant there was a chance of getting
there before Queen Wasp's zombie
minions.
And she'd been right.
They'd found mantis hive empty of hive
wings.
Bewildered silk wings milled about its
halls or rested on the webs, enjoying the
unexpected days off, while also wondering
where everyone had gone.
Every hive wing had left, even the
smallest dragonettes.
Wasp had summoned every single one to the
battlefield outside the poison jungle
determined to crush the leaf wings once
and for all.
She clenches her talons.
Those hive wings hadn't had to lift a
claw.
The leaf wings and the silkwing allies
she brought them had lost before they
even started to fight.
They'd run away.
And now Queen Wasp and the breath of evil
were able to infect silk wings, which
meant the entire tribe might lose the
last bit of freedom they'd had.
Stop, Io.
Cinnabar was whispers, brushing one of
her wings lightly.
Stop worrying.
We got everyone out of mantis hive and
safely into hiding.
We'll save the silk wings here too.
It's too quiet, she whispers back.
The hive wings must be here.
I bet they've got all the silk wings
trapped in there with them.
Even if that's true, Cinnabar whispers.
They can't have put all the silk wings in
the hive under the mind control yet.
They don't have enough of the plant to do
that.
They'll have to grow more, and Sandu said
that without Hawthorne or her.
It take a while.
Not as long as it should.
Some of the leaf wings wasp trapped have
a little bit of leaf speak.
They'll make it grow faster.
And if the hive wings keep all the silk
wings imprisoned until they have enough.
We'll get them out.
That's why we're here.
Io sighs and looks up at the ghostly webs
again.
They're swaying slightly in a far up
breeze, silvery pale in the light of the
3 moons.
Empty.
How are 2 dragons supposed to save all
the silk wings and cicada hive?
They'll help us, she reminds herself.
My friends will rise up when they realize
it's time for the chrysalis to break
free.
The map is safe.
Cinnabar asks.
Hidden, IO promises, where we agreed.
Even if Queen Wasp captures them and
steals their minds, she can't access
their secrets.
The map to the other continent is
somewhere that only Io or Cinnabar can
find with their minds free.
WASP won't even know it exists.
Cinnabar smiles, and her wings rustle in
the darkness.
Then let's go rescue our tribe.
Chapter 15.
Snowfall floundered back into her own
mind shouting, it's a trap.
Don't go in there.
She threw off the talons holding her down
and tried to lunge into the air.
But she was so disoriented that she
crashed into somebody's wings and landed
back in a soft pile of pine needles.
Your majesty, said Winter's voice, and
somehow that was disorienting too, her
own cousin calling her that, when that
voice, and that name, should only connect
to Queen Glacier.
Don't worry, Kibley said, touching one of
her talons lightly.
You're back.
Your queen snowfall again.
They're going to catch her.
Snowfall said breathlessly.
Cicada hive is full of wasp zombies, lying
in wait for Io and cinnabar.
I have to tell them, that's where blue
is.
They can't go in there.
She struggled up again and then stopped
standing with her wings outstretched
along the ground, trying to breathe.
I can't tell them, she said.
There's no way.
Um, Kibley said, looking at winter.
Maybe there is?
Don't you be needlessly optimistic at
me?
She snapped.
Why?
She screamed at the ring in her mind.
Why would you show me this when there's
nothing I can do?
They were outside Winter's scavenger
enclosure.
The scavenger inside was squeaking loudly
like an overwrought squirrel.
All around them, the bushes rustled in
the wind, or maybe, because of something
else.
Snowfall squinted at one of the trees, and
thought she saw something move that was
bigger than a squirrel.
But then lynx came darting through the
woods and sprinted up to snowfall side.
Are you all right?
She panted.
Who were you this time?
Someone very doomed.
Snowfall bit out, frustrated.
Never mind.
Are all the queens here?
Everyone but Queen Coral, Lang said.
They've agreed to start without her, if
you're ready.
Are you ready?
I'm fine, Snowfall said, waving away
Winter's talons as he tried to help her
up.
She didn't have to tell anyone that her
heartbeat was still racing.
Or that part of her was still inside the
heat and smell of the Savannah night.
Calm down.
You are not currently creeping into a
giant, terrifying dragon city full of
mind controlled monsters with bug
powers.
But Iowas, or would be.
Or already had?
Snowfall shook herself.
She had no idea how to figure out the
time frame for her visions.
That one might have happened days and
days ago.
Io might be dead already.
She flinched at the thought, then shot
another glare at her ring.
You'd better not be sending me visions of
totally dead dragons.
The other queens were assembled in the
mouth of a pebbly cave halfway up one of
the mountain peaks.
The wind whipped around the snow caps
above them, but the spot they'd chosen
was an oasis of quiet.
Each queen had brought one advisor as
backup, and snowfall debated all the way
up the mountain about whether it was
idiotic to bring Lynx, who was clearly
still a dragonette, instead of one of her
guards.
The Queen Thorn had summoned Kibley to
join her.
And he was about the same age as Lynx
surely.
Queen Ruby's choice was a quiet, older
orange dragon, who took notes the entire
time in a kind of miniature scroll.
Snowfall never caught his name.
Queen Morehen had a mud wing with her who
looked so much like her.
The snowfall nearly bowed at the wrong
dragon.
A sister, she guessed, remembering the
way mud wings were about family.
And of course, there was Queen Glory, with
her floppy yaw noodle of a sloth curled
around her neck, as usual.
She'd brought a fidgety nightwing with
her, which Snowfall didn't like, but she
thought it was an interesting choice.
Why not a fellow rain wing?
What did the rain wings think of glory
choosing a night wing over them for this
council?
Perhaps nothing at all.
Did rain wings actually have opinions?
Queen Hazel was there too, with Cricket
and Luna.
Sundew had been left down in the
village.
Most likely because Hazel didn't want her
to do any more shouting in front of the
Queens.
Tsunami, Riptide, and Moon, for the final
3 dragons in the council.
If snowfall hadn't been the last one to
arrive, she might have complained and
tried to get them kicked out, but it was
too late by the time she got there.
Well, fine.
Probably it made sense to get a report
from one Pyrean dragon who'd actually
been to Pentala.
Although there's also me.
I could tell them way too much about
what's happening on Pentala right now.
She shivered a little.
Thinking of Io again.
The other queens exchanged polite
greetings with Snowfall, the kind that
would normally make her freak out about
what they really meant, and what they
thought of her, and whether they talked
about her when she wasn't there.
Today she could barely even concentrate
on saying the right things back to them.
So what if Queen Ruby's smile looked
suspiciously judgmental?
Io and cinnabar.
Wait.
Didn't Cinnabar say, Something
important.
Right at the end of the vision?
Her thoughts were interrupted by Tsunami
standing up and calling the council to
order. as though she was anybody at all.
All right, fine.
She was a royal sea wing princess, so
technically, she could be standing in for
Queen Coral, but still, it was very
presumptuous.
Tsunami told a long story about how Luna
had been swept across the ocean in a
storm carried by her silk, and how that
was their 1st sign, there were dragons on
a lost continent out beyond the sea.
She explained that she and her brother
had decided to swim across the ocean to
find them, and to find out whether Luna's
stories were true, that there were
dragons over there who needed help.
Luna jumped in to talk about the
political system in Pentala, how the hive
wings kept the silk wings under their
control, and how the hive wings
themselves were all controlled by Queen
Wasp, who could take over any hive wings
mind anytime she felt like it, from
anywhere.
Except mine, Cricket said quickly, when
Kibley turned to look at her.
And a few others.
It's a whole thing.
Hazel added the story of the leaf wings
who had fought a war with Queen Wasp, and
almost been wiped out, except for a small
remnant of the tribe that fled to hide in
a poison jungle.
Snowfall drifted in and out for parts of
the stories.
She knew all this, from being Tao, and
Briony, and Blue, and Io.
She could still feel the weight of the
history that rippled under their scales.
She remembered knowing things they hadn't
even thought consciously about.
She could probably draw an accurate map
of Pentala herself.
I am actually the most informed dragon
here, she thought.
Glancing triumphantly around the circle.
The one and only upside to the visions.
Maybe that was why the ancient Ice Wing
Queen had agreed to, or asked for, this
gift in the 1st place.
But knowing a lot about Pentala didn't
seem like an even trade for Snowfall's
sanity.
Finally, after a long explanation of the
new war, Queen Wasps Attack on the Jungle
and the discovery of the plant that gave
her the mind control power, the Pentalan
dragons wound down into silence.
The queens exchanged glances.
So you need a new place to live.
Queen Mohan asked.
I suppose you could stay here in
sanctuary.
If it's all right with Queen Ruby and
Queen Thorn.
I'm afraid we don't have room in the mud
kingdom.
Yeah, right, Snowfall thought.
The Mud Kingdom wasn't exactly packed
wall to wall with mud wings.
They could easily fit a whole other city
of dragons in those endless swamps that
they wanted to.
How many dragons are we talking about?
Ruby interjected.
Who will be in charge of them?
You, she asked Queen Hazel.
I mean, what if you keep having more
dragonettes and spreading out?
Are we going to end out with a new
kingdom in the middle of the continent?
One that mostly takes over Sky Kingdom
territory?
She shot ripped hide a frown.
That's not what I had in mind when I
agreed to this settlement.
I know your majesty, he said.
But we can't possibly send them back to
Pantala.
Beside him, tsunami vigorously shook her
head, and Moon looked horrified, as
though someone had just suggested
rounding up all the baby seals and
setting them on fire.
Is there anywhere else we can put them?
Ruby asked.
She turned to glory.
It sounds like they might be happiest in
the rainforest.
So glory can be queen of 4 tribes.
Snowfall hurt herself, Snap.
Glory made a face she couldn't
interpret.
Was she laughing at Snowfall?
Was she thinking that she could handle 4
tribes easily when Snowfall could barely
manage one?
The part of her that had briefly been
blue, the silk wing thought, or maybe
she's thinking how impossible it would be
to rule 4 tribes, and how much she's
still struggling to bring together the 2
she has.
Shut up, you mushball.
Snowball demanded.
Wait.
Hazel stood up, and spread her wings to
catch their attention.
That's not.
We're not thinking about where we could
live yet.
Most of us.
All of us, I think, want to go back to
Pantala.
Not Cobra Lily, Snowfall thought.
She wondered if Hazel had actually asked
anybody what they wanted.
The leaf wings might be happier here
among trees that weren't constantly
trying to eat them.
Oh, Ruby said, taken aback.
Then, Do that?
We all left dragons we care about over
there.
Hazel said.
They're all in awful danger.
That's true, Snowfall thought.
Extremely true.
We want to go back to rescue them, Hazel
said, but we can't go back alone.
Our numbers are no match for Queen Wasp
especially once she mind controls
everyone else in Pantala.
We were hoping.
Maybe you could help us.
Oh.
Ruby breathed out softly.
You mean with armies, Thorn said.
You want us to send our soldiers all the
way to the other side of the ocean?
Morehen said.
To fight in a war that, I'm so sorry, but
It has nothing to do with us.
Nothing to do with us, Kibble burst out.
Didn't you hear what's happening to those
dragons?
Yes, Morehen said, shooting a get your
dragon under control.
Look at Thorn.
But our dragons are safe here.
That thing over there doesn't even know
about us.
If we go rile it up.
It might come back to attack us, and we
could lose this whole continent too.
At least right now.
This is a safe place for us, and for
you.
Plus, we just got out of a war, Ruby said
and a follow-up, almost war.
Was that a dig at Snowfall?
Was Ruby saying Snowfall was the kind of
queen who would drag her tribe into war
for no reason?
Or was she saying that snowfall couldn't
even finish a war, she tried to start.
Dark Stalker didn't do anything to your
tribe, Kibley pointed out.
Oh.
Was that the almost war she meant?
Everyone against Dark Stalker?
Well, if she was worried about that, she
could have almost been a lot more helpful
trying to fight him.
I have a lot of dragons, who haven't
recovered from the war of Sandwank
succession, Ruby said.
Or, to be honest, from my mother's reign
as the super murdery queen of the
mountains.
I don't know if I can throw them back
into another conflict.
Both Morhen and her sister started
nodding.
We have a similar problem, Glory said
looking thoughtful, as though she were
running calculations in her head.
Half my dragons are not cut out for war.
They wouldn't be any help to you even if
I tried to send them.
And the other half?
Have been through a lot lately.
Oh, have they?
Snowfall said isolately.
Been to a lot?
You mean such as raising an all knowing
magic evil dictator from the dead?
And then trying to help him murder a
whole tribe and take over the continent?
That does sound stressful.
Poor things.
What?
Hazel said, bewildered.
Cricket said at the same time, her eyes
shining with curiosity.
I think what we're all saying, Thorn
interjected, is that it would be tough to
justify sending our soldiers into such a
dangerous situation, when it sounds like
they could have their minds taken over
exactly like your dragons have.
Isn't that right?
We don't know, Hazel said sadly.
I'd guess.
Probably.
We can give you weapons, though, Gloria
said.
My tribe makes these blowguns with darts
that can put dragons to sleep.
You'll be able to stop your friends from
hurting you without having to hurt them.
Oh, wow.
Cricket said.
What's in the darts?
Is it something that grows in your
rainforest?
Have you.
Um, sorry, I'll ask you later.
She subsided as Hazel put one talent over
hers.
We would appreciate that so much.
Hazel said to Glory.
Make a note, Glory said to her night
wing.
We can triple production starting tonight
if we send a messenger back.
We have some Dragon flame cacti, Ruby
said, glancing awkwardly at Thorn.
You're welcome to that.
But I don't think we can send any of our
soldiers.
Wait, wait, Kibley said.
Before you all decide, you have to hear
Moon's prophecy.
Tsunami let out a small huff, and a few
other dragons looked uneasy, but Thorn
and Glory beckoned Moon forward.
A new prophecy?
Glory asked.
Moon nodded.
It came with a vision that led me to Luna
on the western coast.
She cleared her throat and recited it
again.
Snowfall listened a bit more carefully
this time.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire, to
the land across the sea.
We're dragons are poisoned, and dragons
are dying, and no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book.
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive.
Face a great evil with talons united, or
none of the tribes will survive.
Moon glanced over at tsunami when she
finished.
Sorry, she added.
They just happen, I swear.
You all heard that, right?
Kibley said.
Turn your eyes to the land across the
sea.
Face a great evil with talons united.
As cryptic prophecies go.
I think this one is pretty clear.
None of the tribes will survive, Glory
echoed, meaning all of us over here as
well.
But how is that possible?
Ribby said.
How would the danger even get to us?
I thought someone said it was almost
impossible to cross the ocean.
It is, Hazel agreed.
We only made it because we found a map
that was made a long time ago by clear
sight.
I think that's what a secret hides within
their book means.
It showed a trail of islands where we
could rest on our way across the ocean.
Without it, we wouldn't have survived.
There you go, Ruby said.
You had to use the map.
The dragons over there, and whatever is
controlling them, won't be able to follow
you.
So we're all safe here.
That was it.
That was the thing Cinnabar had said.
Actually, we're not, Snowball
interjected.
She turned to Hazel, who looked as though
she'd accidentally pushed them all into a
Venus dragon trap, because you left a
copy of the map there, didn't you?
With IO and Cinnabar.
What?
Ruby cried.
And Io and Cinnabar have been captured by
Hive Wings, Snowfall informed her.
So, Queen Wasp getting her claws on that
map.
It's only a matter of time.
Chapter 16.
Well, there was a lot of shouting and an
unreasonable amount of questions, far too
many of them directed at Snowfall.
You had a vision about Io and Cinnabar?
Cricket kept asking, did you see them get
captured?
Are you sure the High Wings got them?
Unless my vision was of something that
hasn't happened yet?
Snowball said.
That I don't know.
But if it has happened, I definitely saw
them going into Cicada Hive, which is
definitely full of mind controlled
dragons, like blue, lying in wait for
them.
We could try to warn them, tsunami
interjected.
We have a thing, I'll go try.
She flew out of the cave and down the
mountain.
But that didn't help the noise levels
because all the other queens were
interrogating Hazel at once, and the poor
leaf wing queen was trying to explain
about the silk wings they'd hoped to
rescue.
Let's go, Snowfall said to Lynx.
No one's going to make any great
decisions today.
It was trustful enough knowing that map
was floating around on the other
continent.
Snowfall did not want to add explaining
her visions, and by extension, the cursed
ring she'd blithely put on, to all the
queens, to the list of things stressing
her out today.
She slipped out of the cave quietly, and
Lynx followed her.
They flew down the mountain, and Snowfall
found her wings turning toward Winter's
corner of Sanctuary, where the scavenger
enclosure was.
Must be nice to be a scavenger. snowfall
thought.
No problems in the world, no scary things
coming from across the ocean to steal
your brains.
She couldn't believe Hazel had left a
copy of the map with IO.
What kind of nitwit?
But then she thought of Tao, and Jewel
and Grayling, and Blue's sad mothers, and
then Io's fervent, desperate hope to save
them all swept through her so strongly.
It felt like her own emotion.
As ridiculous as that was.
Maybe WASP won't find the map, but how
will anyone else get it?
If Iowa and Cinnabar are captured now, and
they're the only ones who know where it's
hidden.
What can we do?
How can we save them?
Why do I care about this so much?
She tried half-heartedly to pull off a
ring again?
With no success?
They landed on the lake side of the
enclosure, and Snowfall caught herself a
fish, while Lynx told Winter everything
that had happened during the council.
I think your visions are more helpful
than you realize.
Lang said to Snowfall as she finished.
Rubbish.
Hazel would have told them about the map
without me, Snowfall argued.
She's all honest and tortured like that.
But you know what's happening over there
Link said.
You're the only one who can see what's
happened to all those dragons, since
Hazel's group left.
I think it would be much more useful.
If the ring actually answered some of my
actual questions, Snowfall hissed to the
Opal.
Have you tried lying down and closing
your eyes and telling it to give you a
vision?
Winter asked.
No, Snowfall barked.
I mean, sort of, when I went to sleep
last night, but did it listen to me?
No, it did not.
Maybe it's showing you the most important
moments happening in the whole world.
Length suggested.
That seems like something a queen might
have asked for, right?
Perhaps you could try summoning a vision
now?
Winter said.
Maybe it would tell you what happened to
IO and Cinnabar, or the map, or if they
really got caught.
Snowfall side.
Fine.
I hate this idea, but if I have to have a
vision, I'd rather have it when it's
convenient for me anyway.
She looked around and spotted a tall, flat
boulder in the shade of the trees.
In a moment, she was on top of it, lying
on the cool stone.
From up there she could see the little
scavengers scampering around its den.
It was pretty cute.
Cuter than your average squirrel, not as
cute as a polar bear cob.
Stop staring at me, she yelled at Links
in winter.
Mind your own business.
They turned away quickly, and started
walking around the outside of the
enclosure.
Grumbling to herself, Snowfall rested her
chin on her talons, took a deep breath
and closed her eyes.
What happened to Io and Cinnabar?
She asked the ring.
Is the map safe?
Does queen wasp know about it?
She waited to fall into someone else's
scales.
Nothing happened.
And then some more nothing happened.
Snowfall frowned and buried her head
under one wing.
She was definitely still herself.
She had many very strong snowfall
emotions barging around inside her, such
as, for instance, fury.
What was wrong with this ring?
Why couldn't it do what it was told?
Would it work properly for a better
queen?
Is it trying to tell me it also thinks
I'm terrible at this?
Snowfall waited for several more
heartbeats of torture and insecurity and
boredom, but she seemed to be lodged
firmly inside her own anxious brain.
She sighed and opened her eyes.
Links and winter were perched on top of
the scavenger fence, staring at her
again.
Did it work?
Langs called.
What did you see?
That was very boring and frustrating
Snowfall shouted.
And it did not work.
Probably because you were staring at me.
Go away.
They exchanged a glance.
Alright, Winter said.
We're going to find Tsunami and Kibli.
Will you be okay, Jang here?
She glared at him.
Why wouldn't I be?
We could send your guards over.
Links offered.
Oh, Snowfall said, remembering she was
supposed to be guarded at all times.
Yes, yes, sure.
No rush.
Can you keep an eye on pumpkin for me?
Winter asked.
Snowfall flicked her tail across the
smooth coolness of the boulder.
Do not tell me, she said, that you named
your scavenger.
And moreover, that you chose the name
Pumpkin.
I think it's adorable, Lang said, grinning
at Winter, who looked gratifyingly
embarrassed.
I thought you wanted us not to eat your
critter, Snowfall said.
So why would you name her after food?
It's supposed to be cute, he said.
Because she's cute.
Come on, winter.
We'll be here forever if you start
talking scavengers.
Lynx batted his wing with hers, and they
lifted up into the air.
She's been acting a little funny.
Winters said to Snowfall.
She might be planning to break out of her
enclosure again.
If you wouldn't mind.
Yes, yes.
Snowfall said, waving him away.
I'll watch her.
Thank you.
Your Majesty, he called, and the 2 of
them flew away, leaving Snowfall in
blessed silence.
She watched the scavengers scamper
around.
Piling leaves and sticks by the fence.
She tried to think about all the visions
she'd had so far.
Why had the ring chosen those dragons to
show her?
What was the meaning of any of this?
Across the clearing.
The bushes started wrestling in a very
odd way.
In fact, they were more than wrestling.
They were thrashing about as though all
the branches were wrestling furiously
with one another.
And then, all of a sudden, there was a
very loud squeak.
And at the same time, a dragon burst out
of the leaves and careened into the
open.
He fell over and sat there, blinking for
a moment, then hopped up to his feet and
shook his wings.
He lifted his head, saw snowfall watching
him, and grinned a huge, ridiculous, sweet
as baby hedgehog's grin.
Good day, he cried.
This day.
So good.
Right?
She squinted at him.
He was kind of weird looking.
Maybe he was one of the many hybrids here
in Sanctuary, although he looked older
than the little dragonette she'd seen
older than her, actually, if she had to
guess.
His gales were not quite skywing, not
quite sandwing, but somewhere in between
a sort of pale orange.
He had no tail barb though, and his eyes
were a washed out blue.
He didn't look at all dangerous, partly
thanks to the crooked daisy chain wound
around his horns.
Can I help you?
Snfall asked.
I've come to hear to bargain for this, uh
delicious scavenger, the dragon
declared.
He waved one wing dramatically at the
enclosure.
Uh-huh.
Snowfall said skeptically.
I don't think she's for sale.
But I just adore scavenger.
Uh, chewing, he said.
He made a weird, grimacy face.
Chewing scavengers, meat.
Yum.
Want to eat them all day?
Chomp, chomp.
Yes.
So go hunt down one of your own, Snowfall
said.
Somehow, the more he talked, the less she
believed he actually wanted to eat the
scavenger.
I would, he said, but I. He trailed off
and shot a panicked look at the bushes.
Um, don't want to?
Snowfall propped her chin on her front
talons.
This was the most entertainingly strange
thing that had happened to her in days.
You'd rather buy a scavenger that's not
for sale than go catch your own.
Could it be for sale?
He said hopefully.
I have blueberries?
Snowfall laughed.
Winter is not going to sell you his pet
even for all the blueberries in the
world.
Oh, he said.
Oh.
He shot a look at the bushes like, I told
you so, bushes.
She's a pet?
Not for chewy delicious eating.
Snowfall couldn't begin to guess why this
dragon spoke so oddly now and then.
Yep.
It's a pet, she said.
My cousin loves these critters.
He's been trying to catch a good one for
ages.
And she's a good one?
he said, looking as pleased as if she had
complimented him.
Well, she is energetic, Snowfall said
picking over at her again.
The scavenger was leaning innocently
against the far wall, spinning a stick in
her paws.
And Winter says she's a good mimic.
She's made some very dragon like noises
at him, which made him think she's
terribly clever.
The stranger gave a little snort of
laughter.
Hmm, he said.
What if she doesn't want to be his pet?
Snowfall tilted her head at him.
Well, we can't exactly ask her.
I'm sure she's perfectly happy.
He feeds her like twice a day.
What if I gave him a different pet, a
better pet?
the odd dragon suggested, with a
triumphant flourish of his wings.
I am quite sure he...
How about a snail?
The dragon cried.
With a kind of rapturous delight, Snowfall
had only ever seen on dragonettes tasting
ice cream for the 1st time.
A snail, Snowfall echoed.
Snails are amazing, he said adoringly.
Have you seen them?
I have seen snails?
Yes, she said.
Queen Coral had served sea snails during
her visit to the kingdom of the sea, but
Snowfall had a feeling this dragon's
heart would explode if she told him
that.
Or a turtle, he shouted.
I could give him a turtle.
Ah, don't you love turtles with their
little flippery flippers and their sweet
little shells and their tiny heads?
Have you seen their tiny heads?
They look like they're smiling.
Little tiny turtle smiles.
Wouldn't he love a turtle?
He would not.
Snowfall said positively.
I must say, it sounds like you should get
a turtle though.
Yes, he said dreamily.
That is exactly what I have been saying.
He shot another Did you hear that
bushes?
Look at the shrubbery.
How about you go get a turtle then
Snowball said, and leave this scavenger
to my obsessed cousin.
Oh, he said, shaking his head as if he'd
completely forgotten what he was there
for.
Right.
No, no.
I would like this scavenger very much.
This one.
Please.
The bushes behind him made some highly
suspicious squeaking noises.
Snowfall squinted at them.
Did he already have a scavenger?
Maybe he collected them.
Maybe he was Winter's dream brand.
If you're so interested in scavengers.
Wait and talk to Winter about them, she
suggested.
He can tell you everything he's learned
from studying them if you have 20 days to
listen to some outlandish theories.
Can't I please have this scavenger?
He said, with enormous baby seal eyes.
Please, please, please?
Being cute doesn't work on me.
Nice try. she barked.
I am the queen of the ice wings, and I
have told you no.
Queen of the what?
Really?
he said.
Yes, really?
How do you not know that?
She lashed her tail.
The settlement is full of queens right
now, so you should practice being a
little less adorable and a little more
respectful.
What the heck are you anyway?
A hybrid of what?
A startling thought struck her.
Could he possibly be an ice wing sky wing
hybrid?
Not a hybrid, he said.
Just a funny looking sky wing.
He turned and hissed the bushes.
She thinks I'm adorable.
I do not. 3 moons.
Who are you talking to?
No one, he blurted.
Sorry, nothing.
Never mind.
I am not needing the scavenger after
all.
Everything great.
Nice to meet you.
Bye forever.
He turned and bolted into the woods.
There was a bit more thrashing around in
the greenery, and then Snowfall saw his
tail darting away through the trees.
Weirdest dragon of all time.
But she had to admit, this feeling of
amusement and slight confusion was
preferable to the overwhelming anxiety
she normally lived in.
She wouldn't mind being distracted from
the end of the world by him again.
Shaking her head, she glanced over to
check the enclosure.
She should have noticed that it had
gotten very quiet.
She should have been more suspicious of a
scavenger standing so still for once.
She might have guessed that the scavenger
had been standing right there to hide the
new hole in the fence.
If she had, she might have caught the
scavenger before it escaped.
But it was too late.
Winter's pet was gone.
Chapter 17.
Oh, walruses.
Snowball hissed.
This was the last thing she needed to
deal with right now.
She flew down into the enclosure and
marched around it, double checking.
Yes, pumpkin was absolutely gone.
The hole was just big enough for a
scavenger, partly tunneled under the
fence, and partly hacked out of the
wood.
Outside the fence, there was a scramble
of marks in the dirt where the scavenger
would have emerged, but it was hard to
tell what kinds of marks they were.
Hang on.
Was that dragon distracting me so he
could steal her?
But he hadn't moved from his spot while
they talked.
So he must have had an accomplice.
Another dragon?
Why would 2 dragons go to all the trouble
of stealing one scavenger, who was barely
enough of a meal for one of them?
Snowfall frowned at the marks in the
dirt.
She didn't see anything that looked like
a talon or tail had made it.
And the scavenger must have been digging
from her side too.
Unlucky that she escaped right into a
dragon's claws.
If that's what happened.
This really made no sense.
Snowfall sighed deeply.
She should probably go into the forest
and try to catch that dragon just in case
he did have pumpkin.
Grumbling to herself, she set off into
the trees.
Should I wait for my guards?
No, she could handle an overly smiley
dragon who went into raptures over
turtles.
No problem.
Ooh, especially if she used her stealth
armbands.
She set them gleefully to make herself
invisible and darted in the direction
where she'd last seen his tail.
It didn't take long before she heard his
voice burbling away up ahead.
Snowfall slowed to a stealthier pace, and
crept toward him.
He sounded utterly insane.
Whatever he was saying was half words
half yips and chitters, and meeping
noises, as if his brain kept turning into
a chipmunk mid sentence.
She slipped through the trees to get
ahead of him, which wasn't hard, as he
was just ambling along chatting to thin
air.
There were clearly no other dragons with
him, so perhaps his accomplice had gone
in a different direction.
Or perhaps she was wrong, and this dragon
hadn't stolen pumpkin, but she smelled
scavengers somewhere nearby, and his
behavior had been very suspicious.
So she didn't feel guilty about the heart
attack.
She was about to give him Aha!
She shouted. leaping into his path and
flinging off the invisibility magic.
He shrieked.
In a very gratifyingly terrified way.
Give it back, she shouted.
You stole Winter Scavenger.
Give it back now.
She wasn't his. somebody yelled back at
her.
Not the dragon, though.
He was standing there, with his mouth
closed, and his eyes wide open.
What the?
You can't own a scavenger.
We're not pets.
There was a scavenger.
Standing On the dragon's head.
Shouting at snowfall.
In Dragon.
Except you.
You're my pet, the dragon said quickly
almost under his breath, and then made a
face as if he was trying very hard not to
laugh.
Not helpful Skye.
The scavenger barked at him, poking the
top of his head with her foot.
But, but, Snowfall had never in her
entire life been so at a loss for words.
A scavenger.
Speaking dragon.
In a conversation, like it was really
talking to her.
How is this happening?
She glanced down at her jewelry.
Was this another animus curse?
Was she hallucinating, intelligent
talking scavengers now?
Where's pumpkin?
she demanded.
The dragon started snorting with laughter
so much that the scavenger on his head
had to grab his horns so she wouldn't
fall off.
Her name is daffodil, said the
scavenger.
Oh.
Ah, Snowball said, very much in denial
that this conversation was real.
Much more dignified.
A small face peeked out from behind the
dragon's neck, surrounded by a halo of
dark hair.
She waved one of her little paws at
snowfall.
Does she speak dragon too?
Snowfall asked.
She's supposed to, said the scavenger on
the dragon's head.
If she paid attention and studied more
she'd be able to talk to any dragon to
try to kidnap her.
Daffa Dill.
Daffodil, pumpkin, shouted in dragon.
No eating.
The pitch of her voice was too high, and
the accents and growls were in all the
wrong places, but now that Snowfall was
listening for it, she could tell those
were dragon words.
Winter's former pet shook her head
huffily, and squeaked something scavenger
ish in what looked like indignant
outrage.
But scavengers couldn't be sentient.
They couldn't be smart enough to learn
dragon, and talk like dragons, and argue
with queens.
They were just big squirrels.
Pray.
This had to be some kind of party trick.
This weird sky wing, if that's really
what he was, must have trained his
scavengers to make all the right funny
noises.
Surely that was it.
Or else Snowfall would have to believe
that there was a whole civilization of
intelligent life living right under the
dragon's talons all this time, stealing
treasure, and getting eaten, and having
feelings?
Surely not.
This is Snowfall pressed her talons to
her head.
I can't, this makes no...
And then she realized the fuzziness and
headache and creeping darkness weren't
caused by the discovery that an everyday
snack could have a conversation with
her.
It was another vision, arriving now
whether she liked it or not.
Oh, no.
She muttered.
And then her eyes closed, and she
dropped.
Down, down, into.
What?
She is very small.
She is tiny and soft and furry and nimble
leaping from rock to rock, high above the
cave floor, unafraid, even though she has
no wings.
Below her, the green dragon growls and
spins, but it doesn't see her in the dark
shadows of the cave ceiling.
Nice try, she thinks jubilantly.
This particular dragon has been trying to
catch one of them for days, but with no
luck, of course.
Ha ha.
Big old slow moving lizard.
Raven.
She holds onto a stalactite and turns
toward the voice.
Of course, it's mole, picking out of one
of the secret upper passages.
Hey, mole.
She says with a jaunty wave.
Get in here before the dragon sees you, he
hisses.
Raven sighs, but Mole has enough stress
without her adding to it.
She leaps neatly to the ledge beside him
and crawls through the hole in the wall.
On the other side.
The passages are only big enough for
humans.
These winding tunnels are the safe parts
of the cave, which is to say, the boring
parts.
Are you trying to get caught by a
dragon?
he asks.
Of course not, Raven says cheerfully.
I just think it's funny to watch them get
all grumpy about it.
They set off toward their cave village.
You mustn't provoke them, Mole argues.
What if one of them catches you or gets
really mad and smashes down some cave
walls and finds all of us?
There are too many dragons down here
right now.
We should stay hidden, not run around
poking their noses and asking to be
eaten.
Raven rolls her eyes.
Don't you want to know why they're
suddenly here?
Something is happening in the sky world.
Something important.
Important to dragons maybe, he says.
Nothing to do with us.
Unless it's related to the abyss.
Raven points out.
He looks around furtively.
You know the rules.
But it's acting weird, and everyone knows
it, she says.
I don't think we can keep pretending it's
not there.
Well, if you would like to climb down
into the deepest, darkest hole in the
universe to figure out what those noises
are, then go ahead, Mole says.
Believe me out of it, and stop teasing
the dragons.
He runs on ahead of her, and she feels
guilty for a moment, that she's driven
him past the edges of his patience once
again.
Still.
It is strange that so many dragons came
crowding into the caves, acting weird.
Within days of the abyss changing for the
1st time in years.
Something is happening.
And Mole is wrong.
Whatever it is, if it scared the dragon.
Then there's every chance it could be the
end of the world for the humans.
Chapter 18.
Is she all right?
A voice whispered near Snowball's ear.
I've never seen a dragon paint before.
I think Wren yelled her into fainting, the
dragon's voice said disapprovingly.
That's me, terrifier of dragons, said
someone else.
She was definitely scared of me, right?
No, Snowball snapped, but she couldn't
open her eyes yet.
Everything was too strange.
Her limbs, her scales, her wings all felt
wrong, and it was taking forever for
herself to settle back into place.
Wait, did she just understand me?
The 3rd voice said.
They were speaking human.
Human, a language of its own, not just a
series of squeaks and grogs and gurgles
that the scavengers made.
I don't even want to know this word.
Human.
Should we be running away with a bishop?
The 1st voice asked.
Halfway through the sentence, the human
language faded from Snowfall's brain, and
her inner dragon breathed comforting
frost all through her.
I am Snowfall, she told herself
frantically.
Queen of the ice wings.
I am a dragon.
This is really, truly me.
She sat up, touching her head gingerly.
The pale orange dragon was crouched
beside her, with the dragon speaking
human, scavenger, on his shoulder.
Pumpkin was standing just behind one of
his talons, as if she was prepared to
either duck out of sight, or one forward
and attack, whichever was required.
Sorry, the dragon said kindly, in dragon
thank goodness.
We didn't mean to frighten you.
You did not frighten me, she growled.
The scavenger on the dragon's shoulder
put her hand on the sword at her belt.
I mean I'm not scared.
I get vision sometimes.
That's all that was.
It's a magic curse thing.
She tugged on the intractable ring.
That seemed very intentional, you rotten
accessory.
Were you enchanted to prove me wrong
every time I have a thought you don't
like?
Have you ever thrown any other queens
into the tiny edible body of something
else?
Well, why don't we all know about
scavengers?
If you have.
And if you haven't, why are you torturing
just me?
What did you see?
asked the strange scavenger.
More of you.
Snowfall answered, waving one of her
wings of the creature.
But I think they were on the other
continent.
It was harder to hold on to the memories
from this vision, because they made so
little sense to her dragon brain.
She could still feel the weird little
hairs and flat face and upright balance
of the human, but everything it knew, like
the details of its life underground, was
muddled and bewildering.
But the dragons hiding in the caves?
That sounded like Brian and her group.
And then something about an abyss?
This is Wren, said the dragon, gently
poking a scavenger on his shoulder with
one claw.
You've already met daffodil, and I'm
Skye.
No way, Snowfall said.
He blinked innocently, and she added, Sky
the Sky Wing.
That's completely ridiculous.
Oh, he said, his face relaxing.
Well, Ren named me, and she didn't know
what Skywings were called then about.
He shragged, as if that made any sense.
As if sure, scavengers named dragons all
the time. totally normal.
Winter is going to lose his entire mind.
Snowfall suddenly realized.
A scavenger that can talk to dragons, I
mean, I think his head might literally
explode.
I guess this means moon was right.
She contemplated not telling anybody
about this.
It would be insufferable to have to
confirm that Nightwing's impressions of
scavenger emotions.
But the thought of the look on Winter's
face outweighed everything else.
Wait, said Skye.
What?
We should go, Ren said, tugging on Skye's
ear.
No, no, no, Snowfall said.
No way.
You cannot make me go back to winter
alone to say, oh yes, pumpkin escaped, but
guess what?
She has a scavenger friend who speaks
dragon, and a weirdo dragon who speaks
scavenger.
Ah, well, but I let them go.
Didn't think you'd be interested.
Seriously.
Ren put her fists on her hips.
And you can't make us go back into that
city full of dragons to say, hello, we
escaped, no problem, but we thought it
would be great fun to come back and get
eaten instead, seriously.
Snowfall thought it was wildly funny that
Wren seemed to speak dragon better than
Sky himself did, and that she could even
master the exact right growly intonation
of seriously.
No one's going to eat you, she said.
Obviously, we don't eat things that talk
back to us.
That would be very unsettling.
Guess what's more unsettling, Bren said.
Being eaten.
Ren, maybe it would be fun to meet them
Skye said sweetly.
Maybe they're all nice dragons.
Well, not me, Snowfall said.
I'm definitely not nice.
I'm probably the least nice dragon in
Sanctuary right now.
So if I'm not going to eat you, most
likely nobody else will either.
And don't you want to talk to more
dragons?
Sky asked.
Building human dragon communication.
Isn't that our great quest or something?
No, that's Ivy's Great Quest, Ren
protested.
My great quest is to be left alone.
Snowfall didn't know if it was the vision
making her soft, or this particular
scavenger's personality, but she was
starting to quite like Ren.
Maybe I should get myself a scavenger pet
too, she thought.
The corners of her vision went blurry, and
she glanced down at the ring in alarm.
I mean, not a pet.
Scavengers aren't pets, they're
intelligent.
I meant friend, a scavenger friend.
To her enormous surprise, the blurriness
vanished again, and she did not collapse
or have a vision.
Hmm.
Can I actually talk this ring out of
giving me visions?
If I convince it I've learned whatever
lesson it's teaching me, I guess, she
sighed.
But still, that was a small, interesting
glimmer of hope.
Tell you what, Snowfall said to Ren, you
don't have to meet the entire city.
Just come back and talk to winter, so
he'll believe me.
Also, by the way, it's in your best
interest to prove to him that scavengers
are as smart as dragons, because then
he'll stop chasing you and locking you up
and giving you silly names.
I like the name pumpkin, Skye said.
Ooh, I want to know what he would call
Ren.
His eyes lit up.
Does he have any cute little hats?
Enough with the hats, ran hollered
whacking his neck, and then shaking out
her hand with a grimace that suggested
that had been a bad idea.
All right, fine.
We will come back with you to meet one
dragon.
Excellent.
Snowfall swept her wings behind her, and
led the way to sanctuary.
Unfortunately, when they got there, winter
was pacing around the outside of the
enclosure, lashing his tail, and there
were 3 other dragons with him.
Lynx, Cricket, and Kibley, who were all
helpfully searching through the grass and
bushes.
No wait.
Four, the small hive wing was there as
well, chasing a white butterfly.
It gave Snowfall a weird shiver to see
the baby hive wing tribe pouncing on the
butterfly, even though she missed.
She poked that discomfort for a moment
puzzled, and realized that must have come
from Tao or Io, who would see it as a
sign of a young hive wing, learning to
capture and control silk wings.
She's just playing with a bug.
Don't read into it.
Snowfall ordered herself, and by
extension, all the tangled up others
inside her.
Snowfall!
winter cried.
Pumpkin is missing.
He caught sight of Skye behind her.
Who, what?
That's not one dragon.
That's 5 dragons.
Wren hissed at Snowfall.
Snowball shrugged.
They're all friendly turtles on the
inside, though, she said, which earned
her a gigantic grin from Skye.
I'm very sure none of these will hurt you
so calm down.
He keeps saying pumpkin, Cricket said
pointing to Winter, but what he's
describing sounds much more like a
reading monkey than a pumpkin to me.
I don't know whether I'm looking for an
orange gourd or a small furry thing with
cute paws.
I can't believe he didn't show you
pumpkin earlier, Link said.
He would talk about scavengers all day if
he could find someone to listen.
Scavengers, Cricket said, testing out the
word.
Cousin, Snowfall called to Winter.
Pumpkin is fine.
Get ready for your entire world to be
flipped upside down, though.
Winter tilted his head and took a stout
towards snowfall.
The cricket spotted the 2 scavengers on
Sky's back first.
She bounded over to them, her eyes as
huge as the moons.
Reading monkeys, she cried.
He did mean reading monkeys.
You have them here too.
Is she talking about us?
Ren whispered to Snowfall.
And what the heck kind of dragon is
that?
I mean, can yours read?
Cricket charged on.
Or are they more like regular monkeys?
The one I saw was holding something that
looked just like a book.
Can you imagine?
Monkeys who can read must also be able to
write, don't you think?
Don't you wonder what they'd write
about?
Monkey stories?
Can you think of anything more
fascinating?
Yes.
Actually, if you'd shut up for a moment
Snowfall interrupted.
Try monkeys who can speak dragon, although
they're not monkeys.
We call them scavengers.
And we call ourselves humans, Ren added.
Oh yes, here were the awestruck faces
Snowfall was looking for.
Cricket and winter both seem to be on the
verge of floating right off the planet
and hitting the moons.
Kibli recovered his voice first.
Did she?
Did she just?
My name is Ren, she said.
She pointed to the dragon.
Sky and that's daffodil.
Daffodils squeaked something.
Not pumpkin, when added.
She would like me to say that a couple
more times.
Daffodil.
Definitely not pumpkin.
Winter put one talent to his face and
rubbed it in a dazed way.
She kept making a noise that sounded like
daffodil, he said.
But of course I knew it couldn't be
daffodil, because that's impossible.
Ren chirped something at daffodil, and
daffodil chirped indignantly back, waving
her arms.
Can all humans speak dragon?
Cricket asked.
Bandit couldn't Winter answered.
Could he, do you know Bandit?
he asked Wren.
She raised her eyebrows at him, and
Kibley said, I think we can safely assume
that was not his real name.
Rand speaks dragon better than any other
human in the world, Sky said proudly.
She's a natural.
All that growling and roaring, you know
it matches her personality.
Do you have books?
Cricket blurted.
I mean, the human, I saw, was back on the
other continent, and it looked like it
was reading a book.
So I just wondered if maybe you read
books too?
How is that your 1st question?
Winter asked.
I do read books, Ren said.
She tipped her head to study cricket's
delighted face, and the octagonal
spectacles that rested on her snout.
What kind of dragon are you?
Did you say other continent?
Sky asked.
I'm a hivewing from Pantala, on the far
side of the ocean.
Cricket said, waving vaguely westward.
That's wild.
Did you have scavengers over there too
Kibley said.
I wonder if they speak the same language
as these ones.
They do, Snowfall said.
She'd been replaying her vision in her
mind.
They live in the cave systems underneath
the Savannah.
And I think, I think they know something
about the breath of evil.
Chapter 19.
Snowfall explained about her vision, about
being inside a human on the other
continent.
She said something about an abyss.
She said it was acting strangely, whatever
that means.
Snowfall looked around at the other
dragons.
Perhaps it's connected to the mind
control in the plant.
We should find out, Kibble said
excitedly.
That's it.
Your Majesty, you found the perfect
solution.
Did I?
She said.
I mean, of course I did.
But you explain it.
We shouldn't send our armies to fight
Queen Wasp, Kibley said.
Cricket flinched, and he spread his front
talons quickly.
Wait, listen.
Armies are for wars where you want to
kill as many of their dragons as possible
before they kill you.
But we don't want to kill their dragons.
Most of them are friends and family who
wouldn't be fighting if they weren't
under wasps' control.
What we need is a way to free them.
And not even all the armies in Pyria
would be able to do that.
Sure, but if we send all the armies in
Pyria, they could at least kill Queen
Wasp, Snowball said.
Maybe that's all we have to do.
I'm very into that plan.
We don't think killing Queen Wasp will be
enough, Cricket said with a little
shiver.
There's something or someone else
controlling her, and that's the thing we
really have to fight.
Still, our armies could help, Snowfall
said.
With those rain wing tranquilizer darts
we could knock out all the hive wings and
imprison them while we work on the
freeing them part, and the killing queen
wasp part.
Now Winter was giving her that look she
kept getting, as though her horns had
turned bright pink and were spouting
lemonade.
What?
Snowfall demanded.
Why is your face doing that at me?
I'm sorry, Your Majesty. he said, ducking
his head.
I just...
Never expected you to be one of the
queens who argued for helping the
Pentalan dragons.
I am familiar with a concept of empathy.
Cousin, Snowfall said frostily.
Would you 2 please shut your glamorous
ice wing snout?
Kibley said.
I'm not finished.
Listen to my awesome plan.
Instead of armies.
We have to send a secret stealth team of
dragons to Pantala.
Their mission?
To find out the truth about the breath of
evil, and how to destroy it.
That sounds.
Much easier said than done, Winter
observed.
I want to go with the Secret Stealth team
Cricket said.
Me.
The little hive wing shouted from the top
of the boulder.
Me stealth.
She leaped off the boulder. flapped her
wings wildly for a moment, and then
somersaulted into the grass.
Daffodil crouched and held out one hand
and the tiny dragonette wobbled over to
sniff it, warbling cheerfully.
Find out the truth?
Leng asked.
How exactly?
Kibley pointed at Snowfall.
By going into the abyss.
Everyone stared at him.
He flapped his wings with dramatic
exasperation.
Come on, everybody.
Haven't you been listening to Moon's
prophecy?
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
What farther below than an abyss?
Seriously?
This one is much clearer than the last
one.
Three moons, Winter said.
I sincerely hate to say this, but I think
Kibli might be right.
Also, bonus, a stealth team mission is
something we can do without requiring
armies and soldiers from all the queens
Kibley pointed out.
I think we could get everyone on board
with this plan.
And while the secret team is gone
Snowfall said, we could get our armies
ready, just in case we do need them to
fight at some point.
Far below.
Cricket echoed, staring off toward the
setting sun.
It does make sense.
If everything in that vision was true.
But how are we going to find this abyss?
Do we have to search all of Pantala?
Kibli scratched his head awkwardly.
Well, he said, it would be helpful if we
had someone who could talk to the
scavengers for us.
He glanced sideways at Skye and Wren.
Absolutely not, Ren said.
I don't know what you're talking about
but I'm very sure I don't like the sound
of it.
What?
Sky tore his gaze away from a chipmunk
that was adorably nibbling something near
his talons.
Sorry, what?
We're offering to take you to the other
continent, cricket said.
To meet humans from all the way across
the sea.
Can you imagine?
Just think, what are they like?
How different are their lives from yours
and how much is the same?
Isn't that just amazing to think about?
I'm all right where I am.
Thank you, Ren said.
I don't need another continent full of
people to worry about.
This one is quite sufficient.
But you could save so many dragons, Kibley
said.
If you help us find the Pentalan humans
and they can take us to the abyss, and we
can stop the breath of evil.
I mean, you'd be saving the entire world
basically.
Ren pointed at him.
That does sound fun.
Except for the part where I probably get
eaten and Sky probably gets evil breath
whatever that is.
Sky snort chuckled.
Leaves the one with evil breath, at least
1st thing in the morning.
Hush, you, Ren said, nudging him.
We won't let you get eaten.
Winter said in his most noble voice, Every
dragon on the quest would protect you
with his or her life.
I would gladly sacrifice myself to keep
you safe.
Too much.
Kibley said, patting Winter's talon
gently.
Very heroic and dashing, but you can take
it down a notch.
I can take care of myself.
Sky is the one I'm worried about, Ren
explained.
He is not a super stealth or a fighting
evil kind of dragon.
He is a, But do the bad guys know about
pandas?
Because then I bet they wouldn't be evil
anymore, kind of dragon.
Well, but Sky protested.
I mean, pandas, have you seen pandas?
Is there any chance you're actually a
rain wing?
Winter asked.
You can't take Sky into a war zone, Ren
said, wrapping her arms around his neck
as far as they would go.
I'd be all right, Skye said, nudging her
head with a snout.
Everyone else could do the shouty, stabby
parts, and I could just talk to the
humans.
And maybe the other continent has
something even cuter than pandas.
We have lots of different kinds of
monkeys.
Crickets said, hopefully.
Snowfall could tell that Wren was not
buying any of this, and that she was the
one who made the decisions for these
two.
Think like a scavin- human, she thought.
Remember what it felt like to be Raven.
What did they want?
What did they worry about?
What do I know they could change Ren's
mind?
Human, she said.
I mean, Wren. listen.
What if the agreement went 2 ways?
You and Skye help us save dragons, and we
help you save humans?
Ran glanced over at Daffodil, who was
tossing the baby hive wing up in the air
and then catching her again as the
dragonette giggled.
Keep talking.
All the queens of the dragon tribes are
here in sanctuary right now, Snowfall
said.
In exchange for your help, we could issue
an edict that dragons are no longer
allowed to hunt or eat humans in any of
our kingdoms.
Ooh, Skye said, nudging ran again.
Ivy would love that.
Every human would love that, Ren said.
But would it work?
Do dragons listen to their queens?
How would it be enforced?
And what if the next queen reverses the
edict?
My tribe listens to their queen.
Snowfall said haughtily.
And there isn't going to be a next queen
for a very long time.
It's worth a try, isn't it?
Kibley said to Ren.
It would probably save a lot of humans
even if some dragons disobeyed the
orders.
I love this plan.
Skye said happily.
Let's do this plan.
It is a great idea, Kibley said to
Snowfall.
See, Blank said, thwacking Kibli's wing
with her own.
I told you, best queen ever.
Snowfall fluffed out her wings and gave
Winter I, who's the best cousin for the
throne now, face?
which was a little unwarranted since he'd
never shown any sign of preferring
crystal.
But he was the nearest ice wing she could
make a smug face at.
Truthfully, she thought the other queens
would probably issue an edict like that
with or without Wren's agreement to come
to Pantala.
Once they realized that scavengers could
think and read and talk like dragons, she
assumed they wouldn't be at all
interested in eating them anymore.
No more pet scavengers either, Ren said
wagging her finger at winter again.
She might have noticed the wistful
glances he kept casting at daffodil.
That should be in there too.
Unless they want to be dragon pets, Skye
said, or the hats are very cute.
Do humans love hats, Winter asked
hopefully.
I could get put daffodilla hat.
No, we do not love hats.
Wren glared at Skye.
And daffodil would be the worst pet
really.
She might be willing to stay and practice
her dragon with you for a while, though
if you'd actually listen and not lock her
up.
And if you let her keep playing with
Bumblebee.
Cricket observed.
The hive wing dragonette was now curled
around daffodil's shoulders, winding the
human's hair between her claws.
I promise, Winters said meekly.
No more pets.
I'll tell everyone else.
He gave Kibley a suddenly horrified
luck.
Smolder has a pet human.
He's had her for years.
We must fly at once to convince him to
free her.
Oh no, she's fine, Ren said.
We've met, and she's happy.
Don't worry about her.
Hmm, Winters said, subsiding.
Let's go talk to the other queens
Snowfall said.
You 2 can stay here and think about our
offer, and we hope you'll still be here
to discuss it when we return.
She beckoned imperiously to Kibley, and
swept across the clearing with links
trotting along beside her.
Will this work?
Snowfall flicked her tail.
Sending a small group of dragons over to
Pantala. armed with a talon full of
tranquilizer darts, a line from a
prophecy and a scavenger.
She thought of the chillingly malevolent
feel of wasps' brain, and the evil
tendrils she'd felt wound all the way
through it.
Is there anything that can save Tao, and
Bryony, and Blue, and Io, and everyone
else?
Or is the prophecy right?
And none of the tribes will survive?
Part 3.
Walls of ice.
Chapter 20.
The night before their return to the Ice
Kingdom, Snowfall had no dreams at all.
She slept peacefully until quite some
time past dawn, and woke up slowly to
wrestling leaves, bars of sunlight, and
several worried ice wing faces ducking
away as she opened her eyes.
Except for two.
Links and crystals stayed where they were
watching her.
Lynx looked disgustingly cheerful, as
usual, and Crystal wore a mask of boredom
over something Snowfall now realized was
nervousness.
Her tail kept twitching, and she glanced
at the trees occasionally as if she was
thinking about flying away.
Good morning, Snowfall said, stretching.
Crystal, I have made a decision.
If you would like to return to the ice
kingdom anytime, for any reason.
I give you my word, I will not have you
killed.
Wait.
Unless you come with an army to try and
steal my throne, then I will probably
have to kill you.
So, I guess I mean, if you would like to
return to the ice kingdom anytime, for
any not deposing snowfall reason, you are
welcome, and you'll be safe.
Oh, Crystal said.
I, thank you.
If it helps, I have no intention of ever
bringing an army to steal the throne, I
really don't want it.
Weirdo, Snowfall said, but nicely.
Also, you have my permission to marry
Garyel.
I wasn't aware I needed that, Crystal
said wryly, but thank you for that as
well.
Snowfall waved one talent.
Permission, blessing, whatever you want
to call it, your queen will not be mad.
You will not be banished.
Crystal tipped her snout down for a
moment, then looked back up with
suspiciously shiny eyes.
I appreciate that, she said.
It is very silly, Snowfall said, that you
are more emotional about me approving
your mud wing than you were about me
promising not to kill you.
I know, Crystal said, with a little laugh
wiping her eyes.
I just came to say goodbye.
I heard you're flying home today.
Yes, Snowfall said.
We had an excellent council of queens
yesterday, and I was an extremely
excellent queen part of it, wasn't I
lynx?
Absolutely marvelous, Link said.
We need a better name than Secret Stealth
team, though?
Snowfall said.
Anyway, the queens agree that we'll all
stop eating scavengers, and we chose the
group that's going to go to Pantala to
search for the Abyss and the Pentalaan
humans, which means I'll have to carry
another map back over to that continent
but it can't be helped.
Personally, I think they should eat it
when they get there.
I can't believe it about scavengers
Crystal said, looking a little green.
When I think.
I just can't think about it.
I have a feeling.
A lot of dragons are going to be pretty
horrified, Lang said.
And some others are going to violently
deny that it's true, so that they don't
have to feel bad about themselves.
Snowball pointed out.
But that is a problem for another day.
Today, my problem is that going home
means I'll have to rearrange all the
names on the stupid wall again.
Oh, wow, the wall, Crystal said with a
laugh.
I totally forgot about that.
How can you forget about the wall
Snowfall said, shocked.
You're still near the top of the 1st
circle.
I kept you there.
Crystal shrugged.
I guess when you're away from it for long
enough.
You realize how pointless it is.
Lynx made a phase that snowfall like, this
is what I was saying.
Remember that time you totally yelled at
me?
I was totally right.
And look, she thinks so too.
Well fine, Snowfall said.
Say goodbye to our mud wing for us.
I'm Asgobi and namely polite to the other
queens for half the day before we can
leave.
You sound a lot more like yourself today
Links observed.
Was that true?
Maybe a night with no visions had brought
her back to herself completely?
Maybe the visions were over?
Snowfall hugged hopefully on the ring.
Nope, still stuck.
She'd have to tell the guards to stay
close enough to catch her in case she
suddenly fell out of the sky on the
flight home.
The queens had decided that face a great
evil with talent united, meant they
should send one dragon from each tribe on
the mission.
Personally, Snowfall thought a team of 10
dragons wasn't the most stealthy idea, but
she wasn't about to wade into the
question of which tribes should be left
out.
Some of the choices were easy.
They only had one hive wing, for instance
and Skye had to be the Sky Wing, and
tsunami didn't bother to ask anyone's
permission to be the sea wing, although
Queen Carl seemed fine with it once she
arrived.
Luna and Sundu convinced Hazel to let
them be the Silk Wing and Leaf Wing
representatives.
Queen Thorn looked worried when Kibli
said he wanted to go, but she agreed that
he was the best choice.
Snowfall could see how much she didn't
want to lose him.
Queen Morehen offered a brawny mud wing
nearly twice the size of most of the
other dragons, a volunteer named
Bullfrog.
Queen Glory had to choose 2 dragons.
She settled on a serious looking rain
wing with a very silly name of pineapple
and moon for the night wing.
Snowfall had the hardest choice, in her
opinion, because she had 2 ice wings who
really wanted to go.
On the one talon, she wanted links to
come back to the ice kingdom with her, to
join her new council, and keep Snowfall
sane.
On the other talent, she trusted Links
more than any other ice wing, and
Snowfall knew for certain that Links was
smart and clever enough to be very
valuable on the mission.
On the 3rd talent, Winter was
occasionally quite smart too, and she
wouldn't miss him nearly as much.
But on the 4th talon, would sending him
really count?
If he was technically banished and not
part of the tribe.
Would Snowfall be risking the whole
mission, just because she wanted to keep
her friend close to her?
She didn't say any of that to them, but
she did gradually admit to herself that
friend was the right word for links after
all.
In the end, she chose links.
Winter would be useful in sanctuary
overseeing the scavenger outreach project
and keeping daffodil safe.
Snowfall did not like to think about how
Ren would react if she came back from
Pantala and someone had accidentally
stepped on daffodil.
So the stealth team was gathered, and
there was a ceremony for them that
involved a lot of awkward talent holding
and speeches from the queens.
Boring, boring, snowfall thought, and
tried not to look at links too often, in
case something stupid and wet happened to
her eyeballs.
She'll be back.
She has to come back.
She watched Sky instead, who was so
excited about all his new dragon friends
and his valiant purpose, and heroic
destiny, and absolutely everything.
Then she realized how much she was going
to worry about his sweet, grinning face
going into danger, and she had to fix her
gaze on bullfrog instead.
There was no risk that she'd get sappy
and sentimental about him.
When the polite farewells finally began
Snowfall took a deep breath.
There was something she had to do, even
though it made her anxiety spike right up
to the moons.
She crossed the clearing to sundew, who
was sitting with her tail twined around
willows, holding one of her talons.
Willow looked as though she'd been crying
all morning.
Sundew tilted her head to meet Snowfall's
eyes.
Yes?
We don't have weapons. like the rain wing
darts to offer you, Snowfall said, nodding
to the pile that pineapple was sorting
into pouches.
But I wanted to give you something else
since I'm guessing you're going to be the
leader of this team, or you should be, no
matter what tsunami thinks.
And you're right, that our magic should
have been able to help you, and if any
piece of magic can help defeat that thing
over there?
I think you should have it.
She unclipped the gift of stealth from
her wrists, and sundew sat up, shining
like the northern lights.
Magic?
The leaf wing echoed.
This is how I made my army invisible.
Snowfall said, passing the wristbands to
her.
It felt a bit like snapping off her horns
and passing them over after so many days
of having the reassuring magic weight of
them on her arms.
We call them the gift of stealth, and
since stealth is literally in the name
and that's your whole mission, I mean, It
just makes sense.
Sundu put them on reverently, the pale
silver metal strange against her dark
green and gold scales.
How do they work?
Snowfall explained everything from the
notes in the treasury, and Sundew
practiced turning herself, then Willow
then both of them invisible.
When they reappeared.
Willow wrapped her wings around
Snowfall.
Thank you.
She whispered in Snowfall's ear.
I feel a little less worried now.
What am I doing?
Snowfall thought. giving away one of the
only animous treasures my tribe has.
Maybe one of the last ones that will ever
be made in this world.
Giving up ice wing magic.
To a strange dragon from a far away
land.
Snowfall straightened her shoulders as
Willow went back to Sundew's side.
I'm choosing to trust them.
This is the right thing to do.
They need it to defeat the breath of evil
and we all need them to succeed.
I'll bring them back, Sundu promised.
When we've won, and everyone is safe.
I'll return them to you.
Thank you, Queen Snowfall.
Good luck, Snowfall said.
She took a step back, glancing at the
gift of stealth one last time.
And then she turned and went up to the
lake to find winter.
Hello, she said, startling him into
dropping the fish he'd just caught.
I hereby decree that you are not banished
anymore, unless you would like to be.
Also, you can go back to that school, if
you want to.
I still don't care.
She hesitated, but I guess there's a very
tiny part of me that wants you to be
happy, she finished in a rush.
Winter dipped his front talons in the
cold lake and smiled down at the water
looking a little surprised and
embarrassed, and pleased at the same
time.
Thank you, Your Majesty. he said.
Ah, she said.
It's too weird.
Just call me Queen Snowfall.
He laughed, and then his face turned
serious again.
Snowfall, you're my queen, and the ice
wings will always be my tribe, whether
I'm banished or not, but Jade Mountain
and Sanctuary.
They've made me feel like I'm part of a
bigger tribe.
Like I'm worth something more than a
place on a wall.
Hmm.
I suppose you are, Snowfall said.
It's possible.
Everyone is, but you didn't hear that
from me.
Good luck with that little daffodil
human.
Stay in touch, winter.
Snowfall made her way through all the
polite goodbyes to the other queens, and
eventually found her guards waiting for
her, ready to fly.
Standing with them was links, who also
looked ready to fly.
Aren't you leaving on a mission
tomorrow?
Snowfall demanded frowning at her.
Day after tomorrow, actually, Lang said.
I'm going to fly home with you 1st and
then meet the others on Jaboa's beach.
Snowfall did not let herself make the
silly sky phase.
She felt her inner dragon making.
Oh, she said.
Very well.
I suppose that's fine with me.
Because you need something from the
palace.
Dragons to say goodbye to.
Lynx nudged her side and smiled.
Just wanted to hang out with you for a
couple more days.
Snowfall scrunched her snout at her, so
that she wouldn't either start beaming or
burst into tears.
Wow, fine.
All right.
I suppose that's fine with me too.
It was late in the day when snowfall and
lynx and the other 10 ice wings reached
the great ice cliff.
Snowfall saw it first, ahead of them in
the distance, huge and glowing red gold
in the sunset.
For 1000s of years.
It's kept all other tribes out of the ice
kingdom.
We always thought it kept us safe.
I thought it was so important.
I wanted to extend it all around us, so
my tribe could huddle safely in our
igloos and ice palaces, and no one would
ever be able to get through our walls of
ice.
But if we'd all stayed hidden in the ice
kingdom, Dark Stalker's plague would have
killed us, we needed dragons from other
tribes, working together. to recognize
his magic and find a way to save us.
We needed hybrids like Typhoon, who could
cross the wall, and were spared the
plague, to bring us those earrings.
We only survived because of our
connections to the other kingdom.
Her wing beats slowed.
And if the breath of evil comes here, if
it lands in the ice kingdom first, we may
need those connections again.
Besides, I want to know what happens on
Pantala.
I want dragons to be able to come tell
me.
I want sundew and sky to be able to fly
right into my kingdom and find me if they
need to.
She veered suddenly into a wind current
that dropped toward the cliff.
Startled, the others wheeled around to
follow her.
Snowfall landed on top of the cliff.
She could see the sheer face of it
dropping away on either side of her
talons.
Length hovered beside her, beating the
air with her wings.
What's happening?
Lang asked.
Snowfall adjusted her small, elegant
crown.
Did I ever tell you what this does?
She asked, pointing to it.
It's the tiara of strength.
All right, all right.
Stop laughing.
It makes me very, very, very strong.
So laughing at me is an even less good
idea than it usually is.
Anyway, my point is, that I've hardly
gotten to play with it at all, since this
turned out not to be the punching dragons
in the snout expedition I thought it was
going to be.
I, for one, am quite glad we didn't have
to punch any dragons in the snout, Lynx
observed.
Want to see how strong I am?
Snowfall asked.
She slammed her fist into the ice below
her.
Cracks shot out from the spot where her
talents met the ice, and the surface
below her shook.
She punched it again as hard as she could
and then had to lift into the air as the
cliff began to shake harder, and chunks
of ice broke off, and started avalanching
down toward the snow below.
Snowfall hit the cliff again and again
triggering more cascades of ice and snow
until she had punched a pretty impressive
hole in it, if she did say so herself.
Oof.
Now her fists hurt.
And her muscles ached, and she was very
tired.
But the look on the other ice wing's
faces was worth it.
That's amazing, Link said, flying down to
swoop through the gap in the cliff, as if
to make sure it was real.
Does that break the spell?
Can other tribes fly through here safely
now?
I'm not sure.
Snowfall said.
We'll come back soon with many more
dragons and tear down the rest of it.
She shook out her claws with a wince.
Maybe I will let someone else wear the
magic strength tiara, and I will do the
ordering everybody around part instead.
Wow.
Links gathered a talon full of snow and
packed it around snowfall's claws.
What happened to everyone is evil and
can't be trusted.
Snowfall looked at her severely.
I have been 6 different dragons and a
human this week, and only one of them was
evil.
I am basically an expert on other dragons
now.
And with my knowledge of everything, I
can now say for a fact that several
dragons are not evil after all.
Several dragons?
Lang said in mock surprise.
Are you sure?
Snowfall flicked her with her tail.
I might even say most dragons.
Still dubious about you, though.
Pretty sure that face you make when you
think you've won puts you right into the
evil category.
Fair, said Lynx grinning.
As long as I still win.
She glanced up at the darkening sky, where
stars were starting to glitter.
It's getting a bit late to fly the rest
of the way to the ice palace.
Maybe we could make camp in the snow.
What do you think?
One more night away from the palace.
Yes, let's do that, Snowfall said.
She turned to the guards.
If that's all right with all of you.
They did a lot of startled blinking
before one of them said, of course, Your
Majesty.
Whatever you wish is fine with us.
It was pretty thrilling to be back in the
ice kingdom, to be making their beds and
piles of snow again.
Snowfall rolled around in hers for a
while, cleaning all the dust off her
scales, until she felt shiny and cold
again.
Then she curled up and stared at the opal
ring.
It had been silent all day.
Where the visions really gone?
If so, why was it still stuck on her
finger?
Was it just lying in wait to spring a
whole bunch of terrible dragons on her at
once?
Hey, magic ring, she whispered.
I put up with all your visions.
I told those Pentalen dragons what you
showed me.
I made peace with scavengers.
Is that what you wanted?
Twinkle, twinkle.
Smug twinkle.
I'm all right with no more visions
Snowfall whispered.
No more visions would be totally fine.
But if you do have to give me another one
tonight.
Could it please be the one I asked for?
Can you tell me what happened to animus
magic, and why it's not working?
If there's a way to fix it, We could use
it to help the Pentalan dragons.
Or if not.
Then, it would be good to know that too
so we can stop worrying about it at
least.
What do you think?
Twinkle, twinkle, twinkle.
Mysterious opal thoughts.
All right.
Snowball said, feeling her eyelids
droop.
Whatever you can do.
She yawned.
Thanks.
And let herself slip into sleep.
Chapter 21.
It is raining.
As always.
She hates the mud kingdom.
Hates everything about it.
From the gloppy swamp between her talons
to the incessant gurgling sound of water
coming from somewhere.
It's never warm enough, and she never
feels dry, even when she retreats to her
cave.
She is constantly worried that Queen
Crane might find her and she'll have to
flee to yet another kingdom.
But she couldn't stay in the stronghold
anymore.
She's not sure she'll ever be able to set
her talent in the desert again.
At least not until Queen Scorpion is
dead.
Which won't be for a long time.
Thanks to those healing and longevity
spells, Jerboa was forced to make for
her.
I said no when it mattered though.
She reminds herself, I saved the sky
wings.
And probably even more dragons than
that.
Queen Scorpion wouldn't have stopped.
She would always want more.
More land, more power, more of Jaboa's
magic.
It's almost as if she was the one losing
her soul, not me.
Treboa flexes her talons, trying to test
herself.
Do I feel like murdering anyone today?
Not particularly?
How about some senseless violence?
Is that on the agenda?
Don't think so.
How do we feel about tiny dragonettes?
Still think they're cute.
No, impulse to kill any of those, right?
She sighs and rests her head on her
claws.
She's always wanted a dragonette of her
own.
The Queen Scorpion kept her away from
other dragons.
And now that she's a fugitive, that dream
is even further away than ever.
Unless I use my magic.
She sits up.
Startled to full alert by the idea.
I could do that.
I think I could.
I could enchant a rock to turn into a
dragon egg.
Would that work?
Maybe it needs to already contain some
kind of life.
I've never brought something to life
before.
That might be on the list of things
animus magic can't do.
But I could steal someone else's egg and
change the dragon inside into a sand wing
like me.
Hang on.
That might have been an evil thought.
She rubs her temples, reviewing the
choices.
Right, yes.
Stealing someone else's egg would be
bad.
What if I found a different kind of egg?
A snake egg or ostrich egg, and changed
it into a dragon egg.
And whatever's alive inside, I make it a
dragonette, my own dragonette, who would
love only me forever.
She is so delighted with this plan that
she almost runs out into the rain to find
an egg right away.
But she stops herself on the threshold of
the cave.
Wait.
Be cautious.
It would not be safe for a dragonette to
be part of my life right now.
If Scorpion found us, she could use it
against me.
Bide your time, Jerboa.
Scorpion is not the only one enchanted
with longevity.
I could live forever if I wanted to.
If I'm patient.
She'll be gone, and then I can create my
dragonette, and we could return to the
kingdom of sand and live in peace.
Yes, really good plan.
Not evil, right?
Right, not evil.
Hugging herself with her wings.
She rolls against the cave wall and falls
asleep, dreaming of her beautiful
dragonette.
She is standing in the desert again at
last. 60 years of hiding was quite long
enough, and quite long enough for anyone
to be queen, especially the power mad
kind.
Queens die in their sleep of unexpected
heart attacks all the time.
It might have happened at any moment, even
without any magic help.
And really, I mean, 60 years, more than
long enough.
Her daughter is perfect, and now she is
perfect here.
In this perfect place, surrounded by sand
and wind and wide, wide open sky.
Welcome home, she says.
Treboa III doesn't answer.
She is in a bit of a snit because she
just found out about Jerboa the second
which was an accident.
Jerboa herself, the 1st Jerboa.
Hadn't planned to ever talk about the
daughter who went wrong.
Because it didn't matter.
She was gone.
And now Jerboa and the next Turboa were
together, and they could just be happy
couldn't they?
I want a different name, says the smaller
Jerboa, one of my own.
Why?
Jerboa is a lovely name.
Because I want to be my own dragon, she
huffs, not just one of your 100s of
copies of you.
I haven't made 100s of copies of me.
Jerboa argues.
Although, come to think of it, she could
couldn't she?
She could test them out, and see which
ones are pleasant company, and which ones
end up as stolen grouches.
She's sure she was never this bad
tempered.
So it's not like the current version is
that close the copy of her.
Maybe a closer copy would be nicer to
have around.
Was that an evil thought?
Her mental voice whispers, as if from
very far away.
You could have made 100s, and I would
never know, little Jerboa points out.
I could be number 847 or something. 847
dragonettes.
Sounds exhausting.
Even if she only tried them one at a time
Turbo wouldn't want to go through that
again and again, teaching each one how to
hunt, listening to their endless
questions.
But I could try a few.
Until I get a quiet, pleasant one.
Jerboa doesn't even have a good nickname
her daughter mutters.
Jerb, Jerby, Boa?
I guess you could call me Boa.
Turboa shrugs.
Ungrateful.
That's what this one is.
If I call you boa, she says, will you
stop sulking and appreciate this lovely
desert?
Fine.
Boa snaps, which doesn't sound like not
sulking to Jaboa, but she lets it go for
the moment.
I don't have to put up with this
forever.
If she becomes unbearable, I can always
start over.
Wait, wait.
Whispers the boys.
And then what?
You'd kill this one?
Didn't we decide once, long ago, that
killing dragonettes was always evil?
Even my own, she argues back.
Once I made myself, Yes.
I think so.
Hmm.
It is hard to imagine disposing of this
one neatly, and she can't just let her go
wandering off.
No one can find out that the long missing
sandwing animus is still alive.
Turboa does not want the hassle.
What if I simply?
Fix her a little, then.
Just a little spell to make her more
agreeable.
Obedient would be a good start, helpful
would be nice too.
She sinks her claws into the warm sand
picturing how perfect small turboa could
be.
But, Evil?
Whispers the little voice again.
Maybe?
Shush you, she whispers back.
I made this dragon.
I can perfect her if I want to.
Nobody gets hurt.
No, no.
I don't have to worry.
That's not evil at all.
She's flying over the ocean, wondering if
they should try shark again.
The last time it was a bit oily, but this
time Boa could prepare it differently.
That was such a good idea, making boa an
excellent cook.
A shame she had to add an extra spell to
also make her enjoy cooking.
She thought just being good at it would
be enough.
But no.
Boa tends to be lazy.
If she could do nothing at all, that
would be her preferred life.
Treboa thinks she wasn't always like
this.
When she was little, Boa had so much
energy.
Perhaps one of the spells went a little
awry.
Perhaps making her more placid, less
argumentative, more likely to say yes to
everything.
Perhaps that resulted in a bit of
laziness, too.
She'll try again.
Calibrating the right personality can be
quite difficult.
It turns out, even with magic.
She isn't in the mood for shark, after
all.
She'll bank Boa, go get them a camel.
It'll be good exercise for her.
As she swoops back down to the beach, she
spots something odd.
Boa is crouched in the surf building a
sand castle.
But the castle is building itself.
Turboa flips through several stages of
panic before she realizes what's really
happening.
Bowie is using one of the objects Treboa
enchanted, the stone that builds them a
new home each time they move.
But for a moment, she thought Boa had her
own magic, and that was terrifying.
What are you doing?
She asked, as she lands in a squelch of
wet sand.
Sand castle, Boa replies serenely.
Her tail swishes lightly as the waves
wash over her talons.
This is not a toy, Turboa hisses.
She snatches the stone out of Boa's
claws.
Boa blinks and bows her head.
Sorry.
You never touch mother's magic things.
Boa tips her head and looks slowly up at
her.
Can I have magic too?
I think I like some magic things of my
own.
No, no, no.
Treboa shakes her head.
Magic isn't safe.
It's very, very dangerous.
Only very special dragons should have it
and that's why it's so rare.
Only one animus dragon at a time.
That's the rule.
This is a lie.
But Boa will never know that.
For a while, Turboa knows.
There were 5 animus dragons coexisting
Empirea, one in the ice kingdom, 2 in the
kingdom of the sea, one in the night
kingdom, and herself.
She doesn't know exactly what happened to
each of them, but they're all gone now.
Everyone but her.
Sometimes she casts the spell, just to
check, but everything is quiet.
Peaceful, much less worrying that way.
Maybe she's a little bit right.
Maybe that much animus magic in the world
at once was like too many dragons
drinking from an oasis at the same time.
Maybe they sucked all the magic out of
the world.
Or maybe the magic is taking a break
waiting for a future generation of
dragons before letting another animus
hatch.
There are rules, Boa says.
About the magic?
Three moons.
She talks so slowly.
It's like all her words have to wade
through the mud wing swamps to make it
out of her mouth.
Absolutely.
Turboa says.
One animus dragon at a time.
If there are too many, can you imagine
how dangerous that would be?
They could get in a fight, start throwing
spells around, and destroy the whole
world by accident.
But Boa says, even more slowly.
One animus dragon could also destroy the
whole world just by herself.
You don't have to worry about that.
Treboa says, I'm the only animus dragon
right now, and I'm not going to destroy
anything.
Boa looks out at the sea, thinking
something at the speed of fossils
forming.
Couldn't I have just...
A little bit of magic.
She says finally.
Magic is also dangerous for your soul
remember?
Jaboa says.
I want to protect your soul, sweetheart.
Let me do all the magic, and take all the
risk on myself, and you stay safe.
All right.
Boa says with a sigh.
And Treboa can sense that one of her
spells is kicking in.
The one that stops Boa from arguing with
her.
That was a great one.
Still, this boa definitely needs a few
tweaks.
And something to make her stop growing.
Turboa enchanted herself to stop at a
normal dragon size.
If they both live for 1000s of years as
Jerboa is planning, it would be very
inconvenient if they wound up absurdly
gigantic.
She'll make Boa stop just a bit smaller
than her, so they'll always look like
mother and daughter.
Maybe she could add a little fear into
the mix as well.
If Boa is more scared of animus magic.
She won't keep asking for it.
And then she'll keep her grubby talons
off your boa's stash of magic items.
Yes, this is a good idea.
Did she once have 2nd thoughts about her
magic spells?
Wasn't there once a voice in her head
that asked, Something.
She shrugs it off.
It probably wasn't important.
She is curled beside the campfire at
night with stars twinkling overhead, and
Bowen nestled against her side.
Boa is small again, and Gerboa has
tripled the dragonette's usual love for
her, so she's extra cute and
affectionate.
It was getting boring having another full
grown dragon around, who never did
anything new or surprising.
Shrinking her down and starting her over
as a 2 year old dragonette, has made
things much more fun for the last couple
of years.
They've both been alive a very, very long
time.
Over 800 years.
Can that be right?
Turboa tries to think.
Boa has started over as a dragonette
several times in those centuries, and
Jerboa has lightly kept track of any
other animus dragons over the years.
She spotted 2 in the Knight Kingdom.
The granddaughter of a dragon named White
Out, and then that dragon's great
grandson, none in the ice kingdom in all
that time, one in the kingdom of the sea
in the royal family, but she didn't live
very long after having her own eggs.
Turboa doesn't know why.
She hasn't gone digging for more
information.
As long as they don't find out about her
or do anything earth shattering, she can
ignore them.
Mother, I think you should make me an
animus dragon.
Boa churps out of nowhere.
This, again.
Turboa thought she'd stomped down all of
Boa's curiosity about magic, but it keeps
coming up year after year, despite all
the memory wipes, and implanted
nightmares, and personality adjustments.
What is wrong with this dragonette?
Why can't Turboa fix it?
She sighs.
If you did have magic, she asks, or let's
say, if you could cast just one spell
what would it be?
Boa thinks, and thanks, and thanks.
Rewinding her age made her a faster
thinker again, but she's gotten slower
with each new spell since then.
I know, she says sweetly.
It would be a teleportation spell, one
that would bring me home to you anytime I
wanted, no matter where I was.
Oh, Treboa says, snuggling her closer.
But you don't need that.
We're never apart.
Is that a shadow flickering across Boa's
face?
I know, she said.
It would be just in case.
Just in case something very bad happened
and we got separated.
Treboa is pleased.
I can make that for you, she says.
She plugs a seashell from the sand, a
pale fan shape edged with dark pink.
Can't I?
Boa starts.
But your boa gently taps her snout with
her tail. and she falls silent.
It only takes a moment, and the spell is
cast.
This seashell will bring boa to her
mother instantly, at just a flicker of a
thought from either one of them.
It's quite neat, actually. 620 years ago
and 250 years ago, and 250 years ago, and
a few other times.
Jerboa can't remember exactly.
Boa tried to run away.
She doesn't remember any of that
misbehavior now, of course.
Each time Boa runs, she thinks it's the
1st time.
And it has been a real pain in the tail
to drag her back.
So it's perfect, that now Jerboa will be
able to do it with a snap of her claws.
Turboa pokes a hole in the shell, threads
a coconut fiber rope through it, and
loops it over Boa's neck.
There, she says.
See, you don't need magic.
Just ask me for whatever you need.
And if I think it's a good idea, I'll
make it for you.
Boa nods faintly.
She doesn't seem as delighted with a gift
as Jerboa would like.
For a moment.
Treboa considers making her more grateful
but really, it's too late now.
Bo has ruined what could have been a very
nice moment.
Treboa size.
A 1000 years.
Maybe it's time for something new.
What if I made you a brother?
she asked Boa.
Wouldn't that be fun?
Something flickers in Boa's eyes again.
Jealousy?
Poor dear.
It would be hard to share her mother
after all this time.
Would his name be Jerboa too?
She asks.
Turboa laughs.
No, of course not.
What do you want him to be like?
Funny, clever.
Boa traces a shape in the sand with her
claw.
You can do that?
she asks.
Make him turn out any way you want?
Of course, Traboa says.
We can even make him love to do all the
boring stuff we hate. like gathering
firewood, or cracking the lobster
shells.
Boa stares at her talons with a strange
expression.
I love gathering firewood.
She says in an odd voice.
Oh, that's right.
Turboa added that to the spell a little
while ago, when she got tired of either
doing it herself, or listening to Boa
whine about it.
Something else then, she says.
Whatever we don't want to do.
We can also make him age very slowly, so
he stays a cute little dragonette for as
long as we want.
Oh, and will make him a really good
sleeper, so he'll nap easily and fall
asleep whenever he starts fussing.
Not like you.
Miss up all night.
Boa tips her head up to the stars.
But, I sleep really well, she says, I
sleep all night, and sometimes during the
day.
I'm a really good sleeper.
Of course, you are now.
Turboa says impatiently.
So what do you think?
Would you like a new toy to play with?
Her daughter doesn't answer for a
boringly long time.
Just as Jerboa is about to snap at her
she suddenly turns and burrows under
Jerboa's wing.
No, she says, no, thank you.
Please?
I don't want a brother.
I like it just us.
I want to be your only dragonette.
Please?
Trabo is surprised.
Well, this is her own fault, phrasing it
like a question.
Instead of presenting the idea in a way
that Boa couldn't argue with.
Anyway, it's fine.
Boa is enough entertainment on her own
especially during the periods when Jerboa
makes her a talented musician. or
storyteller.
Another dragonette would probably be a
lot of trouble.
Boa is trembling.
Shivers running through both their
scales.
All right, all right.
Treboa says.
Just us, no more dragonettes.
Don't worry.
Look at her, sounding all nurturing and
kind.
She's such a great mom.
Promise?
Boa asks.
I promise.
Treboa says easily.
It's always easy to make promises to Boa
since she can erase them from Boa's mind
just as easily.
If Jerboa designs, She does want another
dragonette one day.
She'll have one, and Boa won't complain
or even remember this conversation.
For now, she'll have to think of
something else to make their lives
interesting.
They haven't abducted an enchanted
servant in a while.
Maybe a rain wing this time.
That would be pretty, and they don't eat
very much.
Yes, that would be a nice change of pace
around here.
She is very tired.
They have been flying all day to get to
their summer hut, and they weren't able
to stop at an oasis on the way because
there were so many sand wings milling
about below.
Every century.
It seems like there are more and more
dragons everywhere.
Jerboa prefers to avoid them.
After a few awkward incidents where Boa
tried to get someone to rescue her of all
the nonsense.
Her wings ache, and her head is fuzzy.
And that is the only reason Boa is able
to catch her unawares.
Jerboa doesn't realize what has happened
at first.
She is frozen, one step inside the
doorway of the cabin.
Literally frozen.
No part of her can move, and ice is
starting to travel rapidly up from her
claws.
She whips her head from side to side, and
finally spots Boa in the far corner
pointing something at her.
The porcupine quills.
Boa had gathered them all so carefully in
the mountain forest, then bound them
together with a length of thin vines.
She'd shown them to Draboa, proud and
sweet and asked for a new spell.
When I point us at my prey, she said.
I want them to freeze in place, so I can
catch them more easily.
Turboa had chuckled at her lazy, lazy
daughter, but she'd given her the spell.
Why not?
Boa hadn't asked for a spell in so many
years, and she'd been so good and quiet
and biddable lately.
Easier hunting was a harmless request.
Or so she'd thought.
What are you doing?
Jerboa says with a hiss.
She catches herself, and in a long pause
before Boa speaks, she tries pouring
honey through her voice instead.
Boa, dear, you've accidentally used your
hunting weapon on me.
Let me go.
It's not an accident, Boa says
trembling.
You're stuck now.
It seems that way.
Draboa says.
She's trying to remember the words of the
spell.
Does Boa have to say something specific
to release the prey?
The cold is crawling higher on her legs.
She tries to breathe fire on the blocks
of ice around her talons, but this is
magic ice, and her fire does nothing.
So now you have to listen to me.
Boa says.
I want you to tell me the truth for
once.
How many spells have you cast on me?
Turboa barks a laugh.
I couldn't possibly remember all of
them.
I've been trying to fix you for literally
centuries.
Boa's eyes go a little unfocused for a
moment.
Centuries?
She whispers.
Treboa tries to remember when the last
memory wipe was, but she's too cold to
think straight.
Yes, she hisses instead.
Nearly 11 centuries.
Three moons.
Boa presses her free talent to her eyes.
Why don't I remember that?
Turboa would shrug, if she could move her
shoulders.
Because you keep erasing my memory.
Boa answers herself.
That's why I get so confused.
That's why you keep talking about things
I don't remember at all.
Let's be fair, says Draboa.
You also have an uncommonly stupid
brain.
How would we know, Boa Flares?
Is any of it really me anymore?
She brandishes the quills at your boa?
I only love you because of magic.
She says, right?
You've been enchanting me to love you.
No, that's all real.
Treboa lies.
Silkier now.
If you love me so much, let me go.
She looks down at the ice that now
encases her legs and tail.
Her scales are so cold.
Her wings are raised slightly immobile
but the ice will reach them any moment.
It's not fair to make me love you when
you don't love me at all.
Boa angrily wipes her tears away.
I love you when you're not like this
Treboa points out.
You're exceptionally unlovable right
now.
Well, Boa says.
I guess we can fix that, can't we?
Just a little tweak here, a correction
there.
All you need is this, right?
She holds up an unrolled scroll.
Uh-oh.
Herboa spells.
She should have been more careful, kept
them all in her head the way she used
to.
But it was getting so hard to keep track
of them, and some of them were
complicated.
It was just easier to make an enchanted
scroll where she could write down
whatever she wanted to change about Boa
and it would happen.
Boba wasn't supposed to see it.
She wasn't supposed to get her claws on
it.
Where did you find that?
Treboa snaps.
More obedient, Boa reads from the
scroll.
Even more obedient.
Chew with her mouth closed.
Stop asking about talking to other
dragons.
Forget that other dragons exist.
Remember that other dragons exist and
stop asking inane questions.
Always let mother have the bigger fish.
She narrows her eyes.
This certainly explains a lot.
Treboa has never been so cold.
Guess what?
Boa says.
It turns out, anybody can add notes to
this scroll.
Watch.
She picks up Jerboa's quill. and writes
on the scroll, green, tail, bar, bah.
She says slowly as she writes.
Her tail barb turns a beautiful shade of
emerald green.
See?
Exciting, isn't it?
Boa writes on the scroll again.
Normal color tail barb.
And her tail goes back to normal.
Jerboa can't feel her wings.
The ice is up around her neck now.
She can't even move her head to look at
the rest of her.
But you know what I really want, Boa
says.
More than a green tail mother.
You might remember this, because I've
asked for it before.
More than once, I think.
Maybe quite a lot in all those memories
you erased.
I'd like to be an animus dragon.
No, never.
Turboa tries to cast a spell with her
mind.
She tries to rip the scroll out of Boa's
claws, but it only flutters feebly.
Oh, sorry to disappoint you?
For what?
The 8000000th time?
Boa says, as the quill snaps in half.
You actually can't stop me from writing
it down, because I already did.
She looks down at the quill with a smile
and it smooths back into one piece.
She's not going to save me.
Treboa realizes for the 1st time.
Not ever.
This isn't a negotiation.
It's a final performance.
Boa has freed herself from her mother's
spells.
She doesn't need turboa anymore.
These are my last moments.
After all this time.
She finds she's not as sad as she would
have expected.
She has lived or really, really long
time.
And most of it was quite delightful when
it wasn't irritating.
Goodbye, mother, Boa says, and she
actually looks much sadder than Jerboa
feels.
She's crying, but Jaboa doesn't know if
those are real tears, or ones caused by
the spell that makes Boa love her.
I only have a moment.
One last spell.
Not to save myself.
Just to make sure that Boa isn't as
triumphant as she thinks.
Something to ensure she never, never
forgets me.
She casts the spell on Boa herself.
Making her daughter, her last animus
touched object.
And then she has gone.
Chapter 22.
She is free.
She can't believe it.
Boa steps toward the block of eyes that
has her mother trapped inside.
It is fascinating to see her like this
through the bubbles and glaze of the ice
walls.
It's hard to see her expression, although
Boa will always remember the contorted
fury on her face.
I did it.
I tricked her.
I freed myself.
Finally, after all this time, longer than
she could possibly have guessed.
I'm the only jerboa now.
She hesitates, then writes in the
scroll.
Return all boa's memories.
Gently, she adds in a hasty scroll.
It still too much.
It's so much.
All the times they fought, and Jerboa
just flicked the memories away like bugs
so Boa would be pleasant again.
All the promises she made, and broke. with
a snap of her claws.
The conversation about making a brother
came back, and Boa clutched her stomach.
Did it ever happen?
Was there another damaged dragonette in
their past, or had she convinced her
mother and spared someone else her fate?
No brothers appeared.
No sisters either.
Boa was alone with her mother throughout
all the centuries of memories.
But there were servants here and there.
Dragons that Jerboa kidnapped and
enchanted.
Boa had loved some of them.
She would have run away with them if she
could have.
Her memories gave her no clues about what
happened to them when Jerboa was done.
Did she wipe their memories and throw
them back out into the world?
Or something worse?
All Boa could see were days where she was
happy. building sand castles with a rain
wing, or swimming with a sea wing, and
then the next day they'd be gone, along
with all her memories of them.
I have had friends.
I just never knew it.
Maybe she can cast a spell to find them.
Maybe some of them are still alive.
Maybe she can restore their memories, and
they'll be so happy to see her.
What if I search for them and find out
something terrible, though.
She's not sure she's ready to face every
truth about her mother right now.
And there are so many other less
traumatizing things she can do with all
her wonderful magic.
She can make everyone on the whole
continent be friends with her.
She can make herself queen of the kingdom
of sand if she wants to.
She has all the power her mother had, but
she's not going to use it to torture one
dragonette for 100s of years.
She's going to use it to be happy.
To have a completely different life.
But, 1st things first.
She needs to get this frozen monster out
of her doorway.
Boa touches the shell around her neck.
It gives her instant teleportation to
wherever her mother is.
The 1st spell Jerboa ever made at her
request.
That could still be useful.
If she puts her mother in the right
place.
She rests one talon, lightly against the
chilly ice wall, and looks through the
dark whorls to where she thinks she can
see her mother's eyes.
I enchant this block of ice to bury
itself under this hut and stay frozen
there forever.
The ice and her mother vanish, and the
hut shakes slightly, as though something
is settling in the sand below it.
But Boa doesn't even get a moment to be
thrilled.
Pain, lances through her sharp and
blinding, and she shrieks at the
unexpected agony.
When the 1st wave of pain passes, she
opens her eyes, gasping, and sees that
one of her claws is gone.
It's been sliced off as if someone took a
hatchet to it, and there is blood
everywhere, although the claw itself has
vanished into thin air.
What?
She whispers.
Did she cast the spell wrong?
Maybe she was accidentally touching the
ice block with that talon, and it took a
piece of her with it?
Or?
No.
No, no, no.
Somehow she knows.
In a space beyond knowing.
She can't see the shape of it yet.
She still has to figure out how and what
exactly this is, but she is certain of
one thing.
Her mother did this to her.
She is sitting by the fresh water pond
washing the blood off her newest stump.
Six claws gone.
When she has lost all of them, what will
go next?
Her ears.
Her horns, her tail barb.
Her wings, she shudders.
She has to be so, so careful with her
spells.
There's no way to know which one will
cause enough damage to kill her.
She lost her 2nd claw trying to heal the
1st one, and did only half worked.
The wound closed, covered over with a
shiny new layer of scales, but her claw
did not grow back.
She used a normal bandage on the 2nd
injury and thought for a long time.
Her 3rd claw, sacrificed for
information.
She enchanted a scroll to truthfully
answer any question she asked of it
through the pain, and the spinning stars
around her head, she made it tell her
what her mother had done.
One final curse.
She should have expected it, should have
enchanted something to protect herself.
But she'd had to move fast when she found
the boa changing scroll, in the piles of
bags her mother had forced her to carry
across the desert.
Her mother was so rarely careless, or
perhaps boa was rarely smart and alert
enough to catch her when she was, and now
Jerboa has left her this.
A last spell that was a masterpiece of
awfulness.
Every time Boa tries to use animus magic
she will lose a piece of herself, bit by
bit, until she dies of her wounds.
The spell specifies that the pieces could
not grow back, even with magic, and it is
reinforced, with words of binding that
mean there is no way to reverse it or
fight it.
Boa tried anyway, which is how she lost
clause 4 and 5.
It didn't seem fair that she could be
injured by spells that didn't even work.
Her mother learned a lot over the years
about what animus dragons could do to
each other, and how to word spells so
other dragons couldn't break them.
Boa remembers all the horror stories
now.
Everything her mother told her to try to
scare her away from animus magic.
But she'd never taught her anything.
Boa knows nothing about protecting
herself as an animus.
And I'm not a normal animus.
I'm cursed.
All right.
So, she can live without magic.
She is still free of her mother.
This is her chance to have the normal
life she always wanted, free in the world
meeting other dragons.
Maybe it wouldn't be the glamorous
enchanted whirlwind she'd imagined, but
it would be a 1000 times happier than her
life up to now.
She would be herself.
She would choose her own path.
She would be free.
At that point, she had looked at her
maimed talons and realized it would be
hard to walk into any dragon village and
make friends looking like this.
She'd have a lot of explaining to do.
So then, goodbye to her 6th claw, as a
new spell was added to the shell necklace
casting a glamour, so that she looks
normal and intact to any dragons who see
her.
No one will ever see what her mother did
to her, or know how much pain she is in.
Boa still has several objects her mother
enchanted.
And she knows what about half of them
do.
Her information scroll can tell her the
rest.
She might even be able to sell a few of
them to a queen somewhere if she dares to
risk it.
And if she's ever in danger.
One thought will bring her right back
here, to this hut by the ocean, to the
floorboards that cover her mother's grave
where she can dance and dance, and no one
will ever tell her to stop, or cast a
spell to make her fall over, or enchant
away her love of music for 100 years.
I hope you didn't die thinking you'd won
mother, she says out loud.
Because unlike you, I can control
myself.
I don't need to use my magic.
I'm going to be happy despite everything
you've done to me.
She spreads her wings and lifts into the
sky.
She is taking a break from other
dragons.
She does this occasionally, goes back to
her hut for 50 years or longer, until
everyone she's met, this time around, has
forgotten about her, and she can come
back as someone new.
It might have been longer than 50 years
this time, though.
Has it been closer to 100.
It's so peaceful on her beach, all alone
with the waves.
In the cities, around other dragons.
She is constantly tempted to use her
magic, even knowing the pain it will
cause her.
But here, she never thinks of spells she
wishes she could use.
She can just be.
She has one friend, a dragon who knows
the truth about her.
They met by accident before Glacier
became queen.
But glacier is not like other queens.
She believes in solving her own problems
and she knows how dangerous animus magic
can be.
She also knows.
The cost Turboa has to pay every time she
uses her magic.
Jerboa took off her glamour once, so
Glacier could see her as she really is.
She was surprised when Glacier cried.
No one has ever felt sorry for her before
or told her that it's not fair, everything
she went through.
In all the years they've known each other
even through the recent war, Glacier has
never asked Turboa for a single spell.
Once, Treboa asked her about that.
And Glacier said, You should save your
magic.
Someday, the world might really need it
and you'll be the only dragon who can
save everyone.
Treboa had laughed.
Me, like a hero?
Why not?
Glacier had answered.
Don't you think you're here for a
purpose?
2000 years was a long time to wait for a
purpose, Treboa thinks.
Maybe she'll have to invent one
eventually.
She is strolling down the empty beach
toward the water, thinking about what
kind of fish she'll catch for dinner, when
the universe suddenly crumples inward, and
an unfamiliar voice says, clear as a
bell.
Bring them here.
Every animus dragon in all the 7 tribes.
Bring them here to my throne room right
now.
And before she can think, or breathe, or
run, she finds herself standing in a
sunlit black marble throne room.
In front of her is the largest dragon
she's ever seen.
A night wing ice wing hybrid, menace
radiating off him.
He has his back to her, and as she
appears, 3 more dragons appear in front
of him, 2 sea wings, and another night
wing, all looking completely terrified.
Turboa doesn't hesitate.
Centuries of reacting to fear have
trained her well.
She is barely in the room for a moment
before she seizes her necklace and whisks
herself home again.
She is in her hut, her heart pounding.
Her claws sinking into the weathered
wooden floor. which she has replaced
several times over the years, but always
in the same spot, where her mother is
buried.
Thank you, mother.
For once, one of your spells has saved
me.
The magic has brought her home, but is
she actually safe?
Who was that?
And all those other dragons?
Are there really 5 animus dragons in
Pyria right now?
Didn't mother say the limit was one?
How is this possible?
She scrambles over to her trunk and
tosses everything in it aside to get to
our answers, scroll.
Tell me who that was, she says.
The riding goes on for a while.
The scroll is usually very concise, but
it seems to have a lot to say about this
dark stalker.
His past, his history?
He was alive back when my mother was, she
thinks, the spell that tucked him away
the mistake that freed him, the night
wings who follow him.
What does he want with animus dragons?
she asks.
To control them, the scroll answers.
To use their magic instead of his own, to
preserve his soul, and to be sure that
they can never be any threat to him.
Treboa shudders, feeling sick.
What if he'd been facing her?
What if he'd gotten his claws on her and
forced her to use her magic?
What if he found it amusing to watch her
slowly slice into pieces until she died?
I have to protect myself against him.
I have to cast something to make myself
invulnerable to his spells, or something
to make me more powerful than him.
She reaches for one of her copper
bracelets, then hesitates, struck by a
chilling thought.
Why did he summon all the animus dragons
right now?
Because his magic told him someone was
casting anima spells, and he was afraid
they might be against him.
She asks quietly.
He can tell when someone uses animus
magic.
Yes.
Can he sense me right now?
No.
His spell only searches for new
enchantments.
How can I protect myself against him?
That answer is not available yet.
She knew it would say that.
It can't see the future or tell her
what's going to happen.
It is sort of useless when she needs to
hide or make plans or, for instance, when
there's a big ominous magic user haunting
the land.
Once she tried asking it, How long will I
live?
And it answered, Until you die, which was
neither comforting nor helpful.
Maybe this is it.
Her purpose.
Maybe she's the only dragon empyrea who
can stop him, if she can come up with
just the right spell.
Is this my purpose?
She asks the scroll, knowing what it will
say.
That answer is not available yet.
I could kill him, couldn't I?
With one stroke of magic.
Or put him back to sleep under the
mountain, the way he was before?
Except.
If he's as old and dangerous and powerful
as her scroll says.
Has Dark Stalker protected himself from
other dragons animus magic, she asks.
Yes.
She stands up and starts pacing around
the hut.
The world is in danger, and there's
nothing she can do.
In a way, it's a relief because she would
rather hide here.
But it feels wrong.
It feels as though there should be
something if she can only think of it.
She is outside, recovering her fishing
nets before the storm destroys them.
When she sees a flare of golden fabric up
in the rain clouds.
She watches for a moment, and then sees
that it's attached to an unconscious
dragon.
The wind is blowing her into shore, some
ways south of Jerboa's hut.
Turboa holds the nets in her talons
thinking for a moment, and then she
hurries back inside.
Dark Stalker was defeated not long ago.
No thanks to her.
She did nothing at all.
She had the perfect spell, but she was
too afraid to use it, that it wouldn't
work, that it would backfire somehow, and
she'd be caught and lose all her freedom
again.
But she can't stop thinking about it.
Five animus dragons, all alive at the
same time.
It was so wrong.
The universe was out of joint.
Even with dark stalker gone, how could
the rest be trusted?
What if they turned on one another and
took the world down with them?
What if one of them found out about her
and forced her to use her magic?
What if any of them were like her
mother?
Or almost equally scary?
There's the new ice wing queen.
Turboa wishes she had met Snowfall in
time to save Glacier, but she didn't, and
now she's linked to this tempestuous
paranoid, terrified young queen who wants
to use Jerboa's magic all the time.
She has ideas upon ideas for animus
spells that will benefit her kingdom.
Or, at least, keep them walled off and
away from all other dragons forever.
Turboa doesn't know how many times she
can safely say no.
What if Queen Snowfall brings her army
next time?
What if she locks Jerboa up and tortures
her into doing magic?
She could be on a path to becoming
another queen scorpion.
Turboa remembers all those stories from
her mother very clearly.
She pulls out her scroll.
Who is the dragon that just blew in on
the storm?
she asks.
Her name is Luna.
She comes from Pantala.
The land across the sea.
Turboa's ears twitch.
A dragon from across the sea.
Why is she here?
By accident?
Is she dangerous?
Only to those who threaten the dragons
she loves?
Treboa likes the sound of that.
Is she my purpose?
That answer is not available yet?
Does she need help?
Yes.
Does anyone else know she's here?
A Nightwing has had a vision about her
and will be here to find her soon.
Treboa is a little nervous of night wings
at the moment.
But if she finds Luna first, if she
introduces them, she could be part of
something important.
Bringing the continents together.
Is that a good idea though?
Does Pantala have animus magic?
She asks.
No.
What if the animus dragons here decide to
take over Pantala?
They could do anything to them with all
that magic here, and none over there.
It's time to use her spell.
Time to fix everything.
Dragons can't be trusted with anima's
magic.
Jerboa knows that better than anyone.
She lifts a small glass candle holder
down from a shelf.
It's curved and glittering, and she loves
it, but sacrificing it will make the
spell more powerful.
I hereby enchant this candle holder, she
whispers.
When I shatter it.
I shatter the power of all current animus
dragons.
From now on, no new spells cast by any
animus dragon alive today will ever work
again.
Also, from this point forward, I will
grow old and die. like any normal
dragon.
I make this spell irreversible by any
animus, including myself.
She cuffs her talons around the candle
holder, then hurls it to the floor.
It explodes into a 1000000 shimmering
pieces, and your boa screams with pain.
Her tail barb is gone.
She guesses the price for such a big
spell was necessarily higher than all the
others she's cast, but it's hard to think
through the agony.
Turboa drags herself outside, trying to
stem the flow of blood and get to the
pond.
I didn't.
I think, I hope it worked.
She is in too much pain to test it by
trying another spell right now.
With luck, that was my last animus spell
ever.
Tomorrow, I will find Luna.
Bring her back here and keep her safe
until the night wing comes for her.
Then they can figure out how to unite the
continent safely, without any magic at
all.
And I won't have to be afraid of someone
controlling me.
I don't have to be scared of what animus
magic can do anymore.
And no one. will ever ask me for anything
ever.
Again.
Chapter 23.
Snowfall was awake before anyone else the
next morning, which surprised her, because
she felt as though she'd been asleep for
centuries.
For 2000 years to be more specific.
That was the 1st time her visions had
done that, dragged her from one into
another, on and on through someone's
lifetime, and then into a different
dragons, hopping through time.
But she understood why.
She needed to see all of that to
understand Treboa, her, Treboa, and what
she'd done.
She made a small pile of snow, and
started sculpting it into a shape while
she waited for length and her guards to
wake up.
The sun was only a thin line of gold off
to the east, and the morning air was
gloriously cold.
Everything was so quiet, so much quieter
than the noisy, rustling forest, or the
incessant background chatter of
sanctuary.
Jerboa broke animus magic.
Mostly because of me.
It's all gone because she was afraid of
what I'd make her do.
Snowfall knew there was more to it than
that.
She felt everything Jerboa had felt, and
she recognized it.
She knew so clearly what it was like to
be that scared.
She'd had her own nightmares about the
idea that someone else could take control
of you, and you'd be powerless.
The way Queen Wasp treated the Pentalon
dragons, or the way Dark Stalker had used
his magic against the ice wings and
against his own night wings and backed.
And she understood why Jerboa hadn't told
anybody.
Snowfall herself would have been furious
if she'd found out, even a few days ago
before the dragons arrived from Pentala
before I put on the ring.
Now, though, she realized she wasn't
angry at all.
She couldn't imagine being angry at
Jerboa anymore now that she'd experienced
a tiny bit of Jerboa's life.
And she wondered if Jerboa was right to
do what she did.
How could you be sure who could be
trusted with animus magic?
The 1st Jerboa had seemed like a good
normal dragon in the 1st vision, but the
magic, or the power, had obviously
changed her over time.
Maybe it's not so terrible, if we have to
figure out how to save the world without
magic.
She hoped they could do it.
The dragons who were on their way to
Pentala.
She'd do what she could over here
preparing her army, in case they were
needed.
And maybe soon she'd visit Jerboa, just
to check on her.
It seemed like she needed a friend.
That had never even occurred to
snowfall.
That Glacier and Jerboa had just been
friends, rather than queen and animus
dragon who served her.
That maybe Jerboa missed Glacier, as much
as Snowfall did.
Hey, Leng said, wandering over to her and
yawning at the same time.
What are you making?
She waved her tail at the little snow
creature.
Can't you tell?
Snfall asked.
Links peered at it.
I'm afraid I'll have to have you executed
if you guess wrong.
Snowfall added conversationally.
Add it to my treason list, Lang replied.
Is it a snail?
It is, Snowfall beamed at it.
In honor of that absolutely ridiculous
sky wing.
It is super cute that you keep thinking
about him, Links teased, and snowfall
through a clump of snow adder.
All your guards are awake, by the way, and
looking very embarrassed that someone
wasn't awake and on watch when you woke
up.
Snowfall shrugged.
I was tired too.
I mean, let's give them some stern looks
but I don't feel like decapitating anyone
this morning.
Links laughed.
On their way back to the palace, Snowfall
kept thinking about the 2 jerboas, and
the fact that the ring had actually
answered her question.
That was exciting.
Even if it had been slightly horrible to
experience the 1st Jerboa's gradual loss
of her soul.
Snowfall hoped she wouldn't ever become
like her, too far removed from other
dragons to remember that they had
feelings too.
I need to keep dragon cycle links close
by, to ask me things like, wait, is that
maybe evil, in case I forget to?
They swooped down through the gates, and
Snowfall waved the guards as she flew
by.
They both looked startled, and a little
nervous, but those were expressions she
was pretty used to seeing on her own ice
wings by now.
She'd work on that.
Low voices were coming from the throne
room, so Snowfall headed there first.
That was sort of suspicious, actually.
Why would anyone be in the throne room
while she was away?
Don't be paranoid, she reminded herself.
Not everyone is out to get me.
I am not Queen Wasp.
She swept through the window and landed
right in the center of the grand room.
Conversation slammed to a halt. all
around her.
On one side of the throne stood general
ivory, flanked by a few soldiers, looking
fierce and bristly.
On the other side were tundra and
permafrost.
Calm and gleaming and toothy.
And on the throne itself, wearing
Snowfall's hideous crown was her little
sister, Mink.
Snowfall raised her eyebrows at the
gathered dragons.
Hello, Mink, she said.
That's way too big for you.
Mink reached up and clutched the crown to
her head.
Her giant eyes blinking quickly.
We thought you weren't coming back, Tundra
said, in her slippery, well blubber
voice.
I said she was, Ivory growled.
You wouldn't listen.
We thought it was highly unlikely that
you'd leave a lonely soldier in charge
rather than one of us.
Permafrost smarmed, flicking his tail
between himself and tundra.
So, we assumed something terrible must
have happened to you.
You were wrong.
Snowfall said pleasantly, and now
something terrible is going to happen to
you.
Thank you for trying, Ivory.
Mink?
Budge over.
That's my seat.
No Mink yelled, bursting into tears.
I have to be queen.
I have to stop the awful, hateful
terrible, bad, night wings.
Snowfall squinted at her, then exchanged
a puzzled glance with links.
The what?
she asked.
The night wings.
Mink sobbed.
I hate them so m much.
They're going to hurt us.
Well.
So this made no sense at all.
Mink had never mentioned Nightwings
before, that snowfall could remember.
And Mink loved everybody.
It didn't even seem possible for Mink to
hate someone.
Let alone an entire tribe.
Was it something I said?
Snowfall tried to remember, but she
thought she would have noticed if she'd
said, the night wings are the worst, Mink
and Mink had said, yeah, let's hate
them.
Did you do this?
She asked tundra and permafrost.
Did you make her afraid of the night
wings?
Tundra lifted her wings.
We haven't said anything about them.
I don't know where this came from.
Snowfall was inclined not to believe her
but Tundra looked as confused as Snowfall
felt, and it was rare to see her aunt
have an actual emotion on her face.
When did she start talking about them?
The moment we made her queen, Tundra
said.
I mean, temporary queen, of course.
Just in case you weren't returning.
Uh-huh.
A queen you could control a little better
than me, I suppose.
Snowfall thought.
So where did Mink get this new fear of
night wings?
If Tundra hadn't said anything.
But somehow when she became queen.
Snowfall strode across the room and
knocked the crown off Mink's head.
Mink yelped and tried to grab for it, but
Snowfall held her at arm's length with
the crown in her other talon.
Aunt Tundra, she said.
What do you know about this crown?
When was it made?
It's been in the royal family for 100s of
years, Tendra said, sounding quite
scandalized.
It's one of the most treasured ice swing
heirlooms.
Yes, yes.
Snowfall said, but who made it?
Tundra looked at permafrost, who
scratched his neck and mumbled.
I'm not sure.
I believe maybe it's from the time of
Queen Diamond.
Snowfall said.
As in the one whose son ran off with a
night wing, was kidnapped by a night
wing.
Tundra objected.
The queen who happened to be an animus
herself, Snowfall said.
Correct.
Oh, length cried.
Tundra shot her a quelling look, but Lynx
ignored her, taking a step towards
snowfall.
You think the crown could be enchanted, to
make every queen who wears it hate night
wings as much as Diamond did.
But nobody knew it for all this time.
That's awful.
Permafrost flapped his jaw for a moment
as if a sealskin rug had come back to
life and started questioning his moral
authority.
It's true Queen Diamond was an animus, he
said, but, but she wouldn't just.
That is, she couldn't use her power
beyond her one gift to the tribe.
She wouldn't.
I'm sure of it.
Well, I'm not, Snowfall said.
And I don't like this thing anyway.
So let's be safe and fashionable and
destroy it.
Destroy it?
Tundra gasped faintly.
Ooh, we can do that?
Main gasp.
Because I really, really don't like it
either, Snowfall.
It's so heavy.
It hurt my head.
Did it hurt yours?
Yes, it hurt my head a lot, Snowfall told
her.
Ivory, would you take charge of
destroying this for me?
At once, Your Majesty, Ivory said, with a
respectful bow.
She lifted the crown out of Snowfall's
talons and flew out of the room with 2 of
her soldiers.
Snowfall climbed up on the throne next to
Mink.
It was big enough for a very old queen, so
there was enough room for her to scoot in
beside her sister.
She put one of her wings around Mink, who
snuggled into her side, closed her eyes
and sighed with relief.
I don't have to be queen.
Mink whispered.
You are not allowed to be queen right
now.
Snowfall said kindly.
I'm going to be queen for a long time.
Good, Mink said.
I'm sorry so many dragons keep telling
you what to do, though.
That was my least favorite part.
It'll be better if it's the rye dragons
snowfall said.
I just have to ignore the ones I don't
trust.
She shot a significant look at tundra and
permafrost.
The crown was magic.
Mink asked.
Does that mean I don't have to hate the
night wings?
That's right.
It was just a spell.
Snowfall bopped Mink's head with her
snout.
It'll wear off.
I feel much better about night wings
after being away from the crown for a few
days.
Plus, I bet if you meet any, you'll love
them immediately, just like you love
everybody else.
Oh, I'd like that, Mink said.
I love you the most, though.
Snowball laughed.
I met a sky wing, you would adore, she
said.
I didn't realize until right now that he
reminded me of you.
Your majesty, Tundra said frostily, as
the wall has been neglected for a number
of days, despite my best efforts.
Perhaps you would appreciate a few
updates about the behavior of the palace
ice wings in your absence.
Ah, yes, Snowfall said.
Thank you for reminding me.
Mink, want to see something cool?
I do, I do.
Mink sang.
A snowfall led her through the halls and
out into the courtyard.
Tundra trailed after them, protesting
that the queen needed more information
before she started rearranging names.
Permafrost had made themselves scarce
perhaps realizing that the farther out of
Snowfall's side he was, the fewer spots
he'd drop on the list.
There were several ice wings out in the
courtyard, gathered near the wall or on
benches, chatting to one another.
A hush spread through them as snowfall
swept by, and she saw a few starting to
edge toward the nearest doors.
Mink, Snowfall said, stopping beside the
gift of order.
Do you know what this is?
Of course I do, Mink said with wide
eyes.
Everybody knows what the wall is.
Look, there's me.
She pointed to her name on the dragonette
side.
I'm here.
Which means those dragons up there are
better than me.
But I'm still better than this dragon, and
this dragon, and this dragon, and this
dragon, and all these dragons, she said
tapping one name after another below
hers.
Snowfall winced.
It was somehow so much worse to hear
something like that from someone as
little and sweet as mink.
That's what I thought too, she said to
her sister.
But it turns out, that makes no sense.
It makes no sense.
Mink echoed, blinking up at her.
You might do better on a math test than
this dragon, Snowfall said, pointing to a
name below minx.
But what if he carves a better Isis
sculpture than you?
Then who should be higher on the list?
What?
Mink cried outraged.
But better than mine?
Where?
I want to see.
I just mean if he did, Snowfall said.
Hmm, Mink said.
Not possible.
But I love you anyway, polar bear, she
shouted, at one of the little faces
peeking out of a window overhead.
What I mean, Snowfall said, is that if
you spend all your time worrying about
where you are on the list, and who's
higher than you, and who's below you.
You can't focus on what you do well. or
how everybody can do something important
or kind or clever, no matter where they
are on the list.
And maybe you start to think the dragons
below you aren't as important or special
as you are, which is silly.
Hmm, Mink said thoughtfully.
She tipped her head up again and yelled
Polar bear.
I think you're very special and
important.
Thank you, he called back.
Snowfall wasn't sure this lesson was
going quite as well as she'd pictured it
in her head.
Maybe she should break stuff 1st, explain
it all later.
She called up the tiara's strength and
slammed her fist into the wall of names.
Cracks shot out in all directions, like
bolts of lightning, ripping through every
name on the list.
Tundra shrieked in horror, and tried to
grab her arm, but Snowfall shook her off
easily and did it again, and then again
smashing the wall until it was
obliterated, and she was surrounded by a
rubble of broken chunks of ice.
Whew, she said, into the cloud of
glittering ice dust around her.
That's better.
But, but, Tundra cried.
Snowfall realized that lynx was standing
between them, wings spread, to stop
tundra from charging at snowfall again.
Tundra seemed unable to move at the
moment, though.
She was staring at the space where the
wall had been, as though she thought it
might magically rebuild itself if she
stared hard enough.
Can it do that?
Snowfall gave the broken bits of eyes a
hard stare of her own.
They stayed where they were.
No sign of any magical rebuilding.
Don't even try it, ancient ice wall.
As the echoes died away, lynx started
clapping.
Mink immediately joined in, beaming
although snowfall suspected she just
loved clapping, and didn't entirely
understand the enormity of what snowfall
had done.
I just smashed centuries of tradition
into literal pieces, she thought, feeling
a little dizzy.
But then another ice wing started to clap
and another, across the courtyard.
Snowfall saw a few more at their windows
applauding, although she also saw some
older dragons duck out of sight when she
looked, as though they didn't want to be
caught with disapproving expressions on.
It's all right.
Eventually they'll see that it's better
this way.
The gift.
Of order, Tundra said faintly, and then
she collapsed into the snow.
Snowfall beckoned 2 of her guards over
and told them to carry Tundra gently to
her room and stay until she recovered, in
case she needed anything.
This is so exciting.
Mink said to Snowfall, scrambling over
and sitting on her foot.
What else can we break?
Can I smash something next?
Maybe tomorrow, Snowfall said, resting
one wing around her sister.
I'll let you wear my tiara and
everything.
Tonight, I think, I need to have some ice
cream and go to sleep.
Snowflakes were drifting from the gray
sky, covering everything in quiet
sparkles.
I love it when I'm right, Lang said.
Snowfall bristled at her.
Who said you were?
Maybe I smashed it for my own reasons.
I have many opinions that have nothing to
do with you.
Links gave her a sideways grin.
What?
Snfall said.
Did you mean something else?
Ride about what?
Links flicked her tail gently at
Snowfall's wings.
About you being the best queen ever, Madam
Spiky Face.
Oh.
Snowfall resettled her spikes and nodded
regally.
Yes.
Well, that is the plan.
Chapter 24.
She opens her eyes.
She is standing in the forbidden
treasury.
She can't see a light globe anywhere, but
the niche's glow pale blue, and the walls
glimmer as though icy fireflies are
swimming through them.
She is herself.
She is Queen Snowfall.
She feels that she is, but she holds her
talons out and turns them over, just to
be sure.
The opal ring is still there, on her
claw.
She took off everything else before bed
though.
The tiara and all her weapons.
This is her palace.
She is the queen.
And she decided she wasn't going to be
afraid all the time anymore.
But, She is having a vision, isn't she?
How can she be having a vision of
herself?
Because this is the last one.
Says a voice behind her.
Snowfall turns.
An ice wing is standing there, next to
the empty niche labeled Gift of Vision.
Even in the weird light, Snowfall can see
that she has unusual scales, like there's
a hint of another color beyond the white
in each one.
Like an opal.
The dragon smiles.
That's me, Opal.
Nice to meet you, Queen Snowfall.
Snowfall gives her a wry look.
I have a feeling I've been yelling at you
for the last several days.
Opal shrugs her wings elegantly.
No more than any of the queens who use
the ring before you.
Have there been a lot?
Snowfall asks.
Does every queen put it on at some
point?
Not everyone.
Obal answers.
It's enchanted to appear to those who
need it most.
Snowfall regards the ring for a moment.
So I needed it because We had to find out
what was happening in Pantala.
And make a connection with the scavengers
so they'd help us defeat Queen Wasp.
Opal laughs.
I'm glad you used it so well, she says.
But no, it's for dragons who become queen
before they are ready, to help them take
steps toward becoming even stronger
queens.
Snowfall raises an eyebrow at her.
That's a polite way of putting it, she
says.
But you mean it's for queens who are a
total mess. to teach them to see the
world through other dragon's eyes, so
they won't be so selfish.
Isn't that it?
We don't say that part out loud.
Oble admonishes her, but she's clearly
hiding a smile.
And you weren't a total mess.
Are you really here?
Snowfall asks, in the forbidden
treasury.
Just wondering how to find you so I can
throw you in my dungeon forever.
Opal laughs again.
No, I died a long time ago.
I created my one animus gift, and then
had a long, happy normal life as an ice
wing.
I just left a bit of my spirit in the
ring to keep track of the visions and
have this last conversation when the ring
has finished its work.
I can't believe your original queen
agreed to this, Snowfall says, holding up
her talon with a ring on it.
She fully did not.
Opal says.
Why do you think I made the enchantment
the way it is?
She became queen before she was ready too
and she was so scared, and furious all
the time.
She asked me for an animous gift that
would let her spy on all her enemies.
Both outside the kingdom and inside her
own tribe.
I made her this instead.
Wow.
Snowfall touches the opal lightly with
one claw.
I can't believe she didn't execute you
the moment she realized she couldn't take
it off.
That's probably what I would have done.
She adds ruefully.
No, you wouldn't have.
Oble says with certainty.
You would have thrown me in the dungeon
like she did.
And then, after a few weeks, if the ring
worked the way I enchanted it to, you'd
have forgiven me, like she did.
A few weeks?
Snowfall lifts her chin proudly, and
sweeps her tail across the floor.
I learned all my vision lessons in just a
few days.
Maybe you were closer to Reddy than even
you realized, Opal says.
Snowfall looks down at the ice below her
feet. and hesitates for a moment.
What if...
What if I'm not sure I am ready?
she asks.
Maybe I need a few more visions.
No, Obal says.
The ring is magic.
It knows exactly how much you need.
There's just one more you have to see.
Suddenly, she is standing right in front
of Snowfall and she rests her talons on
Snowfall's temples.
And then, Snowfall is.
Not snowfall anymore.
But her mother instead.
Queen Glacier is flying in from a meeting
with Blaise, thinking about what a
cheerful, brain dead goose that sandwing
is.
Below her in the courtyard.
She sees Dragonette's playing, and she
lands on one of the upper ledges to watch
them.
Three of them are her daughters, Crystal
Snowfall, and Tiny Mink, who tries to
keep up with the other two, but keeps
getting stuck in snow banks.
They're playing some kind of made up
game.
Glacier can't figure out the rules from
up here.
But it involves a lot of running, and
defending particular corners of the
courtyard, and snowballs are flying
everywhere.
Mink tumbles into another pile of snow
and snowfall grabs her, lifting her to
sit on snowfall's back.
Come on, we can't let them win, she
shouts.
She hurtles across the courtyard at
ferocious speed, even with mink clinging
to her shoulders, and tackles one of the
other ice wings before he can throw a
snowball into her corner.
She rolls over him, slides him back
toward his team, bowling 2 of them over
when he crashes into them, and leaps up
with her wings spread wide, to block
another snowball from another direction.
Back in the middle of the courtyard.
Crystal is standing still and yawning.
And is it time for lunch yet?
She calls.
No, Snowfall shouts back, fending off
another snowball, and flinging one of her
own into her opponent's face.
After this, you're going to quiz me on my
kingdom geography.
Remember?
Crystal sighs elegantly and wanders over
to the nearest bench.
If you say so.
The sun warms glaciers wings as she
watches them.
Her 3 perfect dragonettes.
Crystals, serenity, makes affectionate
loveliness, and snowfalls indomitable
ferocity.
She loves them so much.
She's already decided she won't fight
them for the throne.
Whichever one decides to challenge her
first, she'll step aside and let them
have it.
She hopes it's snowfall.
She loves them all, but Snowfall will
fight for this kingdom like nobody else
will.
She has them growing up to do first.
And Glacier hopes to pay more attention
to her after the war is over.
But even now, watching her, Glacier can
see what a great queen snowfall could
be.
Bing Queen is not easy.
Glacier is often exhausted, frustrated
confused, uncertain.
She worries for her tribe all the time
and she has inexplicable nightmares about
night wings.
She has to work hard to seem confident in
front of the tribe.
The crown would be too much.
For crystal or mink.
It would crush them.
Glacier knows perfectly well that the
same is true of Blaze and the Sandwing
Throne, but she plans to be a strong ally
to help her hold it, if Blaze can get
herself together and win the war.
But snowfall is strong enough to rule a
kingdom and do it well.
Glacier is sure of it.
Snowfall earns her place at the top of
the dragonette side of the wall day after
day, and she struggles, and cares, and
tries, and fights, and that to the ice
wings need.
We're going to be all right.
Glacier thanks.
Feeling her shoulders relaxed for the 1st
time in a while.
Watching snowfall fills her with hope.
No matter what happens.
I'll be able to leave the tribe in the
right talons.
The courtyard faint away.
Snowfall wipes the tears from her snout.
Thank you, she says to Wopal.
I just made the magic, Opal says with
another shrug.
You had to walk the visions.
She holds out one talon.
And now, you're done.
Shouldn't I keep it a bit longer?
Snowfall asks.
So I can see what happens to the dragons
who are going to Pantala.
It doesn't work that way, Oble says.
The gift of vision serves its purpose, and
then it disappears again.
Until the next dragon comes along who
needs it?
Snowfall slides the ring off.
She can't believe how easily it moves
after all those days of wrestling with
it.
Now it feels too big again, wobbling
around her claw.
She gives it to Opal, who puts it back in
the empty niche.
Dark eyes slides across the hole, and the
words, gift of vision vanish, until the
ring is completely hidden.
Good luck, Obal says with a smile.
Snowfall woke up late in the morning.
She'd finally had a real night to sleep
in the royal bed despite the tiny snuggle
monster who'd climbed in beside her
during the night.
Mink was still asleep.
One wing flopped over snowfall's snout.
The ring was gone, which didn't surprise
her.
Stupid magic, she thought, but didn't
really feel.
She would miss the visions she realized.
A little bit.
She preferred being herself. always
snowfall, but it felt oddly empty to
think she'd never get to walk in someone
else's talons again.
Mother believed in me after all.
She didn't just choose me because she
couldn't have crystal.
She thought I was the right choice.
Snowfall moved makes wing off her face
and rolled out of bed. outside the
window.
The sun was up, and ice wings were
darting through the sky.
Each one catching the light like a flying
star.
Beyond them, snowfall could see the ocean
all that moving, glittering water between
here and the lost continent of Pantala.
Lynx was out there somewhere, flying to
meet the rest of the dragons whose talons
held the fate of the world.
I hope they survive.
They better survive.
Or I'm going to be so furious at them.
I hope they stop Queen Wasp and a breath
of evil.
I hope I see Skye and Ren again.
And send you on cricket, and all the rest
of them.
I hope we're doing enough to save the
world.
Epilogue.
Raven crept through the tunnel, listening
for any sign she was being followed, but
she couldn't hear anyone behind her.
The darkness pressed in like panther fur
brushing the hairs on her arms.
But she knew the path to the abyss well
enough to navigate without sight.
And as she got closer, She could see the
dim green glow that came from its
depths.
She could also see the skeletal figure
that huddled by the edge of the glow.
He crouched so close to the terrifying
drop, it made Raven dizzy.
He didn't turn toward her.
His eyes were always fixed on the chasm.
Fall, she whispered.
I brought you food.
She set her little bundle down as close
to him as she dared.
Then stepped back, out of reach.
It had been a long time since Vol threw
someone into the abyss, but that was most
likely because no one else dared to
approach him anymore.
Only Raven, who came, even though it was
forbidden, and his brother, Mole, who was
allowed to keep him alive, but never
allowed to speak of him.
Can you hear it?
Bull said, in his shivery rasp of a
voice.
He still didn't look at her.
He never did.
I think so, Raven said, sitting on one of
the rock formations.
I mean, I hear something, but I don't
know what it's saying.
Do you?
The whispers reached the upper caves
winding like long, clinging spider webs
around the people of the village.
She knew they could hear it too, from the
way they flinched, or hunched their
shoulders, or hurried away from one
another.
But no one would talk about it, except
Mole.
It's growing, he said softly.
It's reaching.
Soon it will be now.
But it needs.
He trailed off.
Needs what?
Raven asked.
Suddenly, Bull whipped his head around
and met her eyes for the 1st time in
years.
Raven jumped and nearly fled back into
the dark.
His eyes were nothing like they'd been
when he was just her friend's funny older
brother.
Now they were haunted, and overlaid with
a green shimmer, and they seemed to look
right through her.
It needs a dragon.
He hissed.
A dragon?
Raven curled her fingers around the rough
edges of the stone below her.
Any dragon?
She wanted to run away, screaming.
But if something was changing in the
abyss, Vol would be the only one who
could tell her and she had to know.
You must find the dragon, Bull said, and
now his voice was like the crawling cave
centipedes, 1000s of them, with 1000000s
of scuttling legs crossing her skin.
Bring it the dragon.
Save the village.
Wait, Raven said, as he turned back
toward the abyss.
What does that mean?
Save the village.
From what?
Find the dragon.
Roll said, leaning toward the glow.
Bring it here.
He let out a long, slithering breath that
twined around the whispers from below.
Or everyone you know will die.
A guide to the dragons of Pentala.
Hive wings.
Description.
Red, yellow. and or orange, but always
mixed with some black scales, 4 wings.
Abilities, vary from dragon to dragon.
Examples include deadly stingers that can
extend from their wrists to stab their
enemies, Venom in their teeth or claws.
A paralyzing toxin that can immobilize
their prey.
Others can spray boiling acid from a
stinger on their tails.
Queen, Queen Wasp.
Silk wings.
Description.
Silkwing dragonettes are born wingless
but go through a metamorphosis at age 6
when they develop 4 huge wings and silk
spinning abilities, as beautiful and
gentle as butterflies, with scales in any
color under the sun, except black.
Abilities. can spin silk from glands on
their wrists to create webs or other
woven articles, can detect vibrations
with their antennae to assess threats.
Queen, Queen Wasp.
The last Silkwing Queen, before the tree
wars, was Queen Monarch.
Leaf wings.
Description.
Wiped out during the tree wars with the
hive wings, but while they lived, this
tribe had green and brown scales, and
wings shaped like leaves.
Abilities.
Could absorb energy from sunlight, and
were accomplished gardeners.
Some were rumored to have unusual control
over plants.
Queen.
Last known queen of the leaf wings was
Queen Sequoia, about 50 years ago, at the
time of the tree wars.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 14, The
Dangerous Gift, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Jack Heidelman, executive
producer Melanie Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of Scholastic Inc.
Text Copyright 2021 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production copyright 2021 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.